and the nozzle so as you're saying
there's a bunch of different design
options but it's a critical part of this
yeah how you do that conversion which is
basically like how much can you convert
is really like the ultimate game how
much pressure and heat can we convert
into thrust like that's really at the
end of the day that's what a rocket
engine is
the following is a conversation with Tim
Dodd host of the everyday astronaut
YouTube channel where he educates and
inspires all of us with detailed but
accessible explanations of Rocket
engines and all things space travel
this is a Lex freedom and podcast to
support it please check out our sponsors
in the description and now dear friends
here's Tim Dodd
can you give a brief history of SpaceX
Rockets so we got Falcon 1 Falcon 9.
there's different versions of those
Falcon heavy Starship and also the the
Dragon castles and so on well uh yeah
Falcon one is where it all started the
original intent and the original idea of
of SpaceX was Elon wanted to try to get
something to Mars you know um he saw
that NASA didn't have a current Mars
plan
and he wanted to go to Mars so he
decided how do I best do this
um he literally wanted to at first
purchase a rocket from from Russia uh
then on the after a foiled attempt at
doing that he decided he was going to
try to develop his own rocket and the
Falcon one is what came out of that
process and he developed a pretty
incredible team like I don't know how
exactly he's stumbled upon the team that
he stumbled upon that quickly but the
people that he assembled were amazing
and they built the Falcon one which was
a single Merlin engine followed by an
upper stage engine called the Kestrel
engine
um pretty small compared to the things
they're working on today with that
Merlin engine continued to evolve uh
into being the power plant for the
Falcon 9. they went from a small lift
launch vehicle up into the medium-class
launch vehicle so they could provide
services for NASA
um that's one of the big things they
first kind of hung their hat up was they
got the opportunity to fly cargo to the
International Space Station under um
originally it's called the cots program
the commercial orbital transportation
services uh for NASA which evolved into
the commercial resupply contracts and
that's when SpaceX developed both their
Dragon capsule which is a uh uncrewed at
first uh spacecraft that conducted the
ISS and the Falcon 9 rocket that can
take it to the International Space
Station and the dragon rides on is the
thing up top that rides on the big
booster thing that's uh that launches it
into orbit exactly yep so the Falcon 9's
the the semi truck the dragon capsules
the payload you know it's the thing
being dropped off basically at
assassination in this case the
destination is the International Space
Station
um and uh yeah so they developed those
relatively quickly and uh became a
commercial success before you know it
they're now the number one launch
provider in the world launching more
mass to pay to orbit than anybody else
launching more frequently than
um countries like the entire country of
China who's going crazy right now with
launches granted China beat them by two
launches this last in 2022 but
prior uh prior year SpaceX beat the
entire country of China I mean it's it's
nuts and just like you said the SpaceX
still beats China even this year in
terms of the amount of payload those
though so
yeah the mass the orbit right that uh
China had like 60 something a couple
more uh launches but the there was just
like small cubes that type of launches
exactly some of them are literally like
100 kilograms or something you know like
not not large payloads Bissell SpaceX
customers are different different so
whoever wants to send payloads up into
space yes but right now their biggest
customers actually themselves with
starlink with Starling one of the
biggest reasons they've launched so much
mass to Orbitz because starlink has
designed around the payload Fairing and
the payload capabilities of the Falcon 9
rocket so you know because they're
vertically integrated because they build
their own satellites because they're
building their own rocket they can
literally design a system that's you
know another manufacturer might have
made a more Square satellite that was
heavier or something but SpaceX looked
at it from a blank slate and said here's
our constraints our payload Mass
constraints are volume constraints and
they made a funky looking satellite
things like the size of a you know it's
like a table folded up which isn't
anything I've you know really ever seen
before so but it's purpose built to fit
as efficiently as possible inside their
Fairing and inside the capabilities of
that rocket so therefore
because they're launching those like an
insane amount you know a dozen you know
40 50 times a year or whatever
um they're uh they're just putting up
insane amounts of mass like we've never
seen before what about the different
versions of Falcon 9 before so we can
Linger on them what are some interesting
memories to you of the different
developments in Falcon 9. the very first
Falcon 9s had a square uh array of
engines it had like a three by three by
three grid of their Merlin one engines
the 1DS and um I think it only lasted I
don't remember if it was two or four
flights before they went into this
October configuration where um there's
eight like a ring of eight engines with
a center engine in the middle
um still in the same diameter that the
rocket was the fuselage was more or less
the same 3.7 meter wide diameter but the
the actual thrust structure changed and
one of the big efficiency gains was you
no longer have you know a corner engine
and then like a edge engine and then
another Corner engine you can just make
eight of the same you know kind of part
of the OCTA web it's called uh you know
the same shape and then the your
interchangeability and your
manufacturability becomes a lot simpler
so that was kind of one of the bigger
upgrades at first and they kept
stretching it every time they like
touched this thing it got longer and
like or taller and taller technically
um and then the next big feature that
you saw uh in 2014 would have been they
added Landing legs to a Falcon 9 rocket
which was I was at that was the first
launch I ever went to was actually to
see
um it was crs3 so commercial resupply
mission three and it was probably there
God I don't remember what that was like
their 14th or 15th launch or something
like pretty early on
um and people were literally laughing at
the idea of them putting Landing legs on
it they just thought it was stupid
they're like why are they wasting why is
this billionaire Elon Musk guy wasting
his time trying to
land a rocket it's not going to work so
you said the Mars planet was there in
the beginning uh what about the
reusability of rockets
was that there in the beginning
I think reusability definitely you know
it's it's a necessary part of making any
kind of interplanetary
Mission you know in order to actually do
that just financially you have to start
reusing these things in terms of the
development of the Falcon 1 and falcon
9.
how early on did the uh goal of reusing
the rocket having the rocket actually
land how early did that goal creep in I
I can't speak for Elon in SpaceX but it
was pretty um you know immediate they
wanted to try to recover and as a matter
of fact I think the very first two
Falcon 9 rockets and Falcon one I think
they even wanted to try to recover uh
using parachutes to recover the first
stage
um and it now fast forward you know
almost 20 years later and Rocket lab is
actually doing a concept like that where
they're uh pulling a parachute after the
first stage is re-entering and they
actually are trying to recover it with a
helicopter he's gonna try to snatch it
out of the air they've actually done it
they've actually done it successfully
once how does the helicopter grab the
the rocket with this giant like drag
line and a hook oh and then literally
just like grabs snags onto the parachute
wow and it's pretty amazing and but this
is a small rocket their Rocket's only
about a metric ton that the booster is
empty so the rocket releases parachutes
yep like really high up I'd love to see
this yeah that's an interesting idea
there's so many interesting ideas and
possibilities like SpaceX basically just
innovated
a lot of different weird ideas just in
in the pursuit of making things more
efficient reusable
um all of that so basically thinking
from first principles how to solve this
problem and so what you find is like
you'll get all these kind of crazy kind
of solutions and with SpaceX they
weren't even getting to the point of the
booster surviving re-entry long enough
to be able to pull the parachutes yeah
you know they're Mass fractions you know
and in that varies
every single Rocket's different you know
all the you know for instance rocket lab
uses carbon composite fuselage and tanks
um or you know same thing and that's
very very lightweight has really good
Mass fractions and therefore they're
drag coefficients and things like that
they were able to survive re-entry of
the first stage which is something that
SpaceX wasn't able to do at the time
um what's what the kind of the big I
think breakthrough for SpaceX with
reusing the booster is they uh they
realized we have to basically slow down
before we hit the atmosphere so they
actually do what they used to call a
re-entry burn which I still think is the
correct term because it is re-entering
the atmosphere but now they call it the
entry burn and they light up three of
the nine Merlin engines uh not only to
slow it down but actually even while
those engines are firing it creates like
a a literal like force field as it's
falling through the through the
atmosphere interesting and uh but it
also decreases the velocity by almost
half or around half and then that
therefore decreases the amount of you
know the biggest thing with the
atmosphere is that as it gets compressed
against the front of any anything flying
through the atmosphere the compressed
atoms just get hot and they can get so
hot they turn into a plasma and they get
so hot they can just absolutely destroy
anything so they slow down enough that
the air molecules don't end up you know
destroying the vehicle on re-entry and
then they then they realize I think at
some point there's probably a similar
crossover they're like well if we're
lighting the engines already to slow
down in the atmosphere we can just use
that same engine to land and so like
well what if we just stuck Landing legs
on it and just landed the thing
vertically and next thing you know is
December 21st 2015 they did exactly that
for the first time so you were there
before that then right yeah yeah from
2014 yep early 2014. so that and for me
like that was so fun watching you know
that was like the peak of me just
becoming obsessed with uh with this idea
I'm watching with like and back in the
day it was like months between launches
you know so a launch was like a big idea
I'd wake up at 3am to watch this Landing
attempt or whatever you know and every
you know there's crs4
um almost almost landed crs5 almost
landed crs6 crs7 blew up I was watching
that on I think it was like a Saturday
morning or maybe a Sunday morning and I
remember watching that and watched it
blow up and I was like oh my God now
what you know and it blew up on Ascent
it was their first failure
um so it was their 18th flight I believe
crs7 the upper stage um had a uh one of
the butler's bottles inside the tanks
that are filled with helium and one of
those bottles broke off on ascent and
actually just completely over pressured
this the upper stage and the upper stage
blew up and the whole rocket went kaboom
uh in an uncontrolled manner
and so uh so then they came back with
vengeance when they came back the first
mission back is the first time that they
landed a rocket which was awesome so
they returned to flight after the
anomaly was was uh yeah was was Landing
a rocket and stuck The Landing yep well
actually the first time so the first
time you were there what was that like
what do you remember from the from that
day just I was surprised at how much
bigger the rocket was than I imagined I
was I originally when I was going down
to Kennedy Space Center I was
disappointed that I wasn't seeing like a
you know I didn't know a ton about
Rockets I knew enough to like know what
a space shuttle was what like the Saturn
V was you know but that was probably
about the end of my knowledge I just
remember being disappointed that I
wasn't seeing a big quote-unquote NASA
rocket flying you know I was thinking in
my head like oh I'm gonna see this
launch it's probably gonna be like you
know three stories tall or something you
know just some little skinny little
stick and
some little firecracker and yay you know
and I think I'd almost impitched that
too I think the the people that I was
working for at the time I think they
kind of were downplaying it it's like
well it's not a big Rockets here it's
not gonna be that exciting you know but
we get out there to the pet and I'm like
this thing's huge this is not a small
rocket like this is It's you know it's
70 meters tall 220 feet tall it's huge
um and I think people forget like the
scale of that you know it might look
skinny and tall and all this stuff but
it's still a very very large piece of
Machinery it's physically about as as
large as you can ship the boosters about
as big as you can ship across the
country period without like completely
shutting down highways you know it is
made within those exact specifications
of of like having you know Lane
Privileges and bridges and everything
it's you know 12 feet wide 3.7 meters
wide and it's 45 meters long so it's
like exactly what you can fit uh with a
pretty standard you know like before you
start getting into crazy amounts of
problems shipping the rocket and it's
huge it's huge and people just don't
understand that and so when I saw it
with my own eyes I remember just being
like this is so much cooler than I
thought it was hard to believe that that
thing is gonna have to lift off the
ground and launch up into the air maybe
that's the most humbling aspect of it
that's something that size humans have
come up with a way to take something
that size and launching launch it up
into the air yeah there's certainly a
very humbling aspect when you watch it
actually leave was was there a sound to
it was there like a feel what are the
different experiences do you first
remember well ironically I didn't end up
getting to see that one fly oh I went
home my camera saw it I left my camera
out there like a remote triggered camera
uh my first image is as a launch
photographer at the time was it was crs3
but I went home it scrubbed too many
times this is back in the day they were
scrubbing like often and there'd be like
a three day five day seven day you just
never knew so I go home and I watch the
live stream of it so I didn't even get
an experience my first launch and any
anyone that's ever tried to you know go
to a launch is can probably empathize
because yeah scrubs are very common in
the space flight world so that one I
didn't get to see but since then
obviously I've been able to attend very
many launches uh how much do you
understand the control involved in the
landing how difficult is that problem I
couldn't tell you a single thing about
like the code and like the avionics
behind it but I can tell you all the
hardware that makes it happen if that
helps well that yeah I mean to me it
seems like whenever I talk to people
they say it's not
that big of a deal in terms of the the
level of intelligence and the control
but to me it's just like when you
observe it
it seems incredible because of all the
variables evolved all the uncertainties
involved all the
um because there's aerodynamics I mean
like there's at different temperatures
there's so so much going on with the
fuel the burning of the the combustion
just everything that's going on to be
able to do perform control at such high
stakes effectively like you know that
code is probably not written in
JavaScript I guess is what I'm saying
actually no I don't it if I remember I
again this is well outside of my domain
um but
um they've coded in a Common Language
it's it's uh that's probably it's
probably going to be c yeah I'm pretty
sure it is and that was one of the
things that was weird is that Elon when
he you know started SpaceX was like
we're just going to code in the most
common language so that we don't have to
like have people learn this archaic you
know weird thing we can just literally
pull people off the streets and be like
here write it you know and that's
probably C plus plus I mean it'd be epic
if it was like python or something but I
don't I I think like reliable systems
have to be written in CC plus plus
probably which is a common language
which is something uh I imagine like
NASA Engineers would probably have to
use some kind of proprietary language in
the in the olden days for for security
for privacy all that kind of stuff oh
and the old old days like yeah those are
inventing Yeah the code and language
from scratch
uh for sure it was still it's just still
incredible that it's able to do that
like just the feat of engineering
involved is just it's truly
it's like one of the Marvels to observe
about these Rockets coming back to Earth
uh that they're able to land like the
drama of it is just incredible to see
yeah well the one of the fun things to
remember too with specifically with the
Falcon 9 and the Falcon 9 or Falcon
heavy boosters I mean it's the same
thing basically
um they shut down all but one of the
nine engines and even with that one
engine at its minimum throttle setting
it's still too much thrust to hover
so as this Rocket's coming down
if they start a little bit too early if
they light that engine too early it will
actually stop above the ground and will
not be able to lower itself it will
literally stop like say and stay say
stop 200 feet above the ground
their only option is to kill the engine
and then it's just going to fall those
200 feet so they it's what we call like
a suicide burner a hover slam kind of
interchangeable terms because your
thrust to weight ratio is never below
one so they have to actually literally
be riding the throttle so what you do is
you kind of start ideally you know you
kind of start like in the middle of your
window of of throttle range so let's
pretend your engine can throttle down to
40 of its maximum rated thrust you might
start at like 70 percent of thrust in
the middle of that like window of where
it could burn so that so if all of a
sudden it's kind of coming in too hot
you have room to throttle up if you're
coming into you're actually you know a
little too early you throttle it down
you have a little bit of wiggle room
it's just amazing how smoothly and how
perfectly they're able to still control
that thing even though they're down to
one engine out of the nine and they're
still riding like the finest margin of
what's possible and they're they're
continually playing with that to try to
get it because every every bit of fuel
they're using and proponent they're
using to land is proponent they weren't
using to put something into space yeah
so they want that to be as efficient as
possible they're really like watching
them hone that in and and just continue
to evolve it and edit that and just get
it to be the Workhorse we're coming up
on a hundred consecutive Landings
perfect Landings 100 I think they've
done like 150 something Landings
altogether 160 altogether but we're
talking like in a row without blowing up
which you know five years ago was
completely experimental and insane and
now we're coming up to the point where
we're 100 in a row it's like this is
becoming more reliable in the landing
which is not the primary Mission this is
purely for spacex's like gain is to
recover the booster it has nothing to do
with the effect of getting the payload
on orbit you know most of the time and
the landing is really only for their
their benefit and their gain long-term
gain like it's a long-term investment in
in being able to recover the the
boosters 100 can you believe all this
was done in basically 10 years so that
we've seen this development over a
period of 10 years oh man so like where
we started uh commercial space flight
at scale to today where it's almost uh
almost starting to be mundane yeah how
can I be able to do yeah uh I I can't
really believe it I mean obviously even
just in the I I think I'm a fairly fair
weather fan really didn't start paying
attention to like 2014. yeah and just
seeing what it was like back then to
what it's like like I don't watch every
launch at all anymore like I'll catch
the big ones yeah I'll stream some of
the really big ones but like back in the
day I like I said would wake up in the
middle of the night to catch these
streams or you know catch these launches
and watch them because they were such a
big deal and there's maybe only five of
them a year you know and so it's a
really big deal nowadays it's like oh
yeah there's literally like two a week
on average now it's insane from SpaceX
alone
let alone you know United launch
Alliance rocket lab any of the Chinese
missions you know I mean all of there's
countless it's insane it's hard to
really really really hard to keep up
with I wonder at which point in the
future the number of uh launches to
orbit will exceed the number of launches
of airplanes
like on the surface of Earth yeah I have
to admit I kind of have a hard time
extrapolating out that far you know
there's a lot of people that are like
big futurists and really do think about
like interplanetary stuff and think
about colonizing Mars and stuff I have a
hard time predicting like when
starship's Gonna Fly the orbital launch
you know and that's like imminentish
like month or two scale time frame and
yet I'm still like I can't tell you when
that's gonna I can't tell you anything
about like when we're gonna land on Mars
or what that's what that economy and
what that you know the scale of launch
operations is going to look like in
order to do that because it's just so
hard to I wouldn't have predicted where
we're at today five years ago you know
it's it's insane it's so hard to predict
and
yeah but it's it's funny because there's
so many like new companies starting up
trying to predict that and it's a really
exciting you know startup culture right
I think uh when you make certain
engineering decisions
and hiring decisions and like what you
focus on in terms of both business and
Engineering it's good to think on the
scale of 10 20 50 100 years that's one
of the things that Elon has
exceptionally good at which is asking uh
the question okay this might seem
impossible right now but what's the
obvious way to do this if we look out 20
years and then you start to make
decisions you start to make decisions
about robotics about bringing computer
interfaces about space travel there they
make a lot of sense when you look at the
scale of 10 20 50 100 years and don't
make any sense if you if you look at the
scale of of just months so but of course
the actual work of day to day is focused
on the next few months because there's
deadlines there's missions they have to
accomplish anyway we uh returning back
to the brief history
Rockets
the Falcon heavy so what what else is
there so we talked about Falcon 9 and
the rapid development there yeah what
other flavors of of Falcon is there and
how does that take us to Starship yeah
realistically the Falcon 9 evolved more
or less kind of like just got more
powerful in a little bit longer and more
capable
but nowadays they fly What's called the
block five even though it's like the
eighth or ninth iteration of the of the
Falcon now but they call it block five
it's the one that has the black Landing
legs the black inner stage they have a
fleet of roughly 10 or so that are doing
the majority of the legwork these days
and they're flying you know up to 15
times I think right now is the current
booster leader they're also recovering
the fairing so the nose cone of the
Rockets are frequently if not every time
being recovered
um same with the same with the booster
for the most part and the only thing
being expended is the upper stage and
that's kind of where the Falcon 9 is
ending it's really doesn't make sense to
develop that infrastructure any longer
so they went with the next step which is
go even bigger physically so they have
more margin for upper stage reusability
and that's what we see with Starship and
super heavy so the super heavy booster
uh the whole system is confusing the
whole system is kind of considered
Starship but it technically the Starship
is just the upper stage which is also
like the spaceship which is also the
upper stage and then the booster itself
is considered the super heavy booster
and that's what they've been working on
uh publicly it came out in 2016 as the
at the time it was the its the inter
planetary transportation system uh later
in I think about 20 by the end of that
year 2017 it kind of became known as the
bfr the big Falcon rocket yes yeah
um and then I think it was about end of
2018 they started calling it Starship
but that is the that is where we're at
today and that's what their uh working
full steam ahead on and uh what about
dragon and we mentioned Dragon uh crew
Dragon cargo Dragon yeah so they went
from the cargo version of dragon that
flew about 20 times uh successfully to
the International Space Station uh
except for that one crs7 where the
rocket blew up in the capsule obviously
didn't make it to the ISS
um then they went into the dragon true
Dragon 2 which has two variants it has a
crew variant so we just call it crew
dragon and then there's the cargo
version of of dragon two
um and that's just an updated sleeker
sexier version of dragon and it's
ironically it's heavier altogether so it
uh you'll never see those those cool
return to launch site Landing the
boosters coming back to land for CRS
missions anymore like we used to but
they landed on the Drone ship anyway and
um and yeah that's been flying
successfully that's kind of the so
there's the starlink dragon Falcon 9
Falcon heavy and Starship system it's
kind of the whole
the whole SpaceX world really in terms
of the the spaceships involved so what
what do you are some of the major
milestones in that history we kind of
mentioned
a few yeah like in the landing is there
something that kind of stands out yeah I
would say definitely
um the big ones obviously like any of
the first like the first flight of
Falcon one first flight of Falcon 9
first time they went to the
International Space Station
um the first time they landed a booster
um the first time they reused a booster
which is I think about six months after
no oh it was a year after it was SCS 10
um
2017 it was the first time they they
reused one of those boosters you know
and that was a big milestone like can we
even yeah we recovered one we we caught
one you know it's like we got one now
what
um that was the first time they reflew
one
um yeah then flying humans was a huge
one dm2 Bob and Doug
um for NASA
that was incredible you know that was
that was a huge huge step I think for
SpaceX was flying people so it's this
first major commercial
launching of humans out into space yeah
and not just into space because you know
there's been people that have done you
know space flights with you know like
sub-orbital hops but going into orbit
and especially docking and rendezvous
with the International Space Station is
a it's a big deal it's a whole it until
you really understand the physics
involved in the scale involved with like
just crossing the karma line going
straight up versus going into orbit like
they're just completely different things
almost what about uh Starship are we oh
are we in a place where we can talk
about Milestones with Starship has there
been or has it just been an Epic Journey
of failure and successes of testing and
and so on was there like even yeah what
would you classify at this point as uh
as a milestone a Starship or bfr
whatever the name is I was able to
achieve well so far the Milestones we've
seen I'd say the first one would be the
Hop of they call it star Hopper and it's
basically a very rudimentary rocket but
it was the first time they they utilized
their new Raptor engine to produce
thrusted to fly something
it first flew like literally like three
meters off the ground or something like
Tethered to the ground then it flew like
15 and then finally it flew 150 meters
um and that was in 2019 and that was the
first big milestone of of Starship and
then after that we saw uh sn5 sn6 kind
of do the similar like 150 meter hops
with a little bit more elegant systems
you know proving out more of their their
tank building proving out more of their
you know a lot of just subsystems and
then the big ones physically were in uh
end end end end of 2020 and early 2021
when they flew the uh sn8 9 10 11 and
15. what is the n stand for in SN I
think just serial number yeah these are
just names numbers numerical
representations of the different testing
efforts they skipped some numbers right
yeah if they if they scratch uh a test
yeah and lots of times it'd be like
literally they're building you know
because at Starbase and it what SpaceX
is working like the one foot is always
in front of someone else's foot and like
the arm is not knowing what the leg is
doing sometimes yeah they they will have
someone working on you know they'll just
be like hurry up and build 40 of these
tank sections and you build the bulkhead
and you build the downcomer and you
build the header tank blah blah and all
of a sudden like oh we actually evolved
that we don't use that header tank now
so it's going to go on to this one so
they'll have like parts of certain
Rockets built in fact ask literally
scrap it like not scrap it like in the
you know joke term but like literally
just go scrap it and they uh so yeah
they just evolve and iterate so quickly
there was some epic explosions
um I think Starship something about it
uh probably just the amount of fuel just
leads to some epic epic failures oh yeah
probably would you say Starship is the
source of the most epic failures in
terms of size of explosion so you can
literally measure in like a yield of
explosive power you know like like you
could TNT like you can take a look at uh
how much repellent is left over at the
at the time of the explosion and you
know Starship what's flown so far even
though it's physically one of the
largest flying objects ever uh just with
the Upper State alone they've not filled
it more than like 10 or 20 percent full
of propellant yeah and so it actually
hasn't been the the failures have been
really epic looking uh big visual
Fireballs but in terms of space flight
they're still pretty small explosions
believe it or not they could still go
bigger yo yeah a lot a lot and of course
the test payload of a Tesla Roadster was
launched um I forget what year that was
yeah that's 2018. that was quite epic
would you put that on a milestone oh
yeah yeah Falcon heavy demo was like
definitely a a big big big milestone
yeah is that funny to you that there's a
roadster floating out there yeah we know
the location of that Roaster at this oh
yeah where is roadster.com yeah oh yeah
where's is it orbiting something yeah
it's orbiting the Sun it's orbiting the
Sun and its orbit is basically between
the Earth's orbit and Beyond Mars so I
think of like 2.5 Au if I remember right
so it's it's beyond Mars's orbit and its
highest point and it's back at Earth
kind of in its lowest point I wonder if
there's a mission where you're going to
somehow connect with it once again and
like Place extra things into it I wonder
how challenging that is technically oh
yeah it could it could absolutely be
done
um you know the hard thing at this point
because it's on an eccentric orbit would
be rendezvousing with it because you
kind of have to be in alignment with its
orbit to really line up well with it
yeah um but yeah I mean someday I don't
see any reason why we couldn't at least
send for sure an uncrewed you know felon
wanted to just fly a a robot out there
to check up on it and photograph it or
something like we could that could be
well within the realm of things and get
an uh Optimus uh robot up there
uh so that was the story uh brilliantly
told by you of the Rockets uh for SpaceX
what about through the lens of engines
can you give a brief history of the
SpaceX rocket engines that were uh used
that we haven't covered so you mentioned
all started with the Merlin engine and a
custom engine what
um yeah through that lens yeah what's
there the engines are relatively small
number which is which is easy for us
there's either Merlin and Merlin's
evolved throughout time to be from like
the Merlin to the Merlin one seed and
Merlin 1D to the Merlin 1D full thrust
and all these other kind of tweaks of
the same architecture uh Kestrel ended
with Falcon one
um they also have the Merlin vacuum
engine which is the upper stage engine
for Falcon 9. same relative uh system
but just optimized for vacuum so it has
a much larger Bell nozzle there's the
Draco thrusters which you know you kind
of can consider engines well they are
rocket engines but they're just small
they're not like the orbital engines
there's these super Draco engines which
are the abort thrusters on on crew
Dragon capsule and then nowadays they
have the Raptor engine and the Raptor
vacuum variant but they've already had
two versions of raptor we've already
seen kind of the Raptor development
engine
um it kind of seemed like a raptor 1.5
whereas kind of taking hints of the
future Raptor but now we're well within
the well within what you'd consider a
Raptor 2 variant
and that's really it yeah for the uh the
Raptor maybe I'll ask you that
separately but I like in general and
people
who doesn't know whoever the astronaut
is but if you don't somehow know go go
go check his uh your YouTube channel out
you're an incredible educator about the
the super technical and uh the more sort
of even the the philosophical the actual
like the the actual space travel so you
go down to the raw details of it and
there's just great videos on the Raptor
engine
um
I think you have one on Merlin uh and
and also actual tours with Elon where he
discusses some of those things I'm one
of the tourists he says uh he's full of
good lines that guy uh he says something
about uh the number of fiddly bits
and he's uh the number of fiddly bits
was decreased between Raptor two and
Raptor one yeah and I I think that's
actually a really beautiful
representation of um the engineering
efforts there which is constantly trying
to simplify oh yeah increase the
efficiency of the engines but also
uh simplify the design so you can
manufacture it and in general
simplification leads to better
performance and testing you know and
everything so the number of fiddly bits
I'm sure there's a Wikipedia page on
that now as an index is actually a
really good one well and when you think
about it I I don't know of any other
company prior that had kind of try to
measure their performance of their
engine not and like thrust to weight
ratio or like how efficient it is like
in specific impulse but literally in
like dollar to thrust ratio like how
much does this engine cost how much
thrust can it produce and like using
that as a trade study instead of just
like pure metrics of you know because at
the end of the day like okay if it's if
it's cheaper and does you know x amount
of work even if it's less efficient it
can actually be better long term
and so I guess another way it's not even
just thrust I don't know if that metric
is used but basically the cost of
getting one kilogram
of thing up into space yeah that's
basically what they're trying to
minimize especially yeah at the end of
the day that is definitely the ultimate
metric is how much does one kilogram
cost to orbit eventually you know and
but there's it's so funny because
spaceflight is just the ultimate you
know it's the ultimate compromise every
little thing any variable can just
change everything else so you can tweak
so many different things to get to
different numbers and conclusions you
know but even things like on your first
stage when you're when you're the
Rocket's pointing straight up and the
engines are pointing straight down
you're dealing more with the thrust to
weight ratio of the rocket so how much
thrust is it producing versus how much
is gravity pulling down on it is
actually a more important metric than
how raw efficient the engine is so it's
funny then in space it's kind of the
opposite thrust to weight ratio doesn't
really matter uh what really matters is
the actual the specific impulses color
like the the nozzle escape velocity of
the or the injection velocity of the how
fast is the gas moving it's like the
more important number on or orbit but
it's it's just so crazy because there's
all these like I would just love to see
the trade studies you know when you're
like trying to figure out like is this
more important than this or this or this
and it's like you change this one little
thing also you know like all the
everything changes it's just even the
profile like the launch profile the
trajectory of it the I mean everything
I wonder what that trade out discussions
are like because you can't really
perfectly plan everything so and you
always have to have some
spare leeway on on you know especially
as you're testing new vehicles like
Starship yeah so Origins are important
yeah having having a margin given all
the uncertainty that's there yeah it's
really interesting like how they do
those kinds of trade-offs because
they're also rapidly designing and
redesigning and re-engineering
and uh the ultimately you want to give
yourself the freedom to constantly
innovate but then through the process of
testing
you solidify the thing that can be
relied upon especially if it's a crude
Mission yeah that how to do that in a
rapid cycle I I remember at some point
that NASA as they're leading up to
Flying humans for the first time for
NASA
um you know there's some talk that like
we're gonna do a design freeze because
SpaceX does evolve and iterate so
quickly you know they were saying that
it was leading because especially at the
time it was a mission called emo six and
they lost a rocket they've only lost two
rockets like ever really as far as um
you know trying to get something to
space for the Falcon 9 sorry
um and the second one ammo 6 I mean that
was back in 2016 so it's it's been a
long time and uh but at the time you
know they're looking at flying humans in
the near future
and it's like if you guys keep tweaking
this thing every time you take it out to
the pad really it's gonna be a problem
you know and so there's some pressure
from NASA to kind of slow down on that
iterative process
and uh but that is also why they were
able to evolve the Falcon 9 to be what
it is today is because they did just
evolve it so quickly literally like one
after another was never really the same
and we're definitely seeing that with
Starship now like it's
evolves so quickly that you just can't
even keep up with it you know so there's
a fascinating culture uh Clash there
have you just in observing and
interacting with NASA folks seen them
sort of grow and change and evolve
themselves sort of inspired by this new
development in commercial space flight
oh yeah yeah there's a lot of especially
like around dm2 there's a lot of talks
in the press conferences and stuff where
you'd hear people say you know this was
a big this is well outside of our
comfort zone to work with SpaceX in this
manner because we're we take this
approach to things where X Y and Z in
this in this way the way we normally
certify things and we're not used to
SpaceX like well let's just try it you
know like and and do something you know
to a point and so they they said it
ended up being fantastic they loved
working that way because it was just
less paperwork almost and more just do
and
um and but at the same time SpaceX I
think even expressed I don't remember if
it was Hans koenigsman or someone in a
press conference said well we really
liked having someone just double check
us so that we're not doing something
super stupid right before we test
something you know
um so there was a cool collaboration
because it is uh two very different
philosophies of uh of development and
managing you know space programs I
wanted to talk to you a lot about
engines
and maybe about Starship and maybe about
your own becoming an actual astronaut
but like let's just go there uh before
all that and and talk about the actual
culture of SpaceX and uh your
conversations with uh Elon you've toured
SpaceX facilities with him you've
interviewed him you've interacted with
him
uh what have you learned about Rockets
about propulsion about engineering about
design about life from those
interactions he's pretty transparent
open human being as an engineer as a as
a leader as a person
I would definitely say the biggest
takeaway I've had from my times with
Elon at SpaceX is
real like the the idea of questionnaire
constraints he says that a lot but he
also does it a lot like he though you
know there'll be times where like
you'll see him change on a dime because
he's like rethinking of something in a
newer different way and for me you know
I I think we all put constraints on
ourselves we think about our own limits
you know on
on things that we can or cannot do and I
think it's made me kind of question like
well why am I why did I say no I can't
do that or you know uh you know just off
the top of my head a good example uh I
so in Iowa I live in Iowa or half the
time or whatever and uh there's a bike
right across the state of Iowa called
Ragbrai and every year you just you know
like thousands of people get together
and they they ride across Iowa and it
was last summer I met up with some
friends and like hey you want to go on
rag bar this year I'm like it's like a
week away they're like yeah you want to
go I'm like yeah and so I did without
and it was one of those moments where I
was proud of myself because like I it's
easy to just be like no you know I'm not
ready or this is my constraint is like
I'm not in shape but like just question
that you know and and so I think when it
comes down to questioning your own
constraints it's yes even to that level
like why do you question yourself on
what you can and cannot do so that's for
your personal life is really powerful
but a little bit more intuitive I think
what's really hard is to question
constraints in a place like Aeronautics
or or robotics or autonomous vehicles or
Vehicles because there's
people there's experts everywhere that
have done it for decades and everyone
admires those experts and respects those
experts and you for you to step into a
room and knowing not much more than just
uh what's in a Wikipedia article yeah
and to just use your intuition and first
principles thinking to disagree with the
experts that takes uh that takes some uh
guts I think well you can't have
everyone doing that either you know like
there has to be some humility of knowing
that something is a hardened concept and
a hard you know like especially I'm not
an engineer I don't I don't do this
stuff you know but I can imagine you
sitting there having spent six years on
a type of valve that perfectly manages
crowdog propellants or whatever and
someone walks in and says why don't you
put a heater element in there you know
or something that's you know something
like because probably you know we've
done that 40 times whatever whatever you
know like I'm sure there are things like
that that are very frustrating but but I
know what that's like you know the thing
is with the experts they're always going
to be frustrated
when the Newbie comes in with their
first principles thinking but sometimes
that frustration is Justified and
sometimes it's not sometimes just
stubbornness for failing to acknowledge
a better way and I've seen it both
directions so which is really
interesting so you need you need both
but that tension is always going to be
there and there has to be a almost like
a dictatorial imperative that breaks
through the the expertise of the way
things have been been done in the past
to push forward like a new way of doing
it and elon's done that um I've seen a
lot of great Engineers uh do that in the
Machining machine learning world because
there's been so much Development I've
seen that happen usually when there's
like rapid development that starts to
come into play yeah and yeah and I've
seen that autonomous vehicle space
bringing computer interfaces that Elon
has evolved with all of it it's kind of
fascinating to watch
um what about the actual design and
Engineering of the engine since you've
learned about so many different kinds of
engines over the past few years
just like what stands out to you about
the way that engineering is done at
SpaceX or that Elon does engineering the
hardest thing to
kind of remember is like how much stuff
was developed in the 50s and 60s you
know the the concepts finally being
utilized today were already literally
done in the 60s yeah you know so a lot
of the things that SpaceX is doing isn't
a novel concept per se you know they're
like for instance the Raptor engine
utilizes the full flow stage combustion
cycle engine
and that was already developed by the
Soviets in the 60s for an engine called
the rd270 and it's makes sense like on
paper 100 it makes sense because you're
basically extracting the absolute
maximum
potential of the chemical energy in both
propellants
and you know at the at the end of the
day like you have to be dumb enough to
say we're going to try using this thing
because it's actually really complicated
to to do what they're doing but at the
same time like sore so are Rockets like
rocket engines are already stupid
complicated so adding you know 10 20
more you know pain in the butt during
the r d if it's you know in the long
long long 20 30 year existence or
whatever you know like future of that
engine is that going to be worth it
obviously SpaceX said yeah I think we
can actually develop this this Raptor
engine so it's just interesting to see
the things that have been looked at or
even reusability you know like the space
shuttle was reusable it was fully uh the
upper stage you know the shuttle itself
the Orbiter was you know I mean that
thing was for all intents and purposes a
reusable rocket
now did it live up to its expectations
not necessarily so it left a lot of bad
taste in people's mouth on the the ideas
of reusability so for SpaceX to kind of
come back into the room and on the table
and say we're going to use the reusable
rocket specifically we're going to do a
fully reasonable rocket you know a lot
of people are even still the day a lot
of people going
yeah you're not gonna be able to do that
even today even today so like long term
you're not gonna be able to reuse a
scale
yeah but yeah definitely I think the
number of people that are saying that
today is is a small portion of those
that were saying that type of thing five
years ago you know when Elon did that
announcement in 2016
um for the its it was very very
aspirational and people were just like
yeah right you know and there's a large
number of people that had the factual
reasons to to think that and do that you
know um at the time they'd only landed
like two Rockets or something you know
when they did that or maybe three it was
a very small number uh when they
announced that actually they had just
lost a couple months prior they just
lost mo6 so they like they were still
this young blossoming company and they
come in and be like we figured out
reusability and now we're gonna go full
scale make the world's biggest most
heaviest most powerful rocket ever and
we're going to fully reuse it and it's
gonna go to Mars but it's just pretty
out there like it really was and yeah
you know it's all about perspective but
now again we're coming up on 100
consecutive Landings of an orbital class
rocket that's you know 45 meters tall
3.7 meters wide like this thing is huge
weighs 20 metric tons even empty when
it's Landing that thing's already huge
so seeing the success of that I think
people are now more like well okay maybe
maybe there is actually
the opportunity to be fully reusable
that's definitely probably the biggest
constraint that I think has been
questioned that is yep and then of
course like the broader one of cost of
bringing down costs uh
that he's able to you're able to kind of
bring down costs so much the this
something like colonizing Mars our many
trips to Mars will be a possibility
because yeah people don't even it seems
so far out that they don't even have
time or give effort to questioning it
yeah but it's the implied questioning
can you really do that many launches
actually do it can you actually do it
yeah it's looking I think it's one of
those things where you look at the curve
you know you look at like 10 years ago
that was ridiculous yeah following this
curve if SpaceX goes from you know two
years ago launching I don't remember
what it was 40 times to 60 times to 100
times this year is there is there amount
and if we just keep extrapolating that
out if they maybe not that exponential
maybe it goes more linear or whatever
what's 20 30 years like the amount of
stuff we can put on orbit and and the
potential we have to do things like
absolutely now I don't want to put a
time frame like you know yeah I think
but you gotta think it's it we're
increasingly number of launches we're
increasing the amount of things in space
we're increasing the amount of payload
on orbit that's probably not going to
decrease anytime soon and therefore
eventually like the idea of going to
Mars is absolutely reasonable let me ask
a difficult question that needs to be
asked here
can SpaceX continue uh its successes
without Elon
this long-term Mission to Mars
I I think the discussion about Tesla and
autopilot or Robotics are in your link
with main computer interfaces is a
question wholly separate from the SpaceX
question because there's a lot of other
competitors
doing
um some different but amazing
engineering that Tesla is doing and both
autonomous vehicles semi-autonomy or
full autonomy and obviously in vehicle
design and electric vehicles there's a
lot of people that are doing incredible
brain computer interfaces but while
there is a lot of competitors to SpaceX
and we'll talk about many of them
they're doing amazing work it seems like
he's really driving progress here over
the past 10 years what do you think
about that
okay the first thing I think
to remind people is just how many
brilliant people do work at each of
these companies obviously yes you know
elon's had the some of the best teams
assembled ever just incredible people he
knows this he he will gladly tell people
and he says it often like the amazing
people the amazing teams here so it is
important to remember that
um that being said like there is
something to elon's
just super far forward not taking no for
an answer on things approached and and
almost to his dismay I think
he is afraid of the sunk cost fallacy so
much that it almost almost gets to the
border of like being you know like throw
out everything before it's even we've
we've known or not but the same time
like it moves the needles so fast so far
so as far as the question of would
SpaceX continue to like succeed and be
able to ultimately go to Mars without
Elon the Mars thing I think would
probably be hard to uphold without I
think a lot of that drive for Mars is
from Elon
um it is maybe too Fantastical for the
average person and the average employee
and maybe the average CEO that might
step in to have a company's Mission be
to go to Mars like it's just or even
governments yeah clearly because like
you said the Mars plan was non-existent
for NASA yeah still really there isn't
much you know so
I I think if how many people I'm sorry
to interrupt how many people are talking
about it's obvious that we need to
become multi-planetary right there's not
a
there's the Mars society and like
serious leaders of engineering uh
efforts yeah or nations and so on yeah
which it does seem if you think about it
that it it's obvious yeah and the grand
eventuality it is obvious of the of
human civilization this whole human
experiment we have here we should be uh
expanding out into the cosmos 100 so I
think the big mission if we're measuring
SpaceX spacex's success on getting to
Mars or not I think they'd have a really
hard time
um continuing to fulfill that drive
without Elon at the helm
um now I think there's a certain balance
and beauty of Elon specifically when it
was Tesla and SpaceX where Elon will go
in you know have mild tornadoes around
the factory and the the engineering you
know and like mix everything up and and
things get sometimes just totally thrown
together you know and and totally just
like get it done just to to get it done
and start moving that direction and then
he'll leave and go do that same thing
you know at SpaceX or Tesla vice versa
and then there's a little bit of a calm
where people come back in and they fill
in those gaps you know and I think
that's kind of always been a pretty
healthy thing honestly is like I think
if he is too focused on on any one thing
it almost is like a spin too much you
know like it's like like too many
tornadoes yeah too many tornadoes and
and I think it could almost be like you
need someone to come back in and like
you know like backfill almost because
I've heard definitely stories of like
like well probably a good a good example
would be last
um last well was that last year two
years ago 2020
two yeah was that yeah or no 2021 they
did a the First full stack of the
Starship super heavy and they called it
the big surge all of a sudden like
thousands of SpaceX employees you know
came down to Starbase and they just
started building like you wouldn't
freaking believe I mean it's just things
going crazy it was actually in the
middle of that first interview I did
with him was in the middle of that surge
there was like commotion like you
wouldn't believe you couldn't hardly
talk because there's just so much going
on people just welding and blah blah you
know everything they did during that
period was basically scrapped
because it was just not done very well
but
they got a fully stacked Starship rocket
out on their launch pad
you know and it it said it I think at
some point you kind of have to stabilize
some things enough and just say like
this is what we're doing to catalyze
some things and say now do this it's
almost like do it for fake not do it for
real almost it's funny because through
that time because I had a lot a lot of
conversation with them I think that
process was hugely stressful there was a
sense I don't know where that sense is
today but there's a sense that Starship
is going to be very hard to pull off
yeah that's still borderline impossible
to pull off and then and that was really
weighing heavy on him and the team and
everybody yeah so like to have this
chaos of development is fascinating yeah
big time and I think they really had to
push
you know if they hadn't done that if
they hadn't done that big push
you know we might only be now seeing a
rocket stacked for the first time
um you know it might be a lot more
finished rocket a lot more High Fidelity
a lot more flight worthy rocket finished
and and stacked but
um and they might not have to walk stuff
backwards but the same time like you do
have to in this world you do have to
push really hard uh to make rapid
iteration and Rapid change in progress
so it's it's interesting I don't know so
lingering on that another
a question I I really should ask you
because of you've seen
you've been in awe of the amazing
development
of space travel technology over the past
few years what do you think about Elon
buying Twitter
so in this perfect balance optimized
reallocation of tornadoes throughout uh
the various efforts in human
civilization uh do you think do you
worry about his involvement with Twitter
I mean personally I just I I see that as
a lot less important than and personally
for me inspirational than Starship and
you know the work done at SpaceX and
Tesla to me those were two very
uh impactful and really really just
generally like you know they're uniting
like you know something to Rally around
get excited about rally and just like a
future look forward to yeah
um you know the idea of we're gonna be
building the world's most powerful
biggest rocket ever and it's eventually
going to be able to get humans on Mars
for the first time and we're going to
transition the world into fully
sustainable awesome just totally badass
cars that do all these cool things to me
those were like that brought a sense of
unity and a sense of like we can do this
personally I just don't think that a
social media no matter what it is I
don't see that in a social media and I
don't I don't see
um any sort of politicking as ever
anything that's really every uniting
thing I understand that I totally agree
with you especially space how inspiring
it is I have to push back I do think
the impact of social media
the basic level of uh
meaningful connections of this
collective intelligence that we call
human civilization through the medium of
you know digital communication which is
social media I think that can have a
huge impact it could be the very vehicle
that increases the inspiration that
SpaceX doesn't and all different uh the
thing I've criticized them a bunch for
is like why bring politics into this uh
so the political the political divisions
that we see on Twitter feeding them
It's Tricky
um It's tricky to sort of understand
what is the value of that what is the
contribution of that to uh to this whole
effort with God going on so there's been
a that that's been a big challenge but
that said like again this tornado
the number of tornadoes and social media
I think is really important because
social media has such a huge impact on
on us as a society and to have a
transparent
um have a bit of turmoil
you know it's like Tom way says I like
my town with a bit of Drop of Poison
with a little Drop of Poison so like a
little bit of that
um shake things up I think might be
really healthy I just worry about the
long-term impact down the whole Mars
project through that and so but you know
what
uh this life one of the reasons that's
fun is uh
through the chaos you like none of us
know how it's going to turn out and hope
hopefully we try to help each other to
make sure it turns out well and and this
really isn't like anything about my
personal like politics or anything like
that but really just generally any of my
friends that are like the first thing
you hear about them in their day is
something that happened in politics or
something that some world leaders doing
or not doing or saying and not saying
I just don't find that to be the most
important thing really
um I I know that obviously that can
affect a lot of people that has big real
world consequences politics do
but like I just re and this is just me
I'm such a like he'll come together you
know Cheerio kind of guy
that I just really think like you need
something bigger than bickering about
what you know what people said and did
and what they've voted on and all this
stuff to really push Humanity forward
like I you know I know that politics and
and their and and by extracting that
social media can affect things like
space flight and even our like planetary
defense like be able to defend ourselves
against asteroids like if politics has
their way and everything goes to crap
and we don't even get to you know yeah
we're not going to be able to you know
continue space flight and things like
that but like I don't know I just think
there's better ways to do it and more
uniting ways to do it than
than you know what feels like a mature
name calling sometimes you know yeah I
think the political bickering that most
people talk about that that's on top of
most people's minds is the thing they'll
be completely forgotten by history it
has actually very little impact yes
politics matters but like one percent of
it I think most of it is just
political bickering the push and pull of
the red team and the blue team and the
and then it the uh the news media that
feeds off the division for the attention
and it's just like a fun athletic event
almost with the blue team and the red
team so 100 for that you kind of have to
have a historical perspective on it like
most things
uh will not really have a significant
impact and we should focus on
development of science technology
engineering which is the thing that
grows the pie 100 this is just this is
what the economists know well yeah which
is the Innovation the engineering that's
what actually makes everybody richer
yeah it's kind of political bickering is
just eating the pie and not just richer
but it improves their lives you know we
can look at every modern technology that
is bestowed upon us today air
conditioning electricity internet access
fresh clean water running water blah
blah blah you know 100 years ago so many
of the things that I listed either
didn't exist or were only accessible by
the ultra wealthy you know and it's
through the innovation of Technology and
Engineering and education that we're
able to
have it be that even someone below the
poverty line and most of the developed
world will have a good number of those
things in their life um and that's just
continuing to increase and continue to
get better
so I I think yeah that's to me that's
in the grand scheme more important but
um to each their own
speaking of amazing technological
development uh you have uh you have a
few videos on this but how does a rocket
engine work
uh you've you're wearing some of the
instruction manuals but uh for one one
type of it like what what's the fuel
what are the kind of types of different
rockets that you can kind of give an
overview yeah ultimately a rocket engine
converts
um high pressure and heat into kinetic
energy like that's the only real job of
a rocket engine is to take uh high
pressure gas hot high pressure gas I'm
very energized there's a lot of energy
involved and then literally turning that
into
molecules shooting in One Direction into
kinetic energy
so um yeah what you do basically you
know I mean the simplest version of it
is of course like famously a balloon you
take a balloon you fill it up with air
you've got a pressure you let go of it
uh some of the air shoots out in a
general direction-ish you converted that
pressure into kinetic energy now if you
start scaling that up you know you can
continue to do something like that like
um cold gas Thruster would be kind of
the most simple and easiest rocket
engine to make would be a cold gas
Thruster and all that is you literally
just take air or specifically nitrogen
because it's a little bit more dense
than all the others or you know and it's
the majority of our atmosphere
um you can uh or sorry it's more sparse
you can condense that down shorten a
really high pressure bottle and then uh
just literally shoot it through what's
called a d level nozzle which is
something that chokes the flow a little
bit gets it to be
um takes it and gets it into supersonic
speeds once it's at supersonic speed you
actually can't choke it down anymore
you'll just constrict the flow of of
mass flow constrict the airflow so you
actually go opposite you start making it
wider and once it's already at
supersonic speeds if you expand it and
make it wider it actually gets faster
and faster so at first you know when
it's subsonic gas you start shrinking
you can strict the flow you know it's
actually speeding up just like you know
a highway if you go from you know or any
of these examples like a water hose you
you know if you pinch it down you want
to flow the same amount of water from
point A to point B through a smaller
pipe you can you can flow more water or
the same amount of water from point A to
point B with a smaller pipe it just has
to go faster so obviously you can
constrict it but at some point you
actually get to a physical limitation
and that happens to be the speed of
sound once it gets to the local speed of
sound
you can then actually do the opposite
you actually expand it back out and
you're continuing to convert
um the the pressure into velocity at
that point but it's now Supersonic and
what's interesting is while you're doing
that you're actually cooling it down too
each each bit of that pipe that you're
making wider and wider and wider you're
cooling down so the more heat energy you
have to work with the more work you can
actually do so at some point a hot high
pressure rocket engine is the best
source of like that's the ultimate
amount of work you can do and the nozzle
so as you're saying there's a bunch of
different design options but it's a
critical part of this yeah how you do
that conversion which is basically like
how much can you convert is really like
the ultimate game how much pressure and
heat can we convert into thrust like
that's really at the end of the day
that's what a rocket engine is so you
have to have a powerful enough rocket
engine to actually lift the rocket and
we'll rocket is mostly just fuel it's
like 90 90 plus percent just the weight
of fuel so you just have to lift the
fuel that's going to take it
uh you know into orbit and that's the
thing specifically for Rockets you're
just saying generally rocket engines but
for the task of going to orbit you're
Fighting Gravity Earth gravity which is
fundamentally different than moon
gravity or yeah Mars gravity yeah uh or
like you said traveling out the space
Earth has a pretty intense
gravity it's to overcome we're lucky
because if I think if it's ten percent
either way like 10 harder it'd be like
oh we could still do it you know we'd
still be with our current technology
we'd still be able to get stuff into
orbit man things like reusability and
this you know commercialization the
success that we've seen in the last 10
years it would just be on two thinner
margins I think 10 easier and we would
have been like I mean it's just like
totally different it's so much it's so
much easier it's like this big you know
sliding scale and 10 in either direction
we'd be either screwed or really happy
you know as far as getting in his face
so it's just hard enough that it things
like fully reusable becomes very very
very difficult I think it's completely
achievable we have all the pieces to
make it achievable does not disobey any
laws of physics it does not disobey any
there's no like hard to stop through
it's just very very very hard and so
ultimately yeah like on Earth for the
first bit of launch again when the
Rocket's pointing straight up and it and
the engines are pointing straight down
pointy end up play me and down you're
Fighting Gravity and so that's kind of
your biggest enemy outside of the
Earth's atmosphere too so what kind of
uh sources of fuel is there so this
chemical Rockets liquid solid gas hybrid
uh there's electric so what what are the
kinds of fuels we're talking about what
are oxidizes what what can you just
explain your shirt I guess
yeah
the components so uh so really I mean
fuels it's there's kind of two terms
we'll you'll generally hear the word
propellant being used is anything that
is used to propel a spacecraft or used
in a rocket engine so
um you have to have you know you can
have a fuel here you have to have a fuel
you have to have an oxidizer and you
have to have a spark to actually get
those things burning and that's just a
general law of like the universe you
have to have fuel and oxidizer and a
spark
um now some fuels will by themselves
spark like hypergolic fuels But
ultimately you're always left with some
kind of fuel oxidizer in a spark so um
the the general ones used most often in
Rockets liquid oxygen is kind of the
king of well there's better oxidizers
but they're extremely extremely hard to
work with like fluorine
um but the generally liquid oxygen so
you just chill oxygen down too it's
liquid state minus 183 degrees Celsius
so it can be dense enough to store in
tanks you know it's a thousand times
more dense when it's in a liquid than it
is as a gas
rp1 which is basically kerosene is a
very common fuel
another common fuel nowadays is methane
liquid methane liquid hydrogen is
another it's the most efficient
potential for the most efficient since
it's one of the lightest molecules so if
I think correct me if I'm wrong but
Falcon 9 uses kerosene and then a
Starship uses methane because methane
yep for fuel and they both use liquid
oxygen for their oxidized for the
oxidizer okay yep
um but then you know if you get into
hypergolics you'll normally have
nitrogen tetroxide which is your
oxidizer and some form of hydrazine
for your fuel
there's solid rocket propellants like
solid rocket boosters and those are
actually pre-mixed your oxidizer is
inherently like baked literally like
kind of baked into the sludge of of fuel
so like for SpaceX it's all uh chemical
liquid fuels yep yep so how many solid
base uh fuels are there is that are they
still being used today is there most
Rockets yeah and the United States
really is the only ones that well the
only ones I guess early on because it
was really just the Soviet Union versus
the United States the United States
started to use solids pretty early on uh
they're simple and easy but these days
like you know you'll still see them kind
of as traditionally like boosters like
they're used to just uh help get
something off the ground or help give it
a little extra boost
um so the space shuttle famously had
those two huge white solid rocket
boosters attached to the orange fuel
tank those are solid rocket repellents
um things like the atlas 5 can have up
to five smaller solid rocket boosters
there's very few rockets that use a Pure
uh at least these days they use a Pure
solid rocket motor for its first stage
um there still are especially in China
there's a lot of startup rocket
companies that kind of use just missile
technology you know they might use like
a they might just be a variant of an
ICBM
um that just use solid rocket fuel
because it is very relatively easy to
develop you know model rockets use solid
rocket Motors and stuff like that so
they're they're still around but they're
just not as elegant and not as uh yeah
not as as used these days so uh what are
rocket engine Cycles again I think
getting more to you towards your shirt
question you have a really good video
called that I mean a lot of your videos
that are technical are just
exceptionally well done so I just I
think
um
you deserve all the props you get I mean
thank you for for doing this work really
really really really really well done uh
so it's called rocket engine Cycles how
do you power a rocket engine and you go
through all the different options is
there something you could say about uh
open cycle close cycle full flow
um all the different variants that you
can use words to explain yeah without
all the pretty pictures yeah without the
pretty pictures so ultimately you know
like we said we your ultimate goals you
want to get heat and pressure into an
engine so obviously at some point you
can either make really thick tanks of
your rocket you can like get it so thick
that you store the propellants at really
really high pressures but obviously like
that doesn't scale very well at some
point your Rocket's so heavy you can't
even leave the ground or you know it's
just so much of your mass is just
literally the walls of the rocket so at
some point people realize hey we could
actually just pump the fuels and the
oxidizer into the engine at a high
pressure and increase the pressure
through a pump now obviously a pump is
going to require energy you have to get
that energy from somewhere
um and again at some point people were
like well Rockets are
there's already Rocket Fuel here you
know we'll just use some of the energy
from the rocket fuel to spin these pumps
so that that would be considered like
open cycle closed cycle full flow stage
combustion Cycles are are ways to
tap into the propellant actually and
then there's tap off expanders like I
mean all of them kind of do the same
thing but you end up at some point
spinning a turbine uh you know a turbine
can take uh some of the heat energy and
the and the and the pressure
uh of an engine and then they can that
can be connected to a shaft to pumps and
those pumps can you know increase the
pressure of the propellants
and force it into the combustion chamber
now the difference between open cycle
closed cycle full flaw all those is what
happens
after the gas has flown through the
turbine so after you've used the turbine
and spun up the energy you know spun up
the engine what happens to that gas so
in an open cycle engine you basically
have like a separate small rocket engine
in a sense it's a gas generator they
call it and that will be used to create
someone you know take a little we'll say
10 of your the propellant flowing to the
engine instead you reroute it to like a
smaller rocket engine called the gas
generator you point that at your turbine
and that will spin your turbine up to
you know ridiculous speeds 30 000 plus
RPM and then after it spins it's wasted
most of its its energy you know and it's
just dumped overboard that would be open
cycle you're not worrying about it after
that point but you are left with a lot
of unburnt un you know unused fuel a
good amount of that fuel is just
completely and especially because the
turbine uh you you have to keep it from
melting so you can't run it at like
Optimal
ratios not necessarily stoichiometric
and a rocket engine you actually don't
want it to be near stoichiometric where
you're releasing all the energy you
actually want to release
um you actually want to be throwing out
the lighter molecule so it can be shot
out faster generally in the engine so um
but in order to have a turbine survive
you have to actually cool you have to
have the gas going through it it can't
be stupid stupid hot or else you're just
going to melt your turbine so they
normally um especially in the open cycle
you just run it really fuel Rich so
there's a lot of extra fuel being pumped
into it that will keep the temperatures
at a reasonable
uh you know at a reasonable temperature
so you end up with this like dark [__]
smoke pouring out of that gas generator
that's just unburned fuel it's just
wasted fuel it never got a chance to be
used oh interesting you know like in the
combustion chamber it's not it's not
being used to propel the rocket you know
it's just being used to cool down the
the repellent that's being used to spin
the turbine that's being used to spin
the pumps to push a lot of propellant
into the engine
so
you know it doesn't take too long before
you know your a greedy rocket scientist
being like look at all this wasted
propellant all this potential energy
that's just literally being spewed out
the side of the rocket so that's where
the closed cycle comes in so now we have
to get that propellant take it from
basically
what was being wasted through the
turbine and you're going to try pumping
it back into the engine now you don't
literally just pump that that gas that's
you know that hot that gas into the
engine because it's actually way too low
of pressure uh compared to the main
combustion chamber by that point by the
time has gone through the turbine it's
lost most of its pressure and heat to
the turbine so if you tried pumping it
into the engine you know just taking
that pipe and sticking it right into the
combustion chamber that the much higher
pressure hotter combustion chamber would
just go backwards and it'd stall out the
engine and blow up the engine and
whatever what have you so what they
actually do is they normally will send
there might be some variations of this
but the general concept is you actually
flow all of your fuel or all of your
oxidizer through the turbine so that
would be closed cycle so there's fuel
Rich closed cycle which would be your
flowing all of the fuel through the
turbine or there's oxidizer closed cycle
which is where you're flowing all of the
oxidizer that's going into the engine
through the turbine now the trick here
is you have to have that turbine after
it's done its work so after it's taken
some of the potential energy some of the
heat energy from we're now calling it a
pre-burner by the way instead of it
being a gas generator you now call that
device that's that's creating pressure
to spin the turbine you're not calling
that a pre-burner because it's just
going to pre-burn some of your fuel or
some of your oxidizer
the trick is that has to be by the time
it's gone through the turbine it has to
be higher pressure
than the combustion chamber because
otherwise it's going to go backwards
still so you really have to get that
pre-burner up to ridiculously high
pressures like at least 20 higher than
your main combustion chamber and these
combustion Chambers you know we're
talking about engines that are at you
know 200 100 to 200 even in spacex's
Raptor engine up to 300 bar in the main
combustion chamber so that's what is
that 4500 PSI basically insane amounts
of of pressure inside these combustion
Chambers so your turbine has to be even
above that or your your gas generator or
your pre-burner sorry has to be higher
pressure than that even in order to have
the flow going the right direction
through the engine
so now you'll you'll have those closed
Cycles you'll have fuel Rich you have
oxidizer Rich
um the tricks now you're starting to get
it's crazy there's just so many
compromises every little decision you
have of like oh I did this now I know
well now crap it's gonna do this for
instance fuel Rich if you ran kerosene
fuel Rich you know how I mentioned soot
coming out of the gas generator well if
you run soot
um
through your through your engine like
that and how to go through your
injectors like back into the engine
it'll clog the pores of the injectors
and it will end up blowing up the engine
the soot itself is so damaging
that you can't really run a fuel-rich
kerosene engine what exactly is so it's
like fuel somehow mixed up with the
smoke like what I wonder what what is it
chemically it's just some weird it's
mostly just carbon it's mostly just that
carbon that dark solid solid chunks of
carbon and it can cake up and just
literally like you know like yeah it's
it's like ash almost you know like at
some point you know especially under
those High pressures and high
temperatures it can physically build up
and you know turn into like stalagmites
and stalactites of of carbon really hard
you know for forged in a rocket engine
carbon I wonder how you figure all that
out too is that's the experimentation
some of that has come chemist like
theoretical but like you're gonna have
to build the thing at scale and actually
test the trial and if you're trying here
there's many decades of trial and error
and many pieces of engines that you're
trying to piece back to they're going
like what the hell happened here yeah
what happened yeah okay so uh so that's
closed cycle so how do we get to full
flow so in either of those situations
you're still actually just having the
opposite so if you're fuel Rich you know
all the fuel is going through the
turbine but um only a tiny bit of oxygen
is actually being put into that
pre-burner to to spin the pumps and the
rest of the the rest of the oxygen is
actually going through the pump the
primary pump and straight into the
combustion chamber
now full flow the idea is you're going
to actually pre-burn both your
propellants both your propellants are
going to go through a pre-burner and
they're both going to end up spinning
one of the pumps so you'll have a gas a
fuel rich pre-burner and you're going to
have an oxygen-rich pre-burner each one
of those is going to get just you know
they're going to heat it up just enough
and get it up to just enough pressure to
spin up that turbine as fast as they
need to do to get the pumps up to the
right pressure and still have enough
pressure through the turbine to overcome
the pressure inside the main combustion
chamber and they're both going to arrive
both your fuel and your oxidizer are
going to arrive in the main combustion
chamber as hot gases already so what was
liquid oxygen is now gaseous oxygen what
was Liquid methane is now gaseous
methane and they're meeting in this
combustion chamber at still ridiculously
high pressures again
for spacex's uh Raptor engine they're
meeting at 300 bar insane amounts of
pressure and then they uh then they
combust from there on and because
they're already a gas gas interaction
they're happy to burn they're ready to
they're ready to burn they're ready to
mingle as opposed to having a gas liquid
interaction which is what's a lot more
normal you know you'll have two
different states of matter and they just
might not they might take a little more
core you know coaxing to what's that
word
yeah
that doesn't sound like it's not correct
right focusing coaxing yeah yeah all
right I don't know we'll cut that in
post no we'll have Morgan Freeman uh
over Davos yeah uh
the fascinating thing is they're coaxed
and there's gases and combustion but
yeah they they just take a little bit
more it takes more time in the
combustion chamber to have a liquid gas
interaction like mixed together and and
re unleash as much of their energy as he
can before it exits the system uh some
of the trade-offs here in terms of
efficiency which which is most efficient
and then also complexity of the design
and the engineering and the cost of the
design and the engineering like what are
the different trade-offs between open
cycle closed cycle and full flow yeah
it's a pretty it's kind of like a
oh what's the the Bears uh the
Goldilocks you know like it's like it
you kind of generally the easiest is
open cycle because you know you're just
expelling the the exhaust gas
um the gas generator exhaust you're not
having to worry about it you just spin
up that thing as much as you need and
deal with it right no big deal
um closed Cycles offers 10 to 15 greater
performance generally because you know
you're not wasting that propellant and
but it's it's complicated it's a lot
more complicated especially if you're
doing oxygen rich now you're having hot
gaseous oxygen uh in your engine which
just generally wants to react with
everything it's just a recipe like hot
oxygen is just a recipe for things to
catch on fire that shouldn't be on fire
so Metals you know under those
conditions lots of times we'll just
spontaneously start burning you know
you'll actually turn your metal and it
will now become fuel you'll be engine
Rich before you know it because you're
hot oxygen nice is uh is eating and
using that engine as fuel basically so
um oxygen rich is generally very hard
but that is what the Soviet Union ended
up doing with almost their entire line
of Vengeance was close cycle oxygen rich
but you know so those two are kind of
generally hard but offer great
performance benefits over open cycle uh
but at the end of the day you know full
flow is by far the it's the ultimate of
all of them it's the most difficult but
it also has the most potential to be the
most efficient Starship the Raptor too
the the why is that engine using full
flow
because it's the best I mean it's just
physics wise if you're trying to extract
as much energy out of your propellants
there there just isn't another cycle
type that that is uh better than it but
of course it's very very hard to develop
you know so far to date the rd270 in the
60s was built
um there is a powerhead demonstrator
built in the United States in the in the
90s and early 2000s I think maybe just
the early 2000s um that was just the
just the power Just the the pumps and
the turbines and the pre-burners no
chamber no nothing that was a big deal
only the United States took you know
millions of dollars to just develop that
and then there's spacex's Raptor engine
so you talked about uh the combustion
chamber and how damn hot things get high
pressure
a lot of heat uh how do you keep the
thing cool you have a great video on
this how do you get it from uh from what
do you call it metal Rich engine Rich
engine Rich from like the the metal from
melting well one of the ways is to let
it be engine Rich there's actually you
can use a blade of cooling you can
literally let
um make the walls thicker than you
normally make it make it out of a
material that will ablate away that will
kind of chip away and take some of the
heat away with it it's very again
primitive and it's actually what SpaceX
first used on their first Merlin engines
they used ablative cooling
um so it's basically a carbon nozzle and
you just let it get the carbon the inner
layer of the of the engine was not of
his carbon and you just let it get
chewed away and eaten away and that's
just something you factor in uh it's not
a very elegant and it's definitely not
reusable in that sense so there's
probably really good models about like
how it melts away the rate at which
melts away to know what thickness yeah
but boy is it dangerous right this is
part of the design it seems so silly so
obviously you probably you know it's
again it's not the most elegant and the
problem too your geometry physically is
changing too because as you're eroding
the walls now things like your expansion
ratio or the ratio between your throat
and the nozzle exit is changing yeah
because the thickness like the throat
diameter is actually like everything is
changing so it's it's not great it might
might not be melting away uniformly
there could be some like weird pockets
for aerodynamics stuff it's just a bunch
of chaos just can which I can't imagine
having to like figure all that stuff out
honestly yeah
um so the uh the more elegant thing to
do there's there's a couple other things
you can do but the kind of the most
common one especially when we're dealing
with liquid field Rockets is something
called regeneratively Cooling and the
the idea is you basically just flow fuel
or fuel or oxidizer through the walls of
the of the nozzle on the chamber
um before they go through like into the
injector or into the actual combustion
chamber by doing that your your taking
heat out of the you know you're taking
heat out of the metal the walls and
you're putting it in the propellant so
you're typically heating the propellant
up which is remember when I said there's
gas interaction versus a liquid like
liquid gas lots of times even if you
pump them both that you know as
um they you know both being pumped as
liquids by the time it goes through the
walls of the chamber lots of times one
of them is Phase changed into a gas so
now you do have that gas liquid
interaction that's because they're using
that the fuel or the oxidizer to to cool
the walls of the of the engine so when
you look at a rocket engine although it
looks like you know a nice beautifully
uniform cylinder you know smooth thing
um there's either there's oftentimes
like uh the channels actually like
milled into the walls that they run fuel
through and even though they're tight
you know they can be like two three
millimeters thick they'll actually still
have a channel that goes down on u-turns
and comes around and comes back all the
way down to the tip of the nozzle and
everything so it's it's just insane that
you know that that's pre-designed and
that's that's like uh so they design
those channels yeah there's probably
some optimization there and like how the
flow happens well especially because you
you're thinking about a conical thing or
like a some iconical thing where the the
area is getting smaller and smaller and
smaller you're flowing the same amount
of propellant through it as you are down
you know what I mean like the propellant
has to so they have all these unique
things like you know sometimes uh
different manifolds where they'll inject
more or less fuel in certain areas and
there must be like propellant simulation
software because they can't surely can't
like
test this on actual physical
well back in the day they had to just
build it well you mean back back in the
day
walked up uphill in both ways it was
like I mean like any anything back in
the day before computers were you like
like
you just had to do it and like your
simulation or modeling was like a sheet
of paper where you're like calculating
stuff well but you can heat flux you
know like you can literally see how much
energy and how much heat is inside the
combustion chamber how much you know and
that is a a measurable thing even
without a computer now I'm not near
smart enough to do any of this like I've
never tried measuring the heat flux of
anything I barely even know what that
means I'm just smart enough
to be but that is something that people
would calculate and they find out okay
copper you know does a better job of
transferring the heat between the walls
of it and into the propellant blah blah
blah compared to XYZ
um so yeah you know materials people
like I've met just in all walks of life
especially just through MIT through
everywhere whereas some people
are just like a hundred X smarter than
anyone you've ever met at a particular
thing like you mentioned copper they'll
know the heat dissipation through
different materials they'll understand
that like more than it's like holy [__]
it's possible for a human being to
deeply understand a thing dude Aerospace
is full of that you'll have people that
are so niche in some thing that no one
like the average person has never even
remotely thought of yet this person has
done it 40 000 different ways in a you
know in a an environment being like well
we found out that if we turn it four
degrees that way and add four percent
niobium you know like just things you're
like
what is your life and how do you know
this and the funny thing about them they
usually don't think it's a big deal yeah
they're usually like they're they're so
nonchalant about it that if you don't
actually you have to know enough you
actually have to know quite a lot to
appreciate
how much more they know yeah because
otherwise you won't even notice it
because there are popular culture
doesn't celebrate the intricacies of uh
scientific or engineering Mastery which
is interesting there's all these people
that lurk in the shadows they're just
Geniuses yes like you see you'll have
like the LeBrons who are like good at
basketball so we understand that they're
good at basketball they do this thing
with the ball and the hoop and they do
like it really well better than a lot of
other people under pressure like we
celebrated big public spectacles yeah
look at how great they are yeah but like
the people like yeah as at these
aerospace companies in NASA SpaceX
the kind of stuff they're doing just I
mean there's Geniuses there and it's
actually really inspiring I mean I've
um I've interacted with a lot of
brilliant people in the software world
and maybe because I don't deeply
understand a lot of Hardware stuff
materials engineering mechanical
engineering those people seem like so
much smarter I mean it's always like the
grass is green or whatever the
expression is but there's a depth of
understanding that Engineers have that
do like mechanical engineering that's
just awe-inspiring uh to me well not to
get too like uh X well I don't know what
the word would be introverted or
something or whatever but that's
actually kind of the whole point of
everyday astronaut like that's almost
the whole point of what I do each year
from the beginning I did a thing called
the Astro Awards trying to be like an
award show hoping to you know lift up
and celebrate and and China Spotlight on
the people that are actually doing the
hard work and try to treat them like the
the rock stars that they are that we
don't know about and I think that's one
of the things that for sure I think you
know I think Elon definitely helped make
space flight cool helped make that like
a celebration thing where people are
physically out cheering for rockets and
Science and Space exploration but I
think that's just the beginning you know
I think like this should be a thing
where the general public uh looks to
these people as as the coolest ones as
the the coolest places to work as the
most important things you know sports
are great and everything I'm a big
formula one fan and things like that but
you know at the same time like if we
should be celebrating the people doing
this crazy work you know clocking in
countless hours just trying to figure
out this one little thing that's going
to help us further our understanding I
mean what's cooler than a giant thing
with a really hot fire
that goes boom and goes up into the air
I mean like there's no it's it's like it
to me like bridges are inspiring it's
like uh incredible architecture design
and like the humans are able to uh work
against nature build these gigantic
metal things but like rockets yeah with
like a tiny little humans on top of them
yeah flying out into space it's like
it's the coolest possible thing
everything comes together all the
different disciplines coming together
for the high stakes drama of
you know riding that super powerful
thing up away from the thing we call
home Earth it's like it's so amazing
exactly so freaking amazing well I think
that's kind of part of my like story arc
is I I just used to be a huge car and
motorcycle guy like I just loved you
know things that go fast and you know
are loud and go fast and make lots of
power and at the end of the day like at
some point you realize nothing goes
faster and it's louder and makes more
power or the rocket you know I think
that's I think that's kind of where
where I eventually just ended up you
know wound up there just because there
is nothing cooler than that yeah that's
the ultimate level it reaches the car
guy is to become a rock guy yeah 100 and
at some point some Car Guys literally
become rocket guys and strap Rockets to
cars and try and break land speed
records you know like it's yeah it's
it's the same universe here and yeah uh
so Elon with your conversation with him
on on the Raptor too was talking about
what you were talking about like there's
an excessive amount of cooling to be on
the safe side as you're developing the
engine uh what kind of cooling was that
so that would be film cooling so
remember how a little bit ago we were
talking about keeping the turbine from
melting you can just run it off of like
off nominal basically off you know
typically fuel rich just run more fuel
through that so it's cool enough you can
actually do that locally kind of in your
engine so you can keep it so you know
imagine a combustion chamber and the top
of it's just a flat like imagine a
shower head and then you have like you
know the combustion chamber attached to
it the Outer Perimeter there the the
part where the flame front would be
touching the walls you can actually have
just more fuel injectors so you're
injecting locally of more fuel-rich Zone
along the entire nozzle and that would
be called film cooling so it's less
efficient though again you're kind of
wasting fuel there's fuel that's running
you know and your your mixture ratio is
off but only for a little portion of
your the big picture you know so that's
one of those compromises like you can do
additional film cooling to make sure
you're not melting your engine uh you
know but at the cost of performance you
actually but you can also be smart and
use film cooling you know there's fun
little clever tricks for instance you'll
notice on the F1 engine that was on the
Saturn V you know the biggest uh rocket
that had been built to date prior now to
Starship
um the F1 has this huge huge huge
engines there's five of them on the
Saturn V and you'll notice that like the
gas generator has a pipe that comes down
and then it actually splits off in a
manifold and wraps around part of the
nozzle
and that manifold
takes the hot gas from the turbine which
which is actually I mean it's not hot
it's actually cold gas compared to the
combustion chamber but it's you know in
human terms it's still you wouldn't want
to put your hand in it you know not live
um and it actually pipes that gas into
the nozzle so that it creates a film
cooling a an actual boundary layer of
cooler gas against the hotter combustion
chamber gas so basically repurposing
that gas that was normally wasted and
they pump it back into the engine and
then into the nozzle like kind of
further down so the trick there is it
has to be
far enough down that the pressure at the
in the nozzle because remember as the
nozzle gets bigger and bigger and bigger
the pressure is getting lower and lower
and the temperature is getting lower and
lower so you have to find this trade-off
point where the pressure is is lower
than that gas from the turbine and then
you pump it in and it's cooler than the
then the gas still is in the nozzle and
it can help not melt your nozzle so
you'll notice that the F1 is actually a
good example of regen cooling so the
chamber walls you can physically see the
pipes actually
um on the F1 because it's so big and
they just literally used pipes and bent
them and you can see the the coolant
channels all the way up and down the
engine until you get to that manifold
then from there on it just has what's
called a nozzle extension and it keeps
going and going and going and that
section of nozzle is cooled by the film
cooling of the gas generator
I mean the aerodynamics of cooler gas
and the high gas
because you have to have this kind of
layer right to protective layer of cool
like understanding that obviously
probably has to do in modern times
there's probably really good simulation
of aerodynamics but and to do it in
terms of pressure too like um to make
sure it's in the right place yeah that
doesn't like go back up go backwards
exactly if they have that manifold even
six inches too high on that nozzle yeah
it's just going to go upwards you know
and pressure always wants to flow from
high to low the number of options you
have here that result in it going boom
is very large near Infinity yeah
especially because I mean you can't do
like a small model of it maybe you can
no you can't you can't really scale very
well no you have to you have to do the
full testing and that's why you have all
the kind of that's
that's why you have a Starship all the
tests that you know you think why would
you need to do so many static fires and
so many tests and why is it failing so
many times can't you get it right but
like it's very tough to get it right
well and when you're pushing the
boundaries you want to know where and
how it's going to fail that's right so
you can engineer around them so that's
that's a luxury that SpaceX does have
with the scale of raptor you know
they're building Raptor cheaper than
probably almost any other engine you
know maybe beside some of their own at
least at that scale
um then before they're testing you know
I think since last March or last April
they've tested a thousand Raptor you
know a thousand engine fires I guess not
just Raptors but
um you know that's just an insane amount
of data and an insane amount of edge
cases to learn oh my God we found out
that we're actually slightly over
spinning our turbine at this degree in
this frequency is harmonic at this blah
blah blah and almost realize it's
rattling and you know it did this and
then you can engineer around that you
know it's like it I'll ultimately you
know I think Elon said something like
high production rate uh solves many ills
or something along those lines and it's
just true if you have an insane amount
of engines and an insane amount of data
an insane amount of failures to learn
from you just know your system inside
and out you know those margins you know
where the failure points are you know
how to engineer around them and that's
how I approach dating no I'm just
kidding
because we're talking about engines uh
so most Rockets I think all Rockets have
multiple stages uh today uh maybe
they'll take us in a discussion of what
ideas that could be for single stage uh
to orbit Rockets but can you describe
this whole thing that you've been
mentioning here and there of multiple
stages of a rocket yeah no that's a good
question so ultimately you know like I
said you're kind of pushing about 90 the
Rockets like basically just fuel with
some skin on it you know what I mean
um and so uh that skin weighs a lot of
you know skin in the engines do weigh a
lot you know like I said the Falcon 99
zone is about 20 tons just the boosters
about 20 metric tons
um so it's not an insignificant amount
of weight so the idea is with staging is
you ditch anything you don't need more
or less so um and the you know Falcon 9
is a perfect rocket to think about this
because you have a upper stage and you
have a booster you know our first stage
and the first stage Burns through all
this fuel once it's out of fuel you let
go of the second stage and ta-da you
actually just basically started and lit
a brand new fresh rocket you know this
brand new fresh rocket now doesn't have
all that that 20 tons attached to it so
it's a lot lighter it doesn't need you
know it's nearly as many engines to push
it around it needs just one instead of
nine
its engine can be optimized for the
vacuum of space as opposed to having to
operate at sea level with all of our
actually pretty thick atmosphere you
know relatively so there's so staging is
basically the idea that you get rid of
things you don't need on Earth again
kind of that whole like 10 harder 10
easier if it was 10 easier single stage
door would be no big deal and it
probably would have been like the the
way to get to orbit by choice just
because like it's not that hard but with
our Earth as it is uh with physics as it
is it's just
it's doable and we've had
and you know we almost kind of actually
the first orbit to take humans or the
first rocket to take humans into orbit
uh for the from the United States
um which was the
Atlas rocket um was kind of a stage and
a half it actually only had like one big
fuel tank and what that is they actually
dropped off two of its three engines so
it just ditched some of the engines but
if it hadn't done that you know so kind
of people were like well that was single
stage it's like it still had a staging
event it still had a ditch mass in order
to even make it into orbit had it not
done that it would have not been able to
get into orbit so yeah you pretty
quickly look at your trade and say okay
well if I want to stick to single stage
to orbit my payload Mass becomes
tiny you know like you might be able to
put like you know a falcon 9 booster on
its own like if you just flew one of the
side core boosters of a falcon heavy
with a nose cone on and everything to
say I'm just gonna fly this on its own
you might be able to put like a you know
10 kilograms into space or something you
know a very small amount we'll throw a
second stage on that thing and now you
can put uh you know 17
000 kilograms into space so it's just an
order you know orders of magnitude more
payload capacity because you did staging
because you ditched the vestigial weight
so
um the other thing that's uh hard about
that too uh is that the engines again
that operate at sea level uh are often
not great in in space and vice versa
like you physically can't almost
optimize for space engines you can't
even operate at sea level they'll
destroy themselves due to something
called flow separation so
um not only are you getting the benefit
of ditching all the weight but you're
also able to use a much more efficient
unless typically you know the much less
powerful engine in space so you
mentioned on uh
the multi-stage Rockets
uh that maybe the dream would be uh if
we weren't living on Earth but maybe we
can on Earth uh to have a single stage
uh to orbit rocket where it's all one
package reusable
reusable it's even harder it gets even
harder so first off what is uh just a
link on it what what is the single stage
to orbit rocket and why is it so hard to
achieve on Earth do you already kind of
explained it a little bit but just if we
were to say like yeah that's your
assignment Yeah Tim you're supposed to
get together with Elon and other
brilliant people and like you have to do
this yeah
why is it so hard why is it so hard
um it your the the payload fraction of a
rocket is
like three to five or six or seven
percent would be like you know that's
the amount of payload compared to the
total mass of the rocket like you're
lucky to get into
Beyond five percent so if you're now
having to deal with the weight of the
rocket by the time you're in orbit like
your your payload fraction just you're
you're talking about like margins it's
such
it's so small amount of leftover if you
have to take all of it with you
so the sooner you can ditch weight the
better the sooner you can ditch weight
the better the sooner you can you know
and that's what you're doing a rocket
the whole time is actually ditching
weight all of that fuel and all that big
giant flamacy is literally Mass being
thrown out the back of the rocket but
what typically is an expended you know
at least during nominal operations
you're not seeing the engines being you
know expelled out the thing until you
get to staging of course and that's
where you know you're ditching all that
dead weight so single stage to orbit
your margins just become so small that
it it's border it's not impossible but
it's just at the end of the day like
almost no matter who you are you end up
saying it's just simply not worth it
like it'd be if you have two rockets
that are using the same amount of
propellant you know they're the same
physical sizes and one of them is
cutting you know on a third and has
another little engine it'll have a
hundred or a thousand times more payload
capacity than the one sitting right next
to it and now so there's tricks you can
do to like try to offset that things
like aerospike engines which operate at
uh as efficiently at sea level at a kind
of optimized efficiency at sea level and
just by their uh by the way their design
the physics of them they're also
efficient in a vacuum too
um you can do things like that and at
the end of the day though you just end
up with a worse rocket than if you had
just done stage like no matter what and
and people say like well what if you
developed the new technologies like okay
apply that technology to a multi-stage
rocket and it's gonna do better you know
like no matter where you end up it's
just always better to ditch that weight
you know is there a cost to having
multi-stage because you can still reuse
the different stages that's the the
dream is you know becomes easier to
reuse multiple stages because now you
know like the booster doesn't have to
survive orbital re-entry temperatures
and extreme environments and you only
have to you know make survival the upper
stage you only have to put a big heat
shield I mean starship's the perfect
perfect thing of this the upper stage
has a big giant heat shield the booster
doesn't need it because it's not going
the booster is not going to orbit it's
only going A fifth or a quarter of
orbital velocity so it's heat that it
experiences is survivable just by the
stainless steel you don't need an
additional heat shield
um so all of a sudden if you're trying
to reuse pretend that you just welded
the two stages of Starship together
remove those engines on Starship that
whole vehicle if you're trying to reuse
it the whole vehicle now has to have a
heat shield on one side of it the whole
thing has to have these big heavy Wings
by the time you come down to it there's
probably just zero payload capacity you
basically put your fuel tank in space
you know good job so the the dream of a
single stage to orbit a rocket is is
that just even the wrong dream on Earth
that's what most convention tells you
you know by the time if if you're you're
if your goal is cheap then you're going
to spend you're going to have a
physically larger rocket that has more
engines that has more propellant blah
blah to put the same amount of thing
here same amount of mass into orbit
compared to something else you know
we're talking like rocket Labs electron
a really small rocket it's like I think
1.3 meters wide and something like you
know 18 meters taller I mean it's it's a
small rocket
if you were to you know the and it can
put something like 300 and or so
kilograms into orbit
you can either launch something that
size or again like a full like big old
Falcon 9 booster the huge huge thing and
that would be lucky to put 300 kilograms
into orbit you know so it's like which
one's gonna be cheaper to build you know
ship around all this stuff and then you
also look at you have fixed costs like
the idea of flying a but this this uh
again everything in rocket science is a
compromise because now you have things
like um people on Console time all the
people that are you know on comms and
working on the rocket going down to the
pad you know filing paperwork doing
range control making sure there's not
planes and boats in the way uh flight
termination people you have all these
fixed costs for any launch I don't care
how big the rocket is there's a
relatively fixed cost so now you say
like okay I'm gonna be paying well let's
just make one hour I'm gonna pay five
million dollars to fly a rocket between
all the people going on site all the
propellant all the licenses blah blah
if your fixed cost is five million
dollars and you can put 300 kilograms in
Space versus you have a five million
dollar cost of operation and you can put
5 000 kilograms into space like it it's
it's the business case is going to send
you in One Direction pretty quickly so
you mentioned aerospike engines
I think uh the internet uh informed me
of your love affair with the house by
gotcha find somebody that looks at you
the way Tim not looks at Eros package
can you explain uh what these are how do
they work
um what's beautiful to them what how
practical are they why don't we use them
oh my God uh does it just boil down to
the design of the nozzle uh so maybe can
you explain how is it possible to
achieve this thing for an engine to be
as efficient at uh in a vacuum on sea
level and in all different conditions
you know what I love about this is like
every question you've asked me is like a
one hour video
now boil it down to 45 seconds
so the aerospike engine basically
um is an inside out engine more or less
so with a traditional engine you know
we've talked about the combustion
chamber and the throat and then it
expands out into the nozzle those walls
are containing the pressure right
airspike is the opposite it's basically
the pressure of the engine is on the
outside of it and it's pushing inward
against a spike
so it's it's almost like it's like like
the difference of if you were let me
think about this if you were standing in
like a a tent or a TP right and you put
your arms at the top and you pushed your
arms out like into an iron cross or
something you know you could physically
lift the tent just by pushing outwards
on the tent walls right well that would
be like a traditional nozzle now
aerospike would be almost like squeezing
an ice cube you know if you squeeze an
ice cube you can push in on it and kind
of that wedge force will shoot that ice
cube so that's kind of what is happening
we have the high pressure gases on the
outside of the spike squeezing in on
that Spike and that's and then that's
pushing up against the you know because
it's equal on both sides against like
kind of the ramp is pushing up against
the rocket so that's where that Force
comes in it's against the nozzle against
the chambers the hard part with an
aerospike so the cool okay I guess the
cool thing about an aerospike is
that it can operate
um in space you can have what's known as
a really big expansion ratio so that's
your ratio between the throat the area
of the throat versus the area of the
nozzle exit and remember how the bigger
the nozzle is the it's con continually
just converting more and more is
converting that high energy hot high
pressure gas into a cooler
and cooler lower pressure and faster gas
so each little millimeter along that
nozzle is just getting it lower pressure
and cooler but faster
now if you take a big nozzle on Earth
and you at sea level and you fire it you
can actually get even though we're going
from say 300 bar the Raptor engine
um you know our atmosphere at sea level
is about one bar it's pretty much
exactly one bar
um depending on conditions but you can
actually get a nozzle to get way below
one bar of pressure so every little you
know you can go from 300 bar in just two
meters down to one bar or below one bar
there's actually a limit you can
actually only expand it below you know
we'll say something like 70 so you can
get down to like point seven bar at
nozzle exit before the pressure of the
atmosphere is actually squeezing in on
that exhaust and tearing it away from
the walls of the engine the walls of the
nozzle exit and what happens is it's
it's kind of unpredictable you get these
Pockets these oscillations and they'll
be so extreme that they'll end up just
destroying the nozzle so you can't lower
you can't have a bigger expansion ratio
then again relatively speaking some
something like 0.7 like you can't go
below you can't get that pressure exit
too much below ambient air pressure
before flow separation can destroy the
engine so how come this engine can do so
well in in different pressure conditions
so because it's inside out the ambient
pressure is pushing the exhaust gas into
the wall as opposed to a conventional
engine that exhaust get or the ambient
air is actually squeezing the exhaust
gas away from the walls of the engine
and that squeezing away from is what can
be destructive so that since the
instance is kind of inside out the
ambient air is pushing the exhaust gas
into the engine walls so you can't have
flow separation you won't have flow
separation now what happens is so you
can have this huge amazingly like
efficient vacuum engine that's that's
has a we'll say a 200 to 1 expansion
ratio which is really big like a lot of
sea level engines are like 35 40 50 to 1
expansion ratios and then in space you
know it's common to use like 150 180 200
to 1 expansion ratios so an aerospike
can have something like 200 to one it's
just at the at sea level it's kind of
just getting pushed and it's kind of
getting cut off early almost but it
doesn't matter it's not like destructive
it's just not running at its maximum
efficiency as it climbs in altitude as
the ambient air gets thinner and thinner
and thinner it just inherently is
pushing less and less and less against
the walls of that aerospike engine so it
actually continually gets more efficient
at you know as it climbs in altitude as
as does the normal engine but the
difference is that you can use that huge
expansion ratio at sea level and you
can't use a huge expansion ratio at sea
level with reproduction traditional
nozzle has anyone actually flown on a
spike engine no aerospike engine to date
has ever been flown on an orbital rocket
why not and would you like to see a
future where they're used
purely purely because I think they're
cool yeah you know in the same way
that's at the core of your love affair
with air Spike engines it's just and I
said this in my video actually they're
outside before I came in here I saw an
RX7 on in the streets that I just love
and that uses a rotary engine on paper
the rotary engine is like more efficient
does you know smaller more efficient all
these things but in practice it's like
the thing is actually just like
unreliable hot and it you know it it
blah blah blah blah Burns oil it's kind
of the same thing with the aerospike
engine like yes on paper it's more
efficient but now you have a lot more
surface area of your your your your
throat area no matter what is going to
have uh the the throat of the rocket
engine is always where it's the hottest
you know it's the hardest thing to cool
and with a narrow Spike if you know if
it's inside out now your throat is no
matter what like way bigger you know
it's almost like the size of the nozzle
exit normally but now it's your hardest
thing to cool and you have a ton of it
and you also have two edges of it no
matter what so even if you have like a
you know a circle inside a circle
you have like a just insane amount more
surface area to cool with a limited
amount of fuel don't forget you're using
your fuel as your as your coolant so if
you also now take your throw area and
you have
um
x amount of space that you need to cool
you only have you have a limited Supply
it's like oh it's sorry this is the
stuff that does are there ideas of for
cooling
um or for cooling out Spike engines it's
the same physics apply for aerospike as
they would so you just run into you just
run into a limitation like at some point
I'm not flowing enough propellant my it
scales it scares scales kind of poorly
you know what I mean like you can
increase the thrust of an aerospice by
making it bigger and increase the mass
flow and the fuel going through the
throats or the throat but at the same
time like it just it's at the end of the
day
it's physically possible it's a lot more
complex you have a lot of issues with
Cooling and it's just you end up kind of
right back where you started so it's
like is it worth it to just keep going
down this Rabbit Hole you know try to
engineer this thing to work when like
you could have probably spent a tenth of
the amount of time just slightly
increasing the performance of your
normal engine in the first place you
know
again I'm going to promote morphy's uh
that lesson and applied to my dating
life and once again just kidding okay
um actually just on a small tangent
since you are also a car guy uh what's
the greatest uh combustion engine car
ever made to you if you had to pick
something what's the like the coolest
the sexiest the most powerful the
classiest the most elegant well-designed
I don't know what a lot of those things
are different for me but they are I
still as funny because now maybe it's
just because it's fresh on mind but I
love
that mid 90s RX7 which you know
especially in Japan they had the the 20b
a tri-rotor
that is like the coolest engine ever to
me
the fdrx7
it's just too darn cool honestly
maybe uh there you go well what about
the mid 90s that makes it special
it's more that I love the engine and I
and I like the car it's attached to him
and I'm not actually a big fan of like
90s styling you know personally but just
that the 20b is just such a cool cool
engine and it's twin turbo sequential
turbos so they used um they a bigger
turbo it takes longer to spool up you
know it takes more it's using that same
like a turbine and a compressor and it
just if it's a large turbine it takes
more exhaust gas to get it split up so
if you have an engine that reps to 9000
RPM and you want to get a lot of
pressure out of that turbo you have a
big turbo it's going to take forever
like you're gonna have you know your
floor and then like right it's gonna
take a long time for that turbo to get
spooled up so they actually did a small
turbo on it and a big turbo so the small
turbo would spool up first get some
boost going through the engine get that
engine operating get it up to speed get
it you know get some power to the wheels
and then once that kind of reaches its
limit you'd flow it into the divert the
exhaust gas into the bigger turbo it's
this sequential turbo and then that now
can supplement and actually increase the
you know overall all performance of the
of the vehicle by a lot and I just I
think that's just so cool it's just like
the ultimate like Brute Force out of the
box thinking and it actually made it
into production you know what I mean can
you uh what's it sound like can you tell
an engine by sound it sounds like a
really really angry lawnmower it's
horrible it's actually a terrible
sounding car in my opinion like it
sounds just raspy and like the opposite
of like a big muscle car yeah like a big
muscle car is deep gotta roll like deep
oh it just it hits you this is like it's
just gonna annoy the hell out of you in
all your neighbors like it's but you
love the engineering I love the
engineering of it I said so to you the
car is the engine it's not all the
surface stuff all the design stuff uh
all the you know yeah the the the
Elegance the curves Whatever It Is Well
those come and go you know to me Styles
change just forever yeah I'm gonna apply
that to my uh dating life once again the
metaphors just keep on coming well if
you think about it like my taste has
changed throughout the years when I
first saw uh a model 3 Tesla I thought
it was the most hideous car ever without
the gorilla it's like this is so stupid
it took me all but two months to think
that it was one of the coolest looking
cars same with cyber truck I'm mourned
cyber truck when I first saw that thing
I was at that that thing with and I went
with we used to do a podcast called our
ludicrous future so we talked a lot
about like you know cars and EVs and
stuff we went to that unveiling and
literally like we had like almost a
non-alcohol-induced hangover the next
morning of like morning the hideousness
of cyber truck
come six months later a year later and
I'm like damn it that thing's actually
kind of cool yeah that also teaches you
something about again it's the thing you
said uh earlier sort of uh
going against
the the current of the experts of the
beliefs or whatever is is and making the
decision from first principles some of
that also applies to design and styling
and fashion and culture and big time uh
some of that you know so fashion
especially is so interesting so being
rebellious
against the current the the current fads
actually is the way to pave
the new fads when it didn't take long
for others to follow you look at like
currently like what Hyundai is doing
with their I forget which one like the
ionic or something like that it's it's
Square it's like it's boxy you know it's
it's a throwback it's 80s it's got these
beautiful retro tail lights it's got
these Square headlights it's it's it's
very inspired by cyber truck in my
opinion I mean it might not be it might
be coincidental that we're all kind of
getting this retro feature Vibe but uh I
personally like the boxy so I never I
just still haven't understood uh
Porsches Porsches I still can't quite
understand the small size the elegant
the curves I don't I don't quite get it
like I said I don't love the look of the
RX7 I don't love it but I love it
because of the engineering I guess that
it represents you know what I mean yeah
it's it's uh it's not the surface stuff
it's the deep down stuff it's that 50 50
weight distribution that matters all
right let's uh let's talk about Starship
a little bit we've been sneaking up uh
to it and from a bunch of different
directions
can you just say
um
what is Starship and what is the most
impressive thing uh to your body I mean
you've talked about the sort of the
engines involved maybe you haven't
really kind of like dancing around it
but because this is such a crucial
thing in terms of uh the next few years
in terms of your own life personally and
uh also just human civilization reaching
out to the Stars it seems like Starship
is a really important vehicle to making
that happen so what is this thing that
we're talking about yeah so Starship is
uh currently in development the world's
largest most powerful rocket ever built
fully reusable rocket uh two-stage
rocket so the booster is landed and you
know all this is currently aspirational
until it's working uh so I'll I'll say
it's I'll say what it's aspiration is
going to be yeah and obviously I have
faith that that will happen but just
factually so the booster will be reused
landed and refueled and reused the upper
stage will be landed refueled and reused
and ideally rapidly in the in the sense
not talking about months or weeks of
refurbishment but literally talking
about like mild inspections and ideally
like under 24 hour reuse you know where
you literally really land it and fly it
like an airplane
so it utilizes liquid methane and liquid
oxygen as it's as its propellants it
utilizes the current iterations of it
are 33 Raptor engines on the booster
engine or on the booster and six uh
Raptors on the second stage so there'll
be three that are vacuum optimized and
three that are sea level optimized on
the upper stage that are primarily
they'll be used I think at stage
separation anyway in space but um though
their main reason that they use them is
so they can use them for landing too the
the three sea level engines uh to be
able to propulsively land the upper
stage as well so the three wrapped
engines are the ones that generate the
thrust that makes it the most powerful
rocket ever built by a almost double
compared to the Saturn fight really the
N1 had 45 Mega Newtons of thrust the
Saturn V had I think 35 or 40 Mega ninja
thrust and this has 75 Mega Newtons so
we're talking almost double
it's a uh it's a lot of power
um that could be the sexiest thing I've
ever heard okay uh so uh so what are the
different testing that's happening so
like uh uh what's a static fire with
some of these raptors look like and
where do we stand you would you're just
talking about offline like the thing
that happened uh yesterday it was
impressive you know everything in this
is kind of iterations and so
um you know the Milestones that we're
seeing we actually have on
everydayastronaut.com we have a
milestone checklist of like all the
things we're hoping to see that we kind
of need to see before the first orbital
flight of this rocket so um a big
milestone they got checked off yesterday
was a wet dress rehearsal so it's
literally like fueling the rocket up
getting ready to do everything but
lighting the engines basically so we're
talking about loading it with propellant
all the way uh this is the first time
yep right there where's the Milestones
right there at the top click that big
picture yep just anywhere that big
picture yep so the there's the what
dress rehearsal so what what's the what
dress rehearsal yep so that's where they
uh for the first time they filled it
completely to the brim with both liquid
oxygen and liquid methane now they've
done component level testing where they
fill it with liquid nitrogen which is
you know it's an inert gas so it's not
like say it leaks out it's not going to
explode uh you can just have a big giant
pool of liquid nitrogen like flooding
the area but it's not going to be an
explosion so they've done that for cryo
testing to make sure all the components
and stuff can handle you know being at
cryogenic temperatures
um it's kind of a good analog before you
start putting your your fuel in your
oxidizer in there but now yeah as of uh
yesterday they fall fully fueled the
rocket with propellant both stages the
first stage and the second stage while
fully stacked on the on the pad like
basically I mean it was the first sense
we really got off like this is what it's
going to look like right before it takes
off
you know kind of breathing coming to
life for the first time what does the
pad look like so there's a few
interesting aspects of this what's up
with the Chopsticks and the uh all of
that yeah so the the launch pad is is is
unique I've never seen anything like it
um and the prior history of of space
flight but it's a really simple launch
stand they basically have like this
almost looks like a stool like a you
know like a milking a cow stool thing
with a whole a big giant now I know
you're from Iowa
yes we all know what that's doing oh
yeah we all been sitting on that stool
milking cow yeah
with a giant hole in the middle and that
hole in the middle of that stool is
where the rocket sits and it sits on
these you know launch clamps
um and then next to it is the so that's
the orbital launch Mount and then next
to it there are the olm some people say
next to it is the orbital launch Tower
or the Olt and that is not only
um integral to fueling up the upper
stage you know upper stage has to have
propellant lines run to it so that they
can fill it with propellant and you know
all that but it also uh they ended up
making it so instead of having a big
crane on site to stack the two on top of
each other they literally just use that
Tower as a crane so the crane has these
giant arms lovingly called the
Chopsticks or the whole system can be
called mechazilla and that will grab
onto first it'll grab onto the booster
pick it up off of its off of its
transporter that transports it from the
production site lifts it up puts it down
onto the launch Mount and then it will
pick up the second stage of the upper
stage Starship and plop it down on top
of the booster and they did that for the
first time last year actually I think it
was like Valentine's last year was the
first time they used the Chopsticks to
stack it and now they're doing it quite
frequently you know but ultimately those
Chopsticks have to serve a second
purpose they're actually going to
utilize if you say catch it's not so
much they're going to catch the booster
with these Chopsticks it's not like it's
you know a dad trying to catch a falling
child you know it's more that that the
the booster and the Starship will
someday land on those arms yeah
so
um they're more or less stationary I'm
sure there's some bit of you know
adjustment that the arms will do but
more or less the Rocket's going to
propulsively land and get picked up by
like what's essentially like two like
relatively small ball joints that hold
the entire thing it has to land very
precisely on these these mountains then
on onto the the launch Mount and that's
what's going to just place it back onto
the stand and allow it to be refueled
and fly again what's the idea of using
the arms versus having uh launch pad to
land on what's what's the benefit you
are basically moving the mass of what
would be heavy Landing legs and you're
putting kind of that Landing
infrastructure onto a ground system so
you're not having to carry those Landing
legs into orbit but it's also elevated
off the ground is there some aspect to
that where you don't have to balance the
thrust and all the
you you you can negate some of those
like there's like plume plume
interactions there's like you know the
exhaust hitting concrete and especially
with the rocket this big it's going to
you know use like three Raptor engines
firing if you know if you have them
firing really close to the ground you're
just going to absolutely destroy and
crater the ground and you're going to
refurbish the the ground and the landing
pad every time and you know or have huge
Landing legs that are super long and and
Tall you know to to make it so it's
elevated enough to not do that
um so yeah you're kind of you're
avoiding that whole mess by by catching
it high enough off the ground that you
don't have to factor that in and it's
that's how many engines are involved in
the landing as far as the three Raptor
engines well we haven't actually you
know we haven't today seen the exact
Landing sequence so it might be
something like at first they might light
up you know seven or something or nine
or something some number to to
accelerate quickly or decelerate quickly
without the same thing
um and and then shut it down to three or
something for a little bit more granular
control because unlike Falcon 9 Starship
has enough engines and variability to
actually if it needed to hover you know
to maybe more precisely align itself
with the pad it would have that
capability and especially having
multiple engines you know if you only
have a single engine running you can't
really roll you know your roll access
you can do pitch and yaw because the the
engine is kind of like a Rudder it it
can move in two axes so you can easily
pitch and yaw the vehicle but to
actually induce Roll Along its its
vertical axis you you would either need
like auxiliary engines to roll it or
you'd need a pair of engines so they can
be opposed and induce rolls so by having
two or three running they have all three
axes of control that they would need
kind of like a broomstick you know and
uh bouncing a broomstick on your hand
they can just move it over and if they
need to align it to those Landing Nubs
you know on the landing arms and stuff
like that then uh they can do that
uh speaking of pitching yaw the thing uh
so Starship flips on its belly flops
there's a interesting kind of maneuver
uh on the way down to land uh can you
describe that maneuver what's involved
with that yeah so this is definitely a
first I don't think anything's tried
Landing like this before but the idea is
when you're falling through the
atmosphere the atmosphere could actually
do a lot of work for you you know you're
moving quickly something is falling from
space there's a lot of energy involved
you have a really good video on this as
well
and uh thank you
um the uh as it's falling you know you
can you let the you want to let the
atmosphere do as much work as it can
and so
um if you have a uh unsymmetric you know
it's not a ball that's falling this is
some kind of object with with shape some
you know at one face of it is going to
have more surface area than the other
face so you know in the shape of like a
cylinder if you're falling you know like
a soda can if you're falling top or
bottom first it's a certain amount of
surface area if you flip that on its
side you actually have a lot more
surface area so with the same exact
vehicle you can actually have a lot more
drag you can actually slow it down a lot
more using the exact same like same
atmosphere same same vehicle just by
turning at 90 degrees you can slow it
down substantially like three or four
times slower
so that's energy that you don't have to
use anywhere else you don't have to use
an engine to slow you down you don't
have to do anything else so SpaceX
realized okay if we flip this thing on
its side and let it fall like a skydiver
almost you know instead of like pencil
diving into the pool you're belly
flopping
you're maximizing the amount of surface
area that's in the Windstream that's
being slowed down but obviously like in
order to land especially if you're
SpaceX and you know elon's obsessed with
like not having different parts you know
he wants the best part is no part so if
you're going to land with the engines
you might as well use engines that
you've already have the engines that are
you know used for the other portions of
flight so you kick those on and you use
those engines to actually turn it 90
degrees from belly flopping to feet
first
and that way you can use those same
engines to land and you don't have to
have like auxiliary Landing engines you
don't have to have forces you know even
if you were to land like on its belly
with a separate set of engines Not only
would those engines weigh a lot you know
and be extra complexity etc etc but you
also don't have to make the ship be able
to handle Landing you know like on its
belly as opposed to having the forces be
vertical through it but it's a giant
thing you have to rotate in the air huge
and uh as you also highlight you know
there's liquid fuel slushing around in
the tank so like you can't uh I guess
use that fuel directly you have to have
another kind of fuel like there's just
complexities there yeah that involve uh
plus the actual maneuver is difficult
from the like like what are the
thrusters that actually make that um
make all that happen you're you're
adding a lot of
complexity uh not a lot but your
complexity to the maneuver and
possibility where failure Could Happen
uh in order to sort of save in order for
the air to do uh some of the work so
what is some of that complexity just you
can Linger on it you know if you if you
think about what it's going to take to
go from horizontal to Vertical
um this rocket in particular that
Starship has these big flaps
um so it has kind of two nose flaps and
two uh rearward flaps the river flaps
are a lot bigger because the majority of
the the mass the engines and stuff are
in the back of the the vehicle so in
order to kind of be stable and they just
fold themselves inwards like on their
dihedral angle at a dihedra angle in
order to
increase or decrease the drag so you can
control its all three axes of control
while it's falling uh you know on its
belly you can control it that way using
these four different fins so you have
these giant moving surfaces that take
thousands of of horsepower or just
insane amount of torque in order to move
these quickly enough to be a valid
control surface so that's a huge
complication is moving these fins and
developing that that Landing algorithm
and the you know the control for a huge
vehicle with flaps going like you know
in and out in and out in and out to stay
stable then right as you light the
engines now all of a sudden you want the
top you know you want to flip the rocket
90 degrees so the rear wood flaps the
bottom flaps fold in they tuck all the
way into minimize drag that's going to
make it want to you know swing down you
extend the upper flaps that makes it so
the nose wants to pitch up you kick on
the engines
um they're now lighting all three
engines at least as of the last like
successful attempts they like all three
of the sea level Raptor engines and
they're pitched all the way like you
know 10 or 15 degrees or whatever the
maximum pitches on them and that induces
a you know it does that kick maneuver to
kick it over from horizontal to vertical
now the problem is you lit your engines
while you're horizontal so they put some
horizontal velocity into the rocket they
push the rocket you know at the time the
nose is at the time of lighting those
engines the nose is facing the Horizon
and the engines are facing the opposite
Horizon yeah see now shot at a decent
amount and often you know the direction
that you're not falling you know
um so you have to factor that in to
where you're Landing because you're
going to land on this precise in this
case you're going to land on the inside
of the arm the loving arms of the
Chopsticks you know the Creed Arms Wide
Open you know try to land inside this
exactly the song they'll be playing
through my head as I watch this now
thank you thank you for forever joining
those two I appreciate this and you have
to very precisely control so what you
have to do is now that it's done that
kick you also have to cancel out that
horizontal velocity so it's actually
going to rotate Beyond 90 degrees to
cancel out that horizontal velocity
and then modulate the engines to make it
so the thrust you know is is perfect
so that it can control itself into a
controlled landing and all this is done
in like 500 meters like 1500 feet you
know you're doing all of those things
stupidly close to the ground it looks
absurd so far they've done five of these
tests all um the first four all blew up
you know um they're all coming in from
about 10 kilometers or 33 000 feet
um falling flipping you know again this
thing is huge that just the booster or
just the upper stage of this
um is is like 50 meters tall you know so
it's 150 well it's like 45 meter about
50 meters tall about 165 feet tall
um nine meters wide so 30 feet wide it
weighs you know something like God I
don't remember if it's something like
120 metric tons so 120 000 kilograms you
know two quarter of a million pounds
empty and it's doing this flip maneuver
and it has to do all this perfectly so
the first four four attempts of this
were pretty spectacular failures so just
to clarify which stage is doing this
maneuver it's the upper stage it's doing
this belly flop maneuver yep uh so this
is the the stage that would presumably
um have humans on board if it were to
use
um uh if things continue to play now
here's here's something I would love to
see yeah just saying this yeah if you
already have these big Arrow surfaces
the flaps they also have to move they're
on heavy Motors and hinges and flaps and
all that stuff I'm actually surprised
that for Earth
they aren't just looking at Landing it
horizontally on a Runway like the space
shuttle
oh
I mean interesting that worked the brand
did it you know the Soviet Union's put
on I rolled my arm real hard there sorry
wow wow really good I'm very impressed
and uh you know the Branded it do we
have other space planes like the x37b we
have the upcoming Sierra Nevada's Dream
Chaser uh it's yeah you have some extra
mass in the wings but so does Starship
Starship has the extra mass of those
flaps and you know the the motors and
the hinges and all that stuff I I would
like to see the trade on like is it
actually lighter weight
to do that versus doing what SpaceX is
doing
so yeah I mean that's that's the funny
thing I think realistically if Elon
walks in the door tomorrow and says guys
we did some simulations and actually
it's like we can get another 5 000
kilograms into space if we just land it
horizontal if we kind of give up on our
ego and land horizontally at least on
Earth
then you know I think they could be
doing that pretty quickly because that's
the thing is uh this ultimate thing has
been to land on Mars and you know other
planets and Mars doesn't have a Runway
doesn't have a you know thick enough
atmosphere to utilize aerodynamic flight
like that so you have to do propulsive
Landing for Mars
um you're going to land on an unprepared
surface you know so it has to be able to
do this at some point the ultimate it
sounds ridiculous and it is but the
ultimate goal of it is to land on Mars
there's not much of an atmosphere to
like to help you with the for the belly
fat to be useful there's only one
percent the atmosphere on Mars as there
is on Earth but you still want to
utilize as much of that atmosphere as
possible so in the upper atmosphere it's
still going to be coming in more or less
uh kind of perpendicular to the
Airstream I guess it's probably more
like you know 60 degrees 70 degrees to
the Airstream like where it's belly
flopping and it's going to especially do
that on Mars it's going to need to you
know use up as let the little bit of
atmosphere there is you know you're
coming in at insane velocities and so
even that one percent thin atmosphere is
still going to do a lot of work now on
Mars that there's only 38 of Earth's
gravity on Mars so the belly flop
maneuver is a lot it could be a lot more
conservative you could do that at like 5
000 feet up and it just wouldn't matter
as much because there's not as much
gravity loss or gravity drag so you can
kind of just more more slowly gently you
know you don't have to do this crazy
extravagant like belly flop you know
flip maneuver but it would still
something at some point you would
transition from more or less
perpendicular to the Airstream to you
know horizontal to Landing vertically I
like how we're having this old boring
conversation about the differences of
landing on Earth versus on Mars
uh this is surreal that this is actually
a real conversation
but this is something that we're
discussing yeah because it has to do
both yeah but in my opinion yes I think
we'll pretty quickly see an evolution of
Starship that's like dedicated versions
for certain tasks sure and at the end of
the day again if if it's if someone runs
the simulation says it's actually more
efficient and it's better just to land
horizontally on a Runway then that's
what's gonna happen you know it it
doesn't matter but they still will
develop you know if the ultimate goal is
to land on Mars and they'll have a
dedicated Mars variant you know which
will likely look different than the
earth variant you know and they'll still
probably be launched on the same booster
you know what I mean so there's Oh you
mean like that particular vehicle will
not be returning back to Earth it'll
need to be modified because uh because
the ultimate is to have one Starship
that goes to Mars lands on Mars and
takes off of Mars lands back on Earth
and is reused again yeah over and over
and over and there's a chance that you
you know you have just a cycler just a
you know if you're if you at the end of
the day you're just really trying to see
what is most feasible what's the most
efficient you literally have a vehicle
dedicated to Mars Mars it's easy to do a
single stage to orbit it's a lot lower
gravity a lot thinner atmosphere you can
easily do a single stage orbit you get
into orbit you park to a dedicated you
know transfer vehicle that goes between
Earth and Mars it only stays in space
you don't have heat shields you don't
have Landing Lakes you don't have all
these things that you need and ideally
it's nuclear powered so it's super
efficient that gets you back to earth
once you're at Earth you Rendezvous
again with another Landing Starship and
that Starship might be horizontal Runway
Starship you know like yeah there's no I
I don't see the and I think ultimately
it'll win out where we don't have a one
size fits all I think that's that's the
flaw of the Space Shuttle really is that
it was trying to do everything and ended
up kind of doing nothing well but that's
I think what SpaceX has proven I mean
SpaceX already has variants coming
there's already going to be a dedicated
lunar lander for NASA for the Artemis
program there's already going to be a
tanker variant there's already going to
be likely just a pure cargo version
there's likely going to be a human
version we'll likely see evolutions of
this thing happen you know relatively
quickly
and one once it's all working it's only
a matter of weeks before people riding
on it will be complaining about the
speed of the Wi-Fi
as the old like uh Lucy K joke with like
where you're flying on a chair through
the air it's incredible you didn't even
know this existed and now you're
complaining about it oh that's great
exactly uh so you yeah you tweeted fun
fact about Starship by doing the flip
around 500 meters versus higher up like
two two thousand meters the difference
in Delta V is 500 meters per second
that's a 20 ton fuel saving which means
basically 20 tons more you can put into
orbit that's more than uh Falcon 9 has
ever launched just by flipping later
that's really interesting so there that
that was a decision too to flip close to
the ground yeah yeah be closer to the
ground the better the more again the
more the atmosphere is doing work and uh
you know we get into that video really
dives into like gravity losses and
gravity drag the more time you're spent
every every second that your rocket
engine is running Earth is stealing 9.8
meters per second of acceleration
against you there's just inherently 9.8
meters per second squared of
acceleration so every second that engine
is running
the first a big majority of your thrust
is actually being just stolen by Earth's
gravity well
so if you're the longer you're fighting
that the more inefficient it is so ID I
mean the best thing would be you flip at
you know 100 meters off the ground you
light all your engines to maximum thrust
you pull 50 G's you know you land on a
dime basically obviously there's no
margin there there's you know and
there's diminishing returns on that that
gravity loss thing in your high thrust
weight ratios so that's a pretty good
compromise like yes it looks scary but
they could be a lot more aggressive with
that yeah and squeeze out even a little
bit better performance but there are
diminishing returns so that's kind of
the magic number we've seen so far today
but we'll likely see that you know be
played with
you've attended uh some of these what
does it feel like to see Starship in
person first of all when it's just uh
sitting there stacked and second of all
one is doing some of these tests some of
these maneuvers
well first off if you have the freedom
of traveling and happen to live within a
reasonable either by plane or car it's
worth going down to South Texas it's so
Starbase is right on the border of
Mexico and the United States and very
southern tip of Texas right along the
Rio Grande
and uh it's it's insane because it's
right along a public Highway you can
literally anyone can drive down this
assuming it's not closed for testing
because they do close the highways
during the week a decent amount while
they're doing tests but Sands any of
those days anyone can just drive down
and see these things up close and
personal with their own eyes like we're
talking you know from
100 200 meters away you know so two
football fields away from the world's
biggest most powerful rocket imagine
being able to do that during the you
know Soviet Union and you know during
the N1 and the Saturn V you know imagine
just being able to drive up right next
to the launch pad there's no way you
know and so
to have this kind of access to to this
program is so incredible the craziest
thing is when you when you're driving
out on the on Highway 4 it's
bumpy it's it's you know riddled with
potholes now because of all the insane
amount of trucks having to go out there
and traffic and you're going through
this it's just this weird you're like
where am I you occasionally you're
seeing like you can kind of see that I
mean you can see Mexico out your right
window as you're driving down this
highway you know you're just sitting
there like where am I and then all of a
sudden you kind of turn this corner and
the trees and the brush kind of clear
out and obviously you get a sense of
everything on the horizon at that point
you're pretty much five miles on the
nose or eight kilometers away and from
there you can just see through the the
heat Haze through the you know the
atmospheric Distortion and you just see
this weird like it looks like a city
almost on the horizon you know there's
tons of these tall buildings there's a
weird ominous launch Tower thing With
Arms Wide Open and sometimes and you
know a giant metal rocket and it just
looks so so weird I mean it is it's the
word surreal I think by definition I
think if you are expecting it it's not
surreal I think surreal kind of means
like unexpected surprise or whatever you
know even if you're expecting it even if
you've seen pictures even if everything
it is surreal yeah you stand there and
you just go what is this and and also I
mean there is a there's a kind of
magical aspect to the the this is the
place where over the next few years
we'll start
as a human species reaching out there
that's traveling out there we'll for
sure see the development of the rockets
that I think will take us further than
ever before
be born right there what's it like to
witness the actual testing of of
Starship
so far it's been high stakes
like it's it's been insane because those
the the first I kind of mentioned
earlier there's been sn8 9 10 11 and 15
that have all done these suborbital hops
the highest one went 12.5 kilometers and
the rest of the four went 10 kilometers
in altitude and then turned off the
engines and just fell now the cool thing
about that is the general public could
be about five five miles away so again
like eight kilometers away
and the weird thing is this Rocket's
slowly accelerating they didn't want to
exceed a certain speed so they didn't
have to worry about the aerodynamics of
it you know they just slowly climbed and
it probably also to appease the FAA
they're like here we'll just limit the
thrust away ratio and just you know make
make it so it's slow and controlled no
big deal
so it's basically more or less like
slightly above a hover just climbing
forever for minutes for like four or
five minutes you just hear and feel the
Roar of this thing normal Rockets like
after the first 30 seconds or minute you
know they're so far away that you're
just diminishing you know it's just it's
just fading fading fading fading you
still get that Rumble that that sense
but but those first five flights uh the
suborbital Hops were just I'll cherish
them forever because you just you're
watching this thing that you've driven
up next to you've seen it with your own
eyes that's bigger than most buildings
in a you know fairly dense urban area
you know it's this massive thing you
stay in the you stood there you look at
it you're like wow that's crazy you've
seen people working on it they're little
ants compared to it then you drive away
and you see it on the horizon and all of
a sudden that thing leaves it starts
moving hovering hovering essentially and
the first time I mean
you know you put for me at least I put
my hands on my head when I I just I
can't help it I'm not it's not so I
don't know like you said
I don't know what in human nature
decides this is what to do when you
can't believe something but that's what
happens and when that thing first took
off it was just like my brain couldn't
process
seeing you know because I had spent so
much time driving around and seeing it
and all of a sudden you're watching it
just take off and you're like it's
moving and all these you know the most
complicated rocket engines ever made are
all firing simultaneously and it didn't
blow up on the launch pad and slowly
increasing
and it's just crazy and the sound the
everything about it and so by the time
the first one is specifically it was it
was December 2020 was the first uh sn8
it went up and I actually we all lost it
in the sky we couldn't quite see it but
our we had telescopes and and you know
High telephoto lenses tracking it and
what's funny is there's a pretty strong
wind up there at altitude
and it was moving there's a lot of um
gaseous oxygen being vented out of the
rocket and it's you know being blown by
this air so it looks like it's moving
actually quite quickly like away from us
like a strafing to one side so I'm
watching the monitor I'm going oh my God
they're moving it like over Brownsville
and we're all all of us everyone on this
this hotel balcony is looking out down
like way out over you know and we can't
find it we're like where did they lose
it like we're thinking like oh my God
this is gonna crash down in Brownsville
and and finally they shut the engines
off and were watching it fall and again
we're tracking it we know it's falling
and it's falling falling it's falling
super controlled and we're like oh my
God this is perfect
and all of a sudden it clicked and I see
it with my you know my eyes I finally
like track and it's it's straight out
like straight in front of us and it
looks like it looks like it was a blimp
just barely moving now because it is
Falling Slowly thanks to all of its drag
and again that's one of those moments
I'm like it's falling so slow you know
because it's so big it's so massive it's
falling sideways you know I've seen
Falcon 9 boosters and Falcon heavy
boosters and they scream they come in so
fast and you can barely even see we can
just barely track them almost they light
their engines and they they decelerate
so quickly this was like the opposite it
was like
is that thing ever coming down it was
just falling so slowly and so right
there just felt like it was so close and
so when it finally lit its engine and it
flipped I was losing my mind because I'm
like it's working you know this crazy
plan this huge massive thing is doing
this absurd feat and the first one well
the first four again didn't work out as
planned but getting to that point
already getting to that flip maneuver
was a huge milestone and it was so
exciting just going through those those
firsts were amazing and I think you know
we're coming up now on them doing the
full stacks of the booster and the upper
stage
I think when we see that fly when that
leaves Earth for the first time it'll be
like I said almost twice the amount of
thrust as anything else it'll be the
biggest heaviest largest thing to ever
fly it's going to shake everything I
can't wait to have all 33 Raptor engines
uh been active at once have they tested
that no that's coming up that's kind of
the next Milestone um I don't know you
know when this will come out but we're
that's like the next just a few days
very quickly here it then but if people
listen to this if they're listening to
it early on they'll likely be able to
catch you know I think at this point it
seems like next week so step one would
be static fire yep holding onto the
rocket and lighting up the engines and
so so far they've lit at most they kind
of they went for like a more than 14
engine static fired I don't recall if it
was like you know 16 or something
engines lit at once and they ended up
going down to 14 engines that's the most
engines they've ever lit
um so the next step and the final kind
of Step before they they fly this thing
is they're actually going to light all
33 engines simultaneously and although
that sounds scary let's not forget the
Falcon heavy that's now flown five times
completely flawlessly
um has has 27 engines running
simultaneously so they definitely have
you know SpaceX has experience with high
number of engines running at the same
time but it is still like this is going
to be a lot of moving parts and a lot of
potential and a lot just a lot of
everything uh what are the upcoming
uh Milestones expected milestones and I
think um there's one in particular I'd
like to talk to you more about but
leading up to that of course is like
what what are some of the tests here on
the way so this is the static fire uh
the the the fully stacked with the two
stages
uh will there be uh and then all that
leading to an orbital
launch test uh what so what other things
you should know about and what do you
think like what what do you think the
timeline will be with like the orbital
test timeline uh the reason we have this
website the expected Milestones is
because I always tell people to ignore
any time you ever hear for any of this
stuff yeah just pay attention to
Milestones because when you're doing
stuff for the first time you know you
just have no idea so just to understand
the expected Milestones here the First
Column is the event the the second
columns the date and Status TBD complete
green means what green means it's been
completed and it shows the completion
date there and the completion date yeah
and then the others
maybe maybe more maybe not the full full
stack testing the d-stack and the
there's a 33 engine so so realistically
we're expecting them to de-stack and
SpaceX I think just tweeted that
actually they're going to be de-stacking
um the second stage from the first stage
kind of get the ship safe while they
test because they don't want to you know
33 engines is pretty high risk if they
do blow up the rocket when they test it
for the first time it's not going to be
fully fueled I don't think at least but
there is a limit to how they do have to
have it weighed down enough that the
launch clamps can hold on to it because
if you think about it like normally the
launch clamps are holding on to an
entire rocket weighing 5 million
kilograms 5 million I get you know it's
weighing an insane amount so those
clamps don't actually have to hold 75
Mega Newtons of thrust they really want
to have to hold down 25 Mega Newtons of
thrust you know what I mean they're not
designed to hold down all 75. so they do
have to have enough weight on the rocket
so that so even when they do these the
testing of the 33 engines it'll have to
have enough propellant in there that
they don't exceed the clamping and the
holding force of the stand otherwise
it'll break free from the launch stand
and that booster will go flying off
uncontrolled so it's a difficult thing
to figure out in the test how many uh
simultaneous things you test right so
they're kind of mitigating risks which
is why like they're d-stack you know
they don't want to have although the
ship could be on top of it to help weigh
it down and simulate the you know the
launch environment better at some point
that's a risk they're just going to take
when they go for launch and so for now
they're taking the ship off in case
something goes wrong during the 33
engine test and then once we see if the
33 engine test goes well hopefully we
see the the second stage get stacked
back on it we'll see him get closer like
closing out all the items and hope the
big one too is the FAA launch license
there that's a that'll be publicly filed
we'll see that you know in the system uh
having a launch license and I I have no
sense in that type of thing you know
that's outside of but that's but that is
a big milestone and it might be
something that could potentially hinder
uh you know hold up the launch date
would just be waiting for a launch
license
yeah I'm sure there's a lot of
fascinating bureaucracy and politics and
uh
legal stuff and all that kind of
beautiful magical thing when you live in
reality uh because it is I mean it is a
big
uh rocket yeah one the biggest thing
it's not so much the fa doesn't
necessarily care about the success of
the rocket they just really just care
about the safety of public and public
property you know so it's it's it's a
matter of being convinced and having the
the data to prove okay if this thing
blows up we have a control of how and
when it blows up we have control of you
know X Y and Z here's the potential
damage here's the blast radius you know
this again is over twice as powerful and
twice as much potential actually it's
it's a lot more potential for uh an
explosive energy if it you know where it
happened to well let me walk back a
little because in order to have a real
detonation you have to have a perfect
mixture ratio of your fuel and oxidizer
um if when a rocket blows up typically
you know it kind of unzips and some of
the fuel will mix into some of the
oxidizer and you could have some
explosive energy but a lot of it's
actually just a deflagration it's just
you know flames and and yeah there will
there would be explosive energy but it's
not like you're lighting all of it
simultaneously it's this giant bomb it's
just really not so that's good but at
the same time even in those
circumstances the amount of energy is
still absurd enough to likely blow out
windows you know for miles and miles and
miles including my studio space
uh well if the cameras hold up it would
be one heck of a show hopefully of
course would not uh would not happen so
how does that take us to an orbital
launch when do you think that would
happen
in in my opinion uh this is a very fluid
and this will change literally by the
hour so you really think that it's very
difficult to really say like even even
for something that could very well
happen this year even just a few months
away
um making a prediction uh by the way you
like superstitious on this kind of stuff
a little bit like you don't you're
worried about jinxing it and that kind
of stuff no
um because I would imagine you would be
like waiting for all of these launches
that keep getting delayed or you start
thinking that there's certain things you
do will control the weather my socks I'm
wearing these socks I just scrubbed
again you know like yeah you're lucky
you have to wear the same lucky socks
otherwise it's going to there's going to
be bad weather yeah so the reason that I
say this and why it's so difficult is
they did a first full stack test in July
of 2021 and the expectation was we're a
month or two away from a launch yeah so
like realistically for 18 months I've
been in a Purgatory thinking that we're
a month or two away of an orbital launch
now I did say for the record heard when
that thing stacked and when a lot of
speculation was saying you know a month
or two I was saying I don't expect it to
fly in 2021. you know and I've been just
say I just saw the amount of work that
still needed to be done like on the
ground systems the tanks the the launch
Mount all the stuff I'm sitting there
like there's still a lot of stuff
they're gonna have to validate it
they're gonna have to test everything
every component and you know people were
like how dare you say that even Gwen
Shotwell the president of SpaceX is
saying Q3 of 2021 I'm like okay but like
I'm just I'm not gonna be surprised if
it slips into 2022. and here we are the
beginning of 2023 and I I think we're
finally within like two months
I I'm expecting like I'm trying to keep
my March in April as free as I can
we'll put it that way
I love it uh actually just in a small
tangent on uh going like what what do
you uh uh from everything I know she's
an instrumental a really crucial person
to the success of SpaceX in running the
show she's the president the CEO
um what uh do you know about her that um
sort of the genius of Gwen Shotwell man
my understanding is she's really the
glue you know she's the glue to the
tornado
tornado comes in and then she comes
around and just really executes on on
and and helps
you know a famous story is that at some
point Elon walked in or she's sprinted
into a meeting because Elon was actively
trying to cancel Falcon heavy saying
it's too far like it's too much
development we're it's still too far
away and this is like
you know this might have been like end
of 2017 or something and it flew for the
first time in 2018. so we're talking
like it's close to the end of
development you know there's Hardware
being built all this stuff and elon's
literally in a meeting telling people
they're going to cancel it and we're
going to move on to bfr or no Starship
um and just go full steam ahead on that
and she runs into the meeting and
reminds Elon we have X amount of
customers that have already purchased a
ride on Falcon heavy we can't delay that
you know so it's it's that business
sense of like we yes it's great to
innovate but we also have to pay our
dues and and make the money to continue
our operations and I think she's just a
lot better at
she has I think she has such a great
perspective on everything it really
seems like everything she doesn't I wish
she did more interviews because I would
love to hear more from her um but man
like it just hear that Gwen
both of us yeah she hasn't actually done
that many interviews right not really no
she's done like a TED Talk
um a couple little things here and there
but not really
many interviews and I would just love to
hear like what you know what on a daily
basis like what is she doing to keep
her head on and keep everything so
organized you know it's
you know but yeah I I my understanding
is that she she is absolutely integral
and does just a insane amount of work in
SpaceX yeah I mean the so it's the the
project planning but also the how the
teams integrate together and the and and
the hiring and this is the matter I
think it's a lot of it's honestly even
just the business making sure the
money's flowing in a positive trend more
or less you know that yes elon's
obviously a money guy but he thinks he's
so I think Elon is so risky you know he
just loves to throw it all in
that he leaves little margin for error
you know he's he's been really lucky
with rolling his dice you know
especially like when he started SpaceX
and Tesla that was the ultimate role of
the dice but I think she's a healthy
balance to be like well here's our you
know operations and now we can continue
to do this without risking everything
you know and starship's close let me be
clear Starship is close to risking
everything already it's just such a big
fast-moving high-risk developmental
program that like
I I personally think you know SpaceX
would probably be fine if they shut the
doors on Starship and just flew Falcon 9
and Falcon heavy for the next 10 years
they would still be commercially valid
they could not spend another dollar on
research and development they could fire
I don't want them to fire everyone
involved in anything research
involvement and just ran operations on
Falcon 9 and Falcon heavy and they would
still be dominant for 10 years and they
would still have a business case and
they'd still be fine
but
um they're all in like all chips are
pretty much as many chips as possible
are in
I don't know
what else I could say is there's not
I've talked to a lot of uh great leaders
there's just not many people like Elon
that would push for Starship
when they're already when it's already
had a very successful company yeah uh
sort of everyone doubted that it could
be a successful company it was so close
to bankruptcy and failing and then to
take it into a financially viable
successful company and just when you do
you take on a project that again risks
everything
when he already did this with Falcon 1
to Falcon 9. like literally people were
like what are you doing they basically
signed over and were fully ramping up
Falcon 9 by the time they finally had
their first Falcon one success they had
one more flight they only flew [__]
one successfully twice they flew five
times all together the fourth one was
successful and they flew one more time
and the anyone else out there would have
been like let's keep flying the Falcon
one we have a working rocket we can
start you know making money and
profiting and already he was risking it
all and saying nope we're going from
Falcon one to Falcon 9 it was a huge
huge leap you know it was that I think
it's at least as big as a leap from
Falcon one to nine as it is from Falcon
9 to Starship or around relatively a
similar leap so it's just that same
thing again people are going why are you
leaping into this insane program and
system and risk when you have such a you
know you finally have this Workhorse of
a rocket that's so dominant in the
industry
yet they're going
10x you know
it so happens that you've been selected
for the dear moon mission that will fly
Starship once around the Moon with nine
people on board
uh you are one of those people so
just pause to take that in
everything that we've been talking about
you will not just be reporting on you'll
be a part of it
so tell me about the objective of this
Mission and um how does it feel to be a
part of it
well
[Laughter]
man
yeah yeah it's
basically
it's the Willy Wonka of space like
generous yeah a generous individual
purchased a ride from SpaceX as early uh
at least as far as I know the earliest I
knew about it was February 27 2017.
who's the individual uh you sakumai
isawa but at the time I'm telling a
story at the time we didn't know okay
great great so February 27 2017 a press
release comes out from SpaceX saying
someone purchased a ride
through us around the Moon
we're gonna fly someone around the moon
and if the time is on a crew Dragon
capsule and a falcon heavy
it's like wow and that was enough that
little moment right there that's press
release it's the first time I'm like I'm
gonna make a YouTube video about this
and it stood up turn on my camera put on
my at the time spacesuit and I basically
yelled at the camera for three minutes
about someone's going around the Moon
you know
fast forward to 2018 uh end of 2018 or
near the end they introduced there's a
SpaceX press conference I'm I'm there as
a member of the press I'm reporting on
we're going to meet this person that's
going around the moon and come to find
out boom they're going to be riding on
Starship now they change from Falcon
heavy and Dragon SpaceX is no longer
going to do that they're going to
upgrade them basically to Starship so
instead of being in like a small Tin Can
they're in this giant luxurious you know
Mega rocket around the Moon
and it comes out to this individual
named yusaku mayazawa who is a Japanese
billionaire uh purchased this ride and
instead of inviting you know his friends
and you know colleagues and whatever
whoever's family members or whatever
he decided the the most impactful thing
he could do with this opportunity is
invite
uh more or less artists in the original
thing it was like artists you know
journalist a painter a an athlete a you
know a all you know photographer
videographer you know all walks of life
basically when they said athlete they
thought of you they're like
this guy rode rugby once
but uh so and at the time you know I was
like this is crazy I can't believe this
is gonna happen and you know he had this
this vision of we're gonna find people
from all around the world I'm going to
invite people from all around the world
um from different walks of life
different different you know trades and
I'm going to share this experience so
that they can share it with the world
and really have an impact much greater
than you know any one country or any one
individual or any you know set of
military trained you know astronauts
could could do offer up A New
Perspective
beautiful I literally I mean at the
press conference I I cried like I had a
couple tears in my eyes I was like this
is so so we could just pause on that so
he goes by MZ MZ yep
how incredible is that it's I like uh I
I think it's
you often don't realize the importance
of individuals in human history like
they they Define because this this could
be we were talking about the importance
of Elon in particular you know most of
the work is done by large groups of
people there are collective intelligence
that we band together but like these
individuals can
be the spark of the Catalyst of that
progress and I mean just this idea of
getting
not just civilians which is already
incredible but civilians with a sort of
an artistic flame that burns inside them
they're able to communicate whatever
they do are able to communicate
something about that experience and it's
just a genius idea to spend quite
probably a very large amount of money
for that I mean it's uh it's it's it's
it and it does and that will be part of
History yeah and it's easy these days
for people to be cynical you know
especially about like space flight and
Wealthy individuals but really in my
opinion and maybe you know just the time
I was just so couldn't believe this this
idea
you know I'm someone that has studied a
lot about you know the Apollo program
the people that have been to the moon
and they're incredible individuals
incredible individuals but they're so
saturated with tasks you know and
they're military trained and often
um that they didn't really have the
luxury of just being able to soak in the
experience of going around or to the
Moon
and seeing the Moon up close with your
own eyes like that just psychologically
has to be insane
and so to have this opportunity to be
able to observe our closest Celestial
neighbor with their own eyes and your
sole purpose is to soak it in and share
it and communicate and create
with the rest of our planet like that to
me is just beautiful
so that is the objective of the mission
that right there is the objective of the
mission and how does it feel to be
selected as uh one of the nine to do it
it's it's it's a it's a gradient it's
slowly it's doing a few things
um since I've known it's become
um I think the closer it gets the more
excited and the more nervous I get
you know it's a more real it becomes the
more real it becomes you know the
announcement was a big uh it just got
announced at the end of 2022 publicly
um who's involved and so you know prior
to that like I had you know each step of
the selection process you know there's a
pretty comprehensive selection process
with interviews and stuff each each step
I'd try not to get my hopes up and
frankly like this let me be clear this
was not something that like I've always
wanted to do you know it's not like I'm
out there I didn't start doing YouTube
videos because I wanted to even go to
space like none of that I and I've said
hilariously I probably said dozens or
hundreds of times on air like yeah I
don't ever want to go to space because
it's not like my it's not a driving
force it's not really anything I even
really truly pictured or let myself
fantasize about frankly
so each step of the selection process I
didn't really let myself dream about it
too much or you know but kind of it
would kind of chip away like oh my God
this is actually becoming more real this
is actually more and more of an
opportunity and I get equally more
nervous too like you know frankly it is
it's I've you know I've seen space
flight stuff go wrong I've you know I
think about this stuff a lot so like
yeah I get more nervous but I also get
more excited about that opportunity like
it's an opportunity that how can you
pass and it's still I still have to
actually stop pause think
and actually realize the reality that
like that I am going to the Moon I'm
going to see the Moon up close uh flying
around the Moon I'm sorry some people
get mad when I say going to the moon
since I'm not landing on it
um but flying around the Moon seeing The
Far Side of the Moon with my own eyes
and seeing Earth
and seeing the Earth rise behind it
yeah it's going to I just I can't I
can't tell you what it's going to be
like and feel like so epic but it's
insane to me that like we're having this
conversation that that is my my reality
you know like and that someone was
generous enough to consider the option
of sharing this with with frankly
strangers yeah and the the process that
they had for selecting like how
um how much thought and time went into
the selection process is incredible you
know they did a public call at the
beginning of 2021. and so the teams
involved in in whittling it down from a
million applicants there's a million
applicants that will do and they got it
down to to eight crew members and and
two backups yeah
um amazing people I would have you know
I don't know how they wound up where
they did but it's it's incredible I feel
a very deep connection to everyone
that's already involved in what can you
say about the crew you've gotten the
chance to meet them and talk to them and
Steve aoki's on the crew like well who
else who else is there so uh you are
obviously the the star athlete who else
in terms of the the artists that are
there so oh man we might just want to
pull up just so I don't totally Butcher
and forget anybody but because so far I
haven't actually had the chance to meet
everyone in person you know so far a lot
of this was done during the pandemic but
we've met through a couple different
things we've had a couple different
times to get together but so so far I
have not met Steve Aoki yet or top
um we've been on calls and stuff I also
have not yet met uh Dev Joshi who is uh
an actor from India so yeah I mean Steve
Aoki American DJ and producer and
musician top from uh South Korea is also
uh a musician and a producer so it's all
across the world it's a truly Global uh
all different kinds of walks of life
yeah all artists of different forms and
Steve is is Japanese uh his parents are
Japanese but he you know lit born raised
in the United States uh yemi is a dancer
and choreographer from the Czech
Republic uh Rhiannon is a fine art
photographer from well England in in
Ireland I guess she lives in both in
kind of a bit of a she's all over the
place uh Technically she's Irish I guess
uh I Tim Dodd yep that's me from the
United States uh uh then you have Kareem
who is from England and does also as a
photographer and documentarian uh does a
lot of work with oceanography and uh
volcanoes so he does really incredible
work Brendan Hall is a documentarian and
filmmaker Dev Joshi sorry Brendan is
also from the United States Deb Joshi is
an Indian actor
I believe also I believe he's also
already been producing and things he's
very young I think he's only like 19 or
20 and he's I mean he's been acting
since he was like five years old or
something he's a he's a Bollywood star
like he is a star in India which is
really cool right
um Caitlyn Farrington from the United
States is an Olympic gold medalist
snowboarder
so she believe it or not is the athlete
not me
and then uh and she's one of the backup
crew members as as so is uh Miu from
Japan who's a dancer
oh it's amazing I mean it's such an
interesting group I mean can you is
there something else you could say about
MZ I'll buy you a soccer you sakamaizawa
so he uh he's also a musician so he was
actually in like some kind of punk
hardcore Japanese bands in the early in
the 90s and stuff and early 2000s he
started a um a record company and and
distribution and sales ended up in in
fashion and um owns one of the biggest
fashion companies in Japan and has
become a fine art collector and just
kind of a philanthropist and he's been
out to space already he's already not
only been to space like you know he's
been to the International Space Station
he's been on orbit and on the ISS and so
he what's cool is like you know there's
talks of when they're then frankly to be
to be honest like we still don't I still
don't know all of the details about this
you know we're not yet into training I
kind of always assumed prior that
there'd be some professional astronaut
you know when they talked about in 2018
there's talks of we'll have a
professional astronaut on board
but realistically now like MZ is a
trained astronaut you know he has
trained a lot like six months you know
plus to be able to fly on soyuz so as
far as like it's good to know for me
that I have someone
on the crew that has experience with
space flight
um has trained and has some knowledge on
space flight as well you know that's
that is an important aspect for sure so
you made a excellent video about flying
in the fighter jet uh that I think you
mentioned may be relevant uh to the
training is there some high level
aspects to training that you anticipate
that you might be able to speak to yeah
so you know so far I think we can really
lean on what has happened with the other
um you know commercial crew missions and
in in private missions like the
inspiration form Mission or Axiom uh
where SpaceX flew individually they
trained for about six months a lot of
like reading manuals and learning the
spacecraft are you gonna do like a Rocky
4 Montage or
a lot of physical training and they're
like we didn't tell them to do it he's
just seems to want to film himself
shirtless in the snow it doesn't make
any houses always doing this I can't get
him to stop punching me
um so yeah hopefully uh
realistically
I like it but there's there's a physical
component to all of this and that's
that's really I mean that that's
fascinating it's also inspired in the
sort of civilians
can do this that's that's really
interesting yeah I mean this is and to
me this represents this and the other
commercial space you know uh private
space flight missions like this
represent really a turning point like
truly an inflection and again it's easy
for people to be cynical that
oh you know why are people wasting all
this money doing space flight stuff it's
like well I'm sure some people were
saying that same thing about you know
airplanes and and early Aviation going
like why are we I can't believe those
people are wasting the government's you
know funding these stupid planes and
stuff how's this ever going to benefit
me and nowadays like imagine if all the
planes just stopped working like would
freak out like our economy would
collapse yeah it would suck you know and
I you know might be a long time before
we get to that reality with space fight
well I know if if spaceflight halted
today you know space assets uh all of
our you know on-orbit assets our life
would be crippled and I don't think
people realize that yeah so it's already
we're already reliant on it but now
we're getting to the point where it's
we're really turning that corner where
it's the average person alive today you
know if you're born uh you know now or
from now on I think there's a real
decent chance that by the time you pass
There's an opportunity to have flown in
space
yeah I mean I if I'm being honest I
still haven't lost the the feeling of
magic of flying in an airplane I often
catch myself thinking like how is this
real
how is it and like
the contrast of this incredible thing
that's incredibly safe flying through
the air taking off and Landing while
everyone else just looks bored
watching like I don't know uh some
romantic comedy on their phone with
Wi-Fi yeah so yeah it's just it's like
the contrast of that is like wow we're
we're incredible we're incredible as a
society and it's like we we develop some
amazing technology that improves almost
the measurably our quality of life and
then we take it for granted and now
still reach for the next thing and the
next thing and life becomes more
beautiful and complex and interesting
and yeah it's just the same stuff will
be uh happening oh yeah uh with space
travel oh it'll become mundane and
boring at some point the tough thing
about space travel of course
uh you know I don't even know if it's
such a giant leap over airplanes because
airplanes are already incredible but uh
the tough thing with space travel is the
destination right is the is the is the
landing on a whole lot of the worlds
well there's docking with with different
transport vehicles or the space station
or it's Landing elsewhere I mean it's
it's it it really really is incredible I
I think you mentioned since there's uh
there's artists there's filmmakers and
so on
and you're all of those
on top of being a great athlete I don't
know I'll just stop the running joke at
this point uh but is there have you uh
thought about
um just just in general like we've
offline talked about microphones and
like all the different ways to film
space launch uh for the rocket launches
uh have you thought about the different
options of like how to capture
how to capture this uh uh have you have
the team have been like brainstorming
and thinking about this do you
anticipate it being super challenging
because there's so many opportunities to
sort of think of how to do this so one
of the fun things to remember is that
Starship is huge like its internal
volume is uh the pressurized volume on
Starship is is bigger than a 747s
pressurized volume and it can take a
hundred metric tons to anywhere with
enough refueling 100 so we have in
theory very little mass and volume
constraints unlike prior all other space
flight missions ever you you think
you're counting you know grams down to
you know and just really can't risk you
know you have very defined parameters on
on what you can and cannot do
we're going to likely have the luxury of
being able to film and capture this in a
way that's just never been done before
you know we won't be inhibited by mass
and volume constraints like prior yeah
so
all that said and done I'm hoping that
we'll be able to just arm ourselves to
the teeth with the absolute best cameras
and Equipment possible backups on
backups and
you know on pre-wire you know like
pre-rig things Starship is going to be a
transportation system and it has you
know it's being built from the ground up
there's no reason why they can't
put infrastructure in for cameras that
are just housed in the vehicle you know
um these are talks that I'm excited to
have because I really ideally one of the
things I'd love to do I'm going to be
pushing really hard to actually try live
streaming
from inside during the launch
during the launch live stream from the
inside that would be incredible wouldn't
that be
it's possible to pull off that's really
really incredible now there is the magic
to the live stream because like that's
real that's right there that would the
world would tune in that would be truly
inspiring yes to me that's one of those
things a lot of people ask why they
aren't doing it of course NASA and other
individuals have their reasons of why
not you know there's obviously some
technical hurdles but now with starlink
and other capabilities there's
less hurdles there's obviously some
transparency reasons why you know on
safety reasons why it might not be a
great idea to live stream a risky rocket
launch you know the Challenger I think
put a pretty bad
tasting our mouth as far as publicizing
an event and having every student in the
United States tune in to you know
tragedy but
um that's something I'm pushing for
really hard just because I think it
could be magical I think it could really
connect with people in a way that hasn't
been done before speaking of Challenger
have you thought about the fact that
you're riding
a thing as we've been talking about
that's
um
that's a giant explosive powerful rocket
have you um
have you thought about the risk of that
the danger of that
have you contemplated your own mortality
how could I not you know I've seen with
my I've seen and felt
four of these prototype Vehicles blow up
you know with my own eyes
um I don't know if there's anyone else
you know early days some of the you know
Mercury and Gemini astronauts watched
failures of rockets and then got on them
I don't know of too many people that are
dumb enough to do that though these days
this day and age
um it's it's obviously I will have to
see a lot of successful launches and
have to have a lot of
confidence and in the engineering the
data that they've developed a safe
system because currently the current
iteration of Starship Has No abort
system has no
Escape Tower so you know Dragon capsule
which is currently flying people has a
launch abort system it has super Draco
engines that
either by the push of a button or by the
automatic triggering of the flight
computer can shoot the the capsule off
of the rocket in milliseconds and pull
it safely away get it far enough away
that it can pull the parachutes and
safely splash down
um Starship by all iterations I've ever
seen does not have that the space
shuttle also did not have that so it's
not absurd to not have an abort system
like it is there is you know
certain engineering principles that that
prove that that could be a completely
valid thing you know the space shuttle
through 100 flew 133 times fully
successfully it did have two failures
resulting in the loss of 14 lives
85 or sorry 98.5 success rate
pretty I mean yeah you there's other
I've probably done things that are a lot
riskier I have race motorcycles drag
race motorcycles and you know ridden
like an absolute jerk on the streets on
a motorcycle I'm sure I've had a higher
than a 98.5 percent survival rate or
lower than that I mean at some point
um
so it's a you know yes it's it's risky
it's scary
and um
I think about it a lot a lot it
definitely is one of those things that I
you know I I will have to see and I'm
I'm in no hurry for this to happen
either you know personally I'm in no
hurry because it's like I would rather
see this thing be developed and iterated
and see 10 you know or I was gonna say
ten dozen but I'd be happy with a dozen
fully successful like oh we've got this
thing totally nailed down uh you know
before I get on it
but and that that likely is the reality
there will likely be a dozen or two or
three launches because just even to get
to the moon on Starship they have to
refuel it in orbit
um so it will arrive get to Earth orbit
basically empty and out of fuel so I'll
have to dock with a fuel Depot
and then go to the Moon
so
just even get that full you know we're
already talking about you know a handful
of launches so there will be a lot of
launches before we fly would they do a
test flight without humans on board that
goes to the moon or no I'm not sure I'm
not sure if they'll do that exact flight
profile but by then they will have
already flown most likely the Artemis 3
program will have flown a Starship
variant to the Moon that lands on the
moon
um
so doing at that point you're pretty
much I would like them to test the heat
shield of that entry velocity though
because it is uh you know it takes
another it's about 30 percent faster to
get like if you go 30 faster than the
lower third to get out to a translunar
injection and although that only sounds
like oh 30 faster it's you know the the
re-entry heating experienced by a
vehicle goes up by velocity uh cubed not
squared so and not even not linear so
it's not like if you go twice as fast
you get you see twice as much you know
30 faster 30 more heat it's and it's not
squared it's not go twice as fast get
four times as much heat let's go twice
as fast get eight times as much heat on
re-entry so 30 faster on re-entry is
actually a really really big deal
so I would love to see that because you
know there's certain things that I would
love to see Milestones that I would love
to see tested out and proven
um before I get on board but
at the end of the day I really do
believe that um just like Falcon 9 and
the success of that that they're going
to push it and get all the The Kinks out
well before anyone's on top of it
nowadays Falcon 9 and dragon is you know
arguably the
one of the safest most reliable
and best rides you could take to space
are you afraid of dying
yeah yeah is this one of the first times
you get to you're young yeah have you
gotten a chance to think about death is
one of the
first times you've really contemplated
it
I mean yeah I mean
like I said I've had I've had dumb
moments on motorcycles where I kind of
saw you know like I'm going to smash
into this thing at 120 mile an hour and
I'm so you've had moments when you
realize it could end just like this yes
where you literally and I've I have for
most of my adult life had dreams of
falling and hitting the ground and it
just all you get a ring in your ears it
all goes black and in my head I go oh
[__] that was it have you seen a
therapist about this or no I wonder what
it means
I'm sure there's a Freudian
interpretation
but that I'm going to also apply to my
dating life no the joke is it's the
running joke continues okay so um I mean
it's
um it's fascinating in general as I hope
we'll talk about in the early days of
space flight that there is there is a
the task of reaching out to the stars is
a fundamentally risky one you have to
take risk and of course there's really
rigorous safety precautions and so on
but it still is still a risk well and I
think like most people that that for me
the idea of dying isn't so much about
myself it's about those affected by you
know my my loved ones my family you know
my girlfriend my my friends you know
obviously I don't wanted
have this be a traumatic experience for
anybody you know it's already gonna be
hard like it's already I know uh my mom
gets my parents and and family and
friends are very supportive
um and you know my parents are you know
all about it of course but my mom is
also very emotional too so you know
she's so my speaking of athletes my
brother-in-law's actually been on
American Ninja Warrior two seasons
um phenomenal athlete and even just when
he competes my mom gets so emotional
like she can't even hold it together
seeing that so what's it gonna be like
when she sees her son get on top of a
skyscraper and and Ascend on a column of
flames into the heavens like that's
going to be very difficult you know
um
and I I've you know I've taken them out
they've seen they've seen Starbase and
they've seen Starship they've seen a
couple launches I don't know if that's
gonna make them feel better
explain your therapy I guess exposure
therapy okay uh have you had that
conversation with them about this like
before agreeing
uh to join I mean what's what's that
what the what's that or is it one of
those things like
uh you just you don't have that
conversation I suppose it's understood
that there's a love there's a passion
here and and realistically I'm not
uh I'm going to be
convinced and statistically convinced
that this is relatively safe you know
like again in the in the 99s percent
safe yeah again there's things that
people do every day that are
less safe than this you know like you're
riding a motorcycle again yeah riding
motorcycle doing wheelies at over 100
mile an hour it wheelies over 100
what what
all right I'm not a smart guy always
okay
well you know formation flying in the
fighter jets was likely a more dangerous
thing yes then
what I'll be doing in space flight
so as surreal as it is we're talking
about you
um flying around the Moon let's rewind
and talk about the origin story what's
the origin story of everyday astronaut
I used to be a professional photographer
so from 2008 until the end of 2016 that
was my income was photography full time
like you were an Instagram model into
butt pictures of yourself Instagram by
fitness model fitness model obviously
now the uh I I did I did a lot of
weddings I shot 150 weddings
um all around the world so subjects all
kinds of material like uh like uh dude
portrait also a lot of portrait work and
then just you know random like
commercial things like you know food and
beverages for businesses or like you
know uh wheelchair ramp company I shot
their products like you know it's random
whatever a professional photographer
does in Cedar Falls Iowa when did you uh
fall in love with photography with a
visual medium do you remember yeah I do
actually remember I so I I drew up uh I
grew up drawing constantly I I was the
weird kid that might I would bring a
sketch pad to the restaurants like every
restaurant everyone was growing up until
I was like 18 19 I literally would just
sit there and draw or waiting for food
and my parents like fostered that it
would you know and I I'd be the weird
kid but I'd be engaging and talking but
I'd be sitting there drawing and I I was
always obsessed with realism and like
recreating and you know visualizing
things
and so when I got my hands on the
cameras actually my dad's old Pentax
that I first shot a on a film camera and
developing the film I didn't personally
develop it like you know getting the
film back back in those days
um you know I just was like so excited
about the idea that I had this visual
thing that I saw with my own eyes and
now I can stop time and capture it and
and show it to other people just kind of
like to me that was like the ultimate
form of of realism was like literally
showing you the photons basically that
affected this film
um and so I I mean I was I was 19 when I
got my first digital SLR a Canon 20D
and started shooting
um
and yeah I just I I fell in love with it
it became like I got a job at a camera
store and you know basically all my
extra money went into buying everything
that I could at the time and I only
worked there for about exactly a year
before I went into pursuing photography
full-time and
I basically was shooting weddings that I
could travel and pay like you know
afford to be able to
uh do some big trips every year and and
develop some kind of you know portfolio
of traveling and
not necessarily like not for you know I
guess Instagram wasn't much of a thing
at the time it's really just I liked
making big prints and having them
displayed and
that kind of stuff and pretty are you
still a Canon guy you still a Canon
elitist no no I I moved around I I did
Sony for a bit I still kind of shoot
mostly Canon glass but adapted to either
Sony lenses sorry like Canon lenses look
at you
what do you think about the um these
things that I'm using Sony A7 IV great
this is great see yeah it's uh I've uh
I've been you know I Googled around just
trying to find a camera that can do
video and photography pretty well and
obviously going was just like generic
lenses Prime I've resisted everything my
whole journey with these camera thing
I'm trying to figure stuff out is like
prime lenses seems so stupid so for
problem is it's like a fixed Zoom thing
yep it's like why
because I remember I was going to like
Ukraine
and thinking it's similar like uh
um yeah very similar to space flight but
you're very constrained because you're
going into an unknown environment you're
going to a war zone you're going to a
front you don't know what like you don't
know anything right and there's like a
little suitcase you have to like see
figure out like how do you film this
what's what's robust
um what gives you like a good image
versus a flexibility versus the weight
his weight is important there you have
to think about like can you really bring
like a bunch of zoom lenses and all that
kind of stuff so I had to learn really
quickly but yeah I've um
it's a whole journey that you've already
been on but it's nice to have a beginner
like me like to explore that I think
there is a
there's a nice thing just because we've
been talking about with The Beginner's
mind
to um
not let equipment
get in the way of like what your vision
is of what a thing should look like yeah
sometimes like especially if you're a
professional videographer a photographer
cinematographer whatever you call it you
can like fetishize equipment too much
you can get so much equipment and I've
interacted it because I've been trying
to learn from other people that have so
much more experience than me
I think their advice is often like
uh very pushing a lot of equipment
versus like
the final thing like how do you create
the art of it and like because to me
even photography is just like
storytelling and so like a lot of the
discussion to me
that I enjoy uh especially talking to
creative people is like the the final
story like how and I've learned you know
like light light light is a weird thing
like it's so interesting it's so
interesting how you can create emotion
with light like with a little you could
take a
like a phone and like you light your
face in different ways and like it
changes the emotion oh yeah it's so
weird
I'm like holy [__]
like because like that's the
conversation I want to have okay people
give me advice how to light a scene all
that kind of stuff is great but the
reality is that a little bit of light in
a different direction that you have to
understand how that changes the Contour
on your face yeah everything and the
expression that your face can like the
the expression that could be effective
to communicate under under different
lighting conditions and then like the
mystery of like having some of your face
uh in darkness and some not uh when you
can only see the eyes and not the face
when the background is visible or not I
mean there's the the yeah it's yeah it's
all just like this interesting art form
that's can be so powerful when you're
telling a story well and what's fun for
with me with photography and Rockets
they're both like the ultimate story of
compromise because when you start
learning about photography you learn
about you know how the aperture affects
both your exposure but also your depth
of field higher shutter speed affects
both your exposure your depth of field
how the you know of medium format camera
versus a crop camera effects you know
everything is a compromise and price
versus performance like there's always a
compromise you're always literally doing
like a trade study of what can I afford
What's My outcome like blah blah blah
blah how fast is the autofocus or
whatever
same with rockets like there's a million
choices and every single one of them
affects every single thing so there's
always all these trades and it's so cool
you can see uh the same totally
different outcomes based on the same
like requirements you know like do X and
here's how we're gonna do it and you
know two teams of people will come up
with wildly different things when did
you fall in love
With Rockets So yeah so the the story
kind of keeps going for me so I was
doing drugs
can't talk photography man we'll get
we'll go on a deep Rabbit Hole there so
um so it ended uh you know I'm through
all this doing a lot of weddings I was
already getting saturated and feeling
like I'm not being as creative you know
you can only shoot him so many weddings
before you're like well now we do this
pose this pose this pose you know even
if like they're amazing places like you
know in front of a castle in Germany or
something I'm still like well at the end
of the day I'm
I'm not being very creative you know so
I remember craving like some some
projects and so I was sitting at my
friend's coffee shop
in my hometown in Cedar Falls sidecar
coffee and I'm sitting on this red couch
and I see this article from I think
Gizmodo and it said you could own
the flight stick of an Apollo Command
Module
and I knew enough to know what that
meant but that's really about the end of
my space knowledge and so I clicked on
it the click bait got me like I'm like
oh yeah I'm gonna see if you know and I
see that the minimum bid is like 250 000
I'm like okay no I can't own the Apollo
joystick you know but I got me on this
website called RR auction and so I
started scrolling through that looking
for things that hadn't been bid on and
they had that you know at the time
they're doing a huge space auction and
so I'm looking for things just out of
curiosity fun these are cool like it's
starting to really you know like I said
I like space but I wasn't like in love
with it or anything but I'm very just
seeing all the stuff like this is so
cool look at all this old history stuff
ended up seeing a um there's an article
for a
vmstk 44 flight suit high altitude
flight suit that came from the Soviet
Union
and looks you know it's like a MIG
fighter jet fighter pilot suit very
similar to like the SR-71 like kind of
pumpkin suit
um semi-pressure suit with a you know
full helmet I mean it full it looks like
a spacesuit you know for all intents and
purposes it's kind of like a spacesuit
and I just bid on it you know I've been
like I think 325 dollars and next thing
you know like it arrives at my door
yeah and from that point on like
literally I got it out I immediately try
to put it on and the first thing that I
do is almost die in it because I closed
the helmet down on myself and locked it
and didn't know how to unlock it so I'm
literally and so as soon as I seal it up
I'm realizing I can't breathe I'm going
to run out of air so luckily like
there's a hose you know that kind of
that long hose thing that would normally
plug into an Air Supply had a little
plug on the end of it so I just
unplugged it and was able to temporarily
breathe through the hose until I figured
out the locking mechanism
so there was my almost that was my
mortality rate thing right there so that
was probably above a 98 or below
panicking inside yeah for a few seconds
already reading like my premature
obituary like idiot dies alone in space
suit in his living room you know like
just imagine yeah that would be like
Darwin Award for sure for sure oh so um
so I get the spacesuit and it kind of
literally take my breath away
um
you should feel bad for that one you you
introduced Creed to me so you should
feel bad about that one star's wide open
yeah
okay so
um so I ended up like this basically
kind of like more or less haunted me
because it kind of just it sat in like
my living room for a long time and I
didn't know what to do with it and I
actually had a friend who is also a
photographer wanted to do like a photo
he was just kind of taking pictures
randomly he's like hey bring your
spacesuit over we'll do a picture it's
like all right you know I walk across
the street and literally lived across
the street Taylor and I and I put the
spacesuit on I took this funny picture
of me like this is awesome and I got a
lot of like fun out of like creating a
character you know of everyday astronaut
or at the time I guess I didn't know an
astronaut and then that kind of just
continued I was like thinking of more
and more funny situations where I could
have this astronaut on earth doing
mundane everyday things and came up with
the name everyday astronaut and
originally it was just literally a photo
project like this whole art series of an
astronaut doing these things these funny
Whimsical you know Silly mundane things
but I was researching a lot about like
you know I was trying to hide Easter
eggs like I was gonna hide in like the
you know the echocardiogram of of Alan
Shepard you know like his first flight
into space and photoshopping that into
pictures and like you know doing all
these little like facts about space
fight but they're just hidden little
elements in these photos and man doing
that I just fell in love with it I just
was going over every little detail that
I could learn I just couldn't stop
learning and I was I was getting excited
because I was like I could be teaching
people about all this exciting stuff and
all the cool things people figured out
you know 40 years ago 50 years ago and
was trying to portray that through
images on Instagram and you know it it
took me a little while but eventually I
realized you know on Instagram your
retention rate you're lucky if you get
like two seconds of someone looking at
an image you know or maybe nowadays 60
seconds of a quick little Instagram
short or something
but
um
yeah it doesn't give you a chance to
really teach to explore a little topic
that you felt like you felt the
Curiosity about the thing there's so
much to learn here this is so beautiful
there's so many opportunities to have a
light bulb go off for someone to be like
this is awesome
and so uh yeah I think I I started so at
the by the end of 2016 like throughout
2016 I realized I want to be done doing
photography as a profession and I want
to pursue everyday astronaut but I
didn't know what it meant yet I just
knew like I had this thing you know and
at that time I'd been doing it for
roughly two years and had you know seen
I don't know like 50 000 Instagram
followers or something I thought like I
could just be a full-time influencer now
you know like just go around taking
pictures of myself in a spacesuit and
doing public appearances and write a
children's book or something I don't
know I don't know what this thing is
I'll figure it out you know and so
um it basically I gave myself like a
Runway of one year of 2017 of like uh
I'm gonna throw stuff for the wall and
see what sticks
um so I was doing like twitch streams I
was playing Kerbal Space Program uh
which is like a video game like a
physics-based rocket building simulation
game but it's also like it's fun and
silly because you're not playing with
like humans you're playing with these
little Kerbal like little alien guys and
it's fun and silly you know streaming
that on Twitch and doing things and
doing posting some of those things onto
YouTube but finally like I said it
actually happened to be February 27 2017
when SpaceX had that announcement that
their flights went around the Moon that
I'm
I gotta tell people about this and stood
there and made my first like produced
YouTube video and I didn't want it to be
over three minutes
I was afraid that'd be way too long for
YouTube and I got it down to like I
don't know two minutes and 40 seconds or
something and that video uh wearing the
I was wearing the spacesuit yep and very
like horrible audio it looks like it was
color graded by a seven-year-old with a
tan marker or something like it just
looks terrible sounds horrible I'm
yelling no one's happy but
but the video you know did relatively
well like I had no followers on YouTube
like I had you know maybe 102 or
something is the video still up yeah
that's great okay this is so cringy and
as it should be you know your first
video should be terrible if it's not
terrible and you spent too long trying
to make it yeah so
um the the thing that clicked for me is
I had very little audience and all of a
sudden that video kind of took off you
know relatively I think it got like 10
000 or 12 000 views and I was like holy
crap that's way more engagement than I
don't have famous I'm famous now ten
thousand people that's almost my whole
town first of all that is kind of crazy
like 10 000 people is crazy it's crazy
like if you if you had 500 people attend
a thing that you do that would be like
like you're like a rock star it's crazy
we lose perspective right yeah we really
lose perspective very quickly very
quickly so I made another video
um this one I spent more time on and I I
before photography actually I used to do
like wedding videography too so I had
done my woes with videography and
weddings and stuff I hated video like I
thought video was the worst took so long
to edit you know I loved RVs it's like
boom you Snappy post you're done in an
hour you know and videos like this whole
cumbersome thing so I thought I'll never
do video and here I was making this long
what it's the time seemed like a long
seven minute long YouTube video about
how the Falcon 9 lands
and again like that one I posted and
actually it did really bad and I was
really upset I'm like I spent two weeks
on this stupid video you know worked
really hard scripting and blah blah blah
and then it you know I had like a
thousand views or something it did much
worse in the first video and I was so
upset and I kind of like was ready to
keep throwing more spaghetti at the wall
to see what's gonna stick for everyday
astronaut and I think it was like a
month or two later I happened to like
you know check the analytics on YouTube
and also that video like kind of took
off and I got like 40 or 50 or 60 000
views or something I was like no way and
it just kept you know that just honed it
in more like Okay YouTube will bring a
bigger like bring an audience to me as
opposed to like Instagram I had to find
and you know try to get the audience to
come to me and this was like they were
gonna do the legwork so if I make decent
videos
um and I realized like really the fun
thing for me was explaining a topic that
was scary and intimidating and try to
make it you know fun and engaging what
were some of the struggles of uh
building up a YouTube channel so for
people who don't know once again
you have a YouTube channel uh called
everyday astronaut and there's some
incredible videos on it so what was the
what was the some of the challenges and
the struggles in the early days
definitely like At first you're not
gonna find your own voice and I know
like even you know Jimmy talked to you
about that like how your first video is
gonna suck you don't you're not gonna be
yourself you're going to be nervous
you're gonna be you're not gonna know
the tone the pace the the things that
are interesting and actually originally
I I had constraints I was really worried
about making a short video because I
thought there's no way One's Gonna watch
the three minute video and then a seven
minute video and pretty quickly I
realized like YouTube as a whole was
kind of changing but also there's always
that historic backbone of like 22
minutes of programming for a 30 minute
spot on TV like no one goes over 22 or
44 minutes you know if you have the full
hour special or whatever like that is
the absolute limit of what a human being
can watch you know basically is what I
thought yeah and slowly I just kept
playing and getting longer and and
actually more and more in depth into the
topics and instead of getting like
pushed back you know and being like this
is so boring I realized as long as it's
like as I was walking people through the
whole step you know giving them all the
contacts they need they're happy to get
as deep into the weeds as I can get them
and so that just kind of fed the the
snowball just kept rolling and I'm like
all right and you know before you know
it I'm making hour-long videos like an
hour long is is more or less a normal
length on my channel for a for a
produced video and they're really really
in depth but I love like that process of
trying to preemptively kind of guess
what the questions might be and and you
know part of that is like we do like
script read throughs with like our
supporters and do like cuts of videos
and people a decent amount of people see
it before it goes public and I would get
those questions out of the way you know
we get those people asking the questions
and then I I love nothing more than
trying to
you know get all those questions
answered by the end of the video
a question about being a a Creator on
YouTube
that could be a challenging
psychological aspect to it which is like
you might invest a huge amount of your
effort
into a thing and it uh
doesn't receive much attention at all
and you know there's something about
YouTube and in general social media
that makes you feel really crappy about
that if you let it if you really look at
the numbers
it's very very difficult not to pay
attention to that I mean that's the
reason why I turn off numbers on my
um my interface for stuff that I've
created because I just see it having a
negative effect on your mind but even
then you still it still has an effect uh
I mean your uh your epic video on
the the history of Soviet Rockets comes
to mind and we'll talk about that in a
second but uh it's called people should
check it out uh the entire Soviet rocket
engine family tree so that's something
you've researched for two years yeah
all right you put your heart and soul
into it there's a lot of passion there's
a lot there's a long journey it's in I
think about like an hour and a half
video
um is there like uh is there challenges
is there like
how difficult is that to put so much of
yourself into a video and it maybe not
do so well yeah that that's the that's
the struggle for sure honestly
especially as like as we grow I I try to
make better and better videos which
means hiring more and more people to do
you know higher end animations and spend
more time editing and shooting and
scripting and just
at but at the end of the day like it
still can't be just losing money and I
have videos that definitely lose a lot
of money because I you know hire 3D
artists and stuff and
um and I I was so certain the the Soviet
rocket engine video I thought was just
purely going to be a passion project I
did I honestly was like if it ever
crosses a million I it's a home run
because it cost like a couple million I
think it's a little over two wow which
is insane to me like I just really
thought this was more something just to
put on the Shelf as a resource almost
for myself you know like just to kind of
have that knowledge bank and something
I've always wanted to straighten out in
my own head and and kind of know the
history a little bit better but come to
find out like it took a while you know
it was a slow turn well I remember when
I when you first released it and that's
when I watched it I remember like this
has so few views yeah I remember being
just sad
like I was like sad about the state of
the world because I know how much love
you put into it how like how much I
don't know I I to me for some reason
that somehow would directly connect to
huge views but see you know what made me
sad is like if you use a different
thumbnail or a different title that
could affect the popularity I know and
then I just could imagine the torment
you're going through what if I used a
different thumbnail it's that Jimmy uh
the Mr Beast yeah torment like just a
slightly different title uh or a
slightly different
everything I have videos is ironically
the last like I don't know five videos
I've produced are horribly flopping like
some of my worst videos I've ever made
statistically the the interesting one is
like the you summarize Incredible video
you summarizing that people should go
watch about all the the awards video for
2022 like all the cool stuff that
happened between two and two I remember
that not being that popular there's a
few ones recently that are not that
popular like right into the fighter jet
I thought I thought that was going to be
easy like one or two million I don't
know if I've paid the flights off to go
there you know what I mean like in that
video it makes no sense and frankly
here's here's at the end of the day yeah
I I realized like I have lately
especially the last year or two kind of
disconnected from the that aspect of it
I'm super fortunate I have a very
generous like patreon support and people
that can help me sustain to produce
people go support support Tim on patreon
well it's that but the as you know as a
Creator like that is what keeps the
lights on and makes it so it you know I
can go this deep like if I didn't have
that if I had to rely solely on like
YouTube ad Revenue I mean I would just
it'd be super different videos I
wouldn't spend as much time researching
because I just you know they'd just be
more glossed over it's like a hurry to
churn them out so I can keep the machine
going and I have this incredible freedom
to really dive into a topic like a video
that I've been working on now for almost
three months is how to start a rocket
engine and let me tell you it's not as
easy
as one might think or I guess as it is
as difficult as you might think I mean
it's it's an insane topic oh what do you
mean by stock you mean like the ignition
yeah like how do you physically get them
running you know like there's all these
you know the valves and the if the
turbine the turbine you know that we
were talking about earlier like that has
to run on the pumps but it itself is
powering the pumps so how do you get
that like chicken and egg how do you get
that thing started
you know there's tons of it's so cool
there's so many ways and so for me you
know that required reading a lot and
talking to people that know a lot more
than me
um and just really trying to make sure I
understand enough of it to explain it
and try to weave a narrative you know
and so that video is three months in the
making we're still probably another two
or three weeks out and it's I don't
expect I mean I think this one will do
relatively well you know but in the
grand scheme of YouTube like still
Child's Play you know
but I I'm okay and I'm okay with that
I've I've I'm at that point actually
where I am okay with that it still
stings and I'm more worried about just
like can I continue to do it at this
quality and at this level if it's losing
money you know what I mean so it's there
is a trade-off and I am kind of having
to navigate that but but you have sort
of the depth
uh of the impact you have
is uh is a is the thing that YouTube
can't give you numbers on but it's it's
a really important thing to sort of
remember that it's really not just about
the YouTube numbers or it's off for for
people like you they're basically
educating and revealing the Brilliance
in a technology that uh will make humans
and multi-planetary species and give
hope to millions of young minds that
will build that future I mean that's
immeasurable that's not just the views
but you know it's um that's really
important to sort of remember
as you're creating it that's something I
understand I I I try to think about it
as well so like views
um yeah and that and that becomes more
don't matter I realize that more and
more like every day you know the the
more the channel matures the more I
realize the importance of it as an
overall mission as opposed to like you
know in the first year or two it's a rat
race of of growth and of popularity and
all that kind of stuff you know and you
feel that you feel that it's a driving
force these days not so much just
because that will wear you out very
quickly so back to the Soviet rocket the
epic video probably the most epically
researched video you've done I mean it's
like is it it's true it's truly an epic
video uh so what uh again called the
entire Soviet rocket engine family tree
took you two years to research what are
some fascinating things you've learned
about the history of Rocket engines
in the Soviet Union and in general
um through a process of making that
video
the the coolest thing to me is
how it's this weird blend for the Soviet
Union went through a
an insane iteration process and made so
many engines like I didn't even touch
you know any like maneuvering thrusters
or missile engines like I only really
dealt with main propulsion engines on
orbital rockets and they're still way
too many to talk about I mean it's still
dozens and dozens of engines
and I I could have gone deeper into this
which is hilarious
um they iterated so much made a new
engine for just at the drop of a hat
yet they still also like did Super
primitive things you know they they
physically are still today lighting the
main combustion chambers of the soyuz
engines of the rd-107 already 108 with
essentially matchsticks like they
literally stick a t-shaped thing up into
the chamber and have a pyrotechnic in
the in it that ignites the actual
propellants in the combustion chamber
it's not the most elegant solution in
the world yeah they're still using that
so they went from like
the whole spectrum of like it's a
mixture of like make it better faster
harder stronger gooder all the way
around to also if it ain't broke don't
fix it it's like it employs all of the
above so it's like it's uh a lot of
innovation but also they use duct tape
but it's like all of it together yes
that's exactly like that's exactly the
way to put it and and they did things
that are insane they developed a full
flow stage combustion cycle engine this
engine had been used I mean it would
have put the F it was same relative size
as the F1 engine on the Saturn V like in
that same category way up there of like
you know 6.7 uh like Mega Newtons of
thrust or something around and then the
F1 is like seven or something it's it's
huge
yet way more complicated way more
efficient way just better engine in that
sense as far as far as performance goes
yet it never flew it never left the
stand you know they they never built the
rocket around it the N1 which was the
pre you know the most powerful rocket to
have flown so far to date
um like it never made it through its
first stage burn it all four attempts
failed spectacularly and yet it had so
much technology on it that was still
unrivaled today almost like finally now
we're beating it the nk-33s that they
developed for that rocket like finally
today we're to the point of like having
better engines than they built in the
60s yeah what stands out to you uh from
the N1 family of rocket engine
well it's interesting because the N1 uh
was the connect could snetsov design
Bureau and he was actually an aircraft
manufacturer so he was one of the first
people outside of kind of the the
missile and rocket program you know you
had all these other uh Big Wigs kind of
in the other okbs that were developing
missiles and Rockets and then all of a
sudden here comes uh Nikolai kuznetsov
who
um had never developed a rocket engine
and so his first attempt at Rocket
engines was the NK series nk-15 and k-33
and they were amazing they were
brilliant they were these wonderful
closed cycle oxygen-rich engines
um that were that were awesome there
were awesome engines and that were you
know because
I love that because he his direct
um boss he since he wasn't necessarily
in the in the Aerospace you know or in
the I guess the rocket missile defense
World
um he didn't have to uh at the fall of
the Soviet Union he didn't have to give
away all of his things to the same
people as the other people so he hid you
know like 80 of his engines in a hangar
and uh and then we still literally used
them in the United States we used ulti I
think it was like eight or ten of them
um repurposed them as they're called AJ
26s in the United States but like we
still were flying Soviet rocket engines
in the 2000s because they were better
than engines we are building today like
that's to me that's my favorite fact
about the N1 I'm not gonna sit there
still that good that that they were the
the best choice for at the time uh
orbital Sciences some of the culture
that
engineering has led to these things that
still work it's incredible yeah um you
said that the rd171 is one of the
coolest engines ever made why is that
yeah so one of the fun things about the
Soviet engines is it'll look like a lot
of their engines look like multiple
engines because you see multiple nozzles
you see multiple combustion Chambers and
you would think well obviously you know
the nozzle is the engine right but what
they actually would do the the real the
real heart and the real power of the
rocket engine actually comes from the
turbo pumps comes from the pumps
themselves and you know as we talked
about earlier that that includes the
turbine and the actual
um pumps that flow the propellant into
the into the chambers and so the Soviet
Union was incredible at developing these
closed cycle high-powered turbo pumps
but if you try to scale the combustion
chamber too big
um you end up with what's called
um combustion instability you're you're
having you have such a large surface
area of crazy flames you know and and
combustion happening they can get these
weird pockets and oscillations and
frequencies and and they just couldn't
make big combustion Chambers they never
figured it out they never quite well
they did actually kind of figure it out
but they they didn't like it so they
ended up just shrinking down and having
small combustion Chambers and just
sending splitting the pipes basically
instead of one fuel pump going into or
one pipe going into one combustion
chamber and one oxidizer pipe going into
one combustion chamber they'd split it
off into two or four engine into two or
four combustion Chambers and kind of
spread that work around so they didn't
experience this combustion instability
so the rd171 is like still to date the
most powerful rocket engine ever built
the turbo pump is insane I don't even
remember how many you know like 200 000
horsepower or something comes out of
that turbo pump
in order to flow the amount of
propellant necessary at those rates and
at those pressures into the combustion
chamber so it has four chambers
and it's just it's just an absolute
Marvel of engineering and
yeah and then the cool thing too is
specifically the rd171 it's engine all
four of those nozzles can actually pivot
and and rotate and I just now as I'm
explaining this realized that has to
mean that they have
joints like flexible joints in the high
pressure pump lines in order to like I
never I'm this is the realization I'm
having right now because normally you
put the gimbal above the turbo pump like
the the mount where the engine swivels
so that you have low pressure coming
from the tanks into the pumps and then
you just have a straight you know fixed
pipe flowing into the engine so you'd
have to bend that pipe and have it be
dynamic if they had the four chambers
moving independently from each other
that means those four chambers all had
to have a flexible high pressure pipe
going which I don't even I don't know if
that's why am I just now realizing this
yeah so there's engineering challenges
with that I never even thought that was
a thing you would ever could do honestly
I would I gotta look into why and how
and what yeah I wonder why that the
design decision was made so the easier
thing to do normally is you would keep
those nozzles fixed and then then a fix
like say the the soyuz engine the rd-107
and 108 they have a fixed main
combustion Chambers and they and they
use these little Vernier or some people
got mad at me for saying Vernier and
Werner engines that swivel themselves
and those provide your your Control
Authority so the main Chambers stay
fixed and then you get your your roll
and you're pitch and your yaw out of
auxiliary thrusters uh by the way did
did you get anything wrong in that video
that people told you about yeah a few
things yep
um first off we had a graphic error
where we actually you know we copied and
pasted a lot of our like after effects
projects so our nuclear engines one of
them on screen says that it runs on rp1
it does not it has basically all the
wrong stats we just didn't catch it in
the edit you know that we literally copy
and pasted and I say it right on screen
but the like in the voiceover but on
screen it's wrong the other thing I'm
excited to ask you about this oh I
watched and and I spoke with a lot of uh
Russian speaking individuals we had a
lot of research assistants that were
reading and blah blah I tried really
hard to learn how to pronounce Sergey
corellios name
and I'm still going to say it wrong no
matter what but my understanding yes and
from listening to native speakers it's
closer to krellyoff than it is coralev
yeah definitely said gay probably
see I will never say it that perfectly
but I I know it's not just corlev I mean
again the the English translation of it
likely I should have just said core 11
said I'm saying it the dumb America way
but but you rolled your heart
comrade
excellent so uh
oh let me just ask you in the difference
in in the culture because you've reached
there's so many Rockets from so many
different areas the Saturn five and just
everything you're seeing now are there
some interesting differences especially
when you look at the space race between
um the Soviet
rocket engineers and efforts versus the
American
yeah there's I mean there's definitely
huge huge cultural changes and the fun
thing is that they kind of spawned from
the same they have the same starting
Place both you know the Soviet rocket
engines and Americans all came from the
Nazi V2 rocket and the A4 engine
literally physically spawned from that
because at the fall of you know at the
end of World War II we took a handful of
German scientists and the Soviets took a
handful of German scientists and they
both got their own a little bit some
blueprints here and there and the others
got some blue so we literally have the
same it's a weird thing where we're
starting from the same like thing and
letting two uh two Divergent you know
Divergent paths go crazy on their own
development so it's really fun to see
the cultural differences one of the
things the United States did is they
really would kind of take an engine
and and just perfect it more or less and
then and not really evolve that much
like they they I don't know and I don't
know why I actually need to do a history
lesson on all of the U.S engines but
it's literally like uh as far as orbital
class engines before now
it's like a dozen or two you know it's
it's it's a tenth the amount of the
Soviets and the Soviets just literally
made up a new engine every time they had
a new like they went uh and it was like
a completely different engine yeah so I
just yeah I wonder if there's some
aspect to the culture and I don't want
to overstate it but uh there is more of
a safety culture I think in the United
States and I think if you care about
safety or rather like you have
uh you're more risk-averse yeah so you
care about safety more about the value
of human life there is taken there that
you will iterate less so yeah I think
the Soviets especially in the early
aspect of the program I don't want to
overstate this is
um some of it is just
um through stories you just hey you're
anecdotes there are more willing to take
risks yeah risks with human life risks
with spacecraft for example the first uh
orbital space flights from the Soviet
Union the the Cosmonaut had to eject out
of the capsule and parachute to a
landing yes that's not very well like
known and it wasn't they were hid that
even from history as best they could at
first because they were slightly ashamed
that they couldn't have a full recovery
system with their spacecraft they could
physically recover it but they wouldn't
have been able to recover the cosmonaut
in one piece so instead they had them
just eject out of the thing and
parachute to safety like that's insane
and so there definitely was some some
extra risks and but all also a freedom
to just like push things to the limits
and try everything you know they threw
EV all the spaghetti on the wall it's
funny that most people probably don't
even know the first person in the space
in America and obviously everybody knows
that in uh that it's like um
it's it's kind of interesting how the
space race
and even World War II
even like the history books you ask most
Americans
they think that America won World War II
like without America like they the the
real heroes of World War II is America
yes uh British people they say and and
everybody has a pretty good
justification like without Britain
without Churchill
their Hitler would have taken over the
world and I think probably the strongest
case is the Soviet Union case that
they're the ones that won the war the
reason it's the strongest cases were
most of the fighting happened right most
of the death happen most of like most of
the destruction but everyone has their
perspective and certainly on the space
race
you know the great accomplishment is the
first man on the Moon
yeah I was gonna say and then Yuri
Gagarin from the Russian perspectives
like first man in space and that I think
still persists and some of that in
healthy forms is probably constructive
to a little bit of competition this
pushes all the all the great scientists
on each side uh but anyway what do you
think about
this uh Euro Gagarin mission of the
first human in space
Commission in 1961 just in general when
you when you look back at that time
leading to the the the the the first man
on the Moon yeah April 12 1961. Yuri's
night baby that's a
yeah it's it's insane what's insane to
me is is the first
person in space didn't just go to space
he went into orbit you know you're yarn
flew around the Earth in orbit and
re-entered that's a Monumental task
compared to suborbital so the United
States did two suborbital flights in
that same year I believe in that same
year at least I'm pretty sure in 1961
they flew for the first time orbitaly in
1962's they weren't terribly far behind
to get a human into orbit like in the
grand scheme of things you know 10
months difference but at the same time
like the fact that Soviet Union just
went straight to Flying someone into
orbit is Monumental and I'm sure they
did not do excessive
uh rigorous testing here because there
is a space race and you have the first
is important just imagine being Yuri
what do you say when they're like
launching them like let's go or
something like uh I mean you're taking
uh dude we're talking about you being on
Starship like you're taking a pretty big
risk being launched out into orbit oh
hopefully a lot less risk than what Yuri
went through so Yuri's Yuri the crazy
thing remember those match sticks we
talked about yeah you know there's
there's 20 Main combustion Chambers on
soyuz and there's four and 12 more
Vernier engines that all need to be lit
so you're riding you're sitting on top
of this this booster and they light all
of those 32 combustion Chambers on the
ground and then it has this insane
separation process between what the
Soviet Union would call the first stage
in the second stages but we would call
it like the core stage in the boosters
um they all for these boosters have to
peel away perfectly from the core stage
simultaneously you know if one of them
sticks on Mission failed if one of them
doesn't inject properly and drags into
the other tank you know you're it's it's
a goner so the the staging process of of
the soyuz is is insane to me that that
ended up working out
I I was just the the technology in
stories and I mean more or less that
same rocket is what's still flying
humans
that are cosmonauts from Universe Cosmos
and going to the International Space
Station are flying on a variant of that
soyuz rocket still today it's still
like that big of a Workhorse what do you
think about Russ Cosmos as it stands
today uh it's history and its future
in uh comparison to NASA and other
National efforts and in comparison to
commercial space like yeah
I mean utmost respect for the engineers
involved and you know everything that's
happened I think uh nergomosh is like
still some of the one of the greatest
engine manufacturers when they have the
funding to do so but man it seems like
they're they're
falling from Grace as far as uh space
prowess you know the Roche Cosmos went
from
having I think they got very comfortable
at the top of you know from 2011 until
2000 until 2022 or until 2020 they were
the only ride to the International Space
Station
since then like and it started I feel
like in 2018 honestly I think that's
kind of one things that's the first time
I specifically remember a pretty nasty
like thing happened in 2018 I think it
was a soyuz mission to the International
Space Station had one of the boosters
not detached and had to have an abort
but you know that that happened then all
of a sudden next thing you know there's
a progress being docked to the ISS a
couple years ago that spun the ISS
cartwheel the ISS out of control
followed a few months later the piers
module docks of the International Space
Station spirals the International Space
Station out of control again with like a
Thruster getting fixed on there's a hole
in in as Russian segment uh there's well
I think the most recent one right now
there's a soyuz doc to the ISS that has
a puncture in it and it's leaking
coolant and will not be returning humans
on it so they're actually having to fly
up and uncrewed soyuz and that one
likely wasn't a manufacturing error it
probably was like a micro meteorite
puncture rendering spacecraft unusable
we don't know for sure yet
but it's just really been like this fall
from grace where
they have they have all the potential
potential they have some of the best
engines some of the the best rockets and
especially like right before the
collapse of the Soviet Union the the
bronze uh shuttle and the inergia rocket
were incredible had they been able to
evolve that into Bronto and the reusable
and ergia they had a fully reusable
energy on the drawing board and like I
honestly fully think they could have
done it is it possible to return to a
place where there is friendly
competition between nations that
ultimately
um
unites and inspires the peoples of these
different worlds these very different
worlds that have especially recently uh
come to conflict over the over the war
in Ukraine the tension builds uh the war
the conflict the suffering is actually
creating more and more division creating
more and more hate I think as we've
talked about I think science and
engineering and especially the most epic
version of engineering which is a
rocketry and space travel unites people
the United people even in a time of
tension conflict and War so do you have
a hope that we can return to that place
I think historically spaceflight has
been one of the most bonding things you
know we look at we have countless
examples of you know Cold War enemies
coming together and working together
lending a hand
um Apollo 13 for example of course you
know there is the potential that who
knew where it was going to re-enter
since it was not in the planned
trajectory at all for re-entry and the
Soviet Union said hey wherever you know
wherever they land like we'll help you
guys out basically you know that was a
pretty big thing at the time obviously
um we also in 1975 saw the Apollo soyuz
Mission which was an Apollo spacecraft
docking with soyuz spacecraft first time
there's International collaboration and
again 1975 still very admits the Cold
War
yet we have this collaboration
um that I don't know what else could
have done that you know I mean and think
about what it actually takes to do that
you have to come up with a a docking
module that is you you know like that
takes the two different air environments
and the two different docking systems
and talk to the engineers and Mission
planners and figure out you know train
together the the cosmonauts and the
astronauts trained together and got to
know each other they were crossing
boundaries and borders and coming
together for this Mission and even if it
was totally a Fluff piece like even if
it was totally this like you know
cynical you know just
trying to make a pretty face for
everybody for the for the cameras or
something obviously it still had an
impact yeah it's a symbolic impact but
there's also the Practical impact I mean
a lot of people have to work together
yes and that and that has a ripple
effect on the culture on the different
engineers
uh yeah 100 and even just the the
astronauts and the cosmonauts involved
like think about what what probably went
through their heads during this process
of like going from oh my God I'm gonna
have to work with them to getting to
know them and then sharing meals in
space like that's a crazy transformation
of of timelines and I would love to I I
do think that spaceflight has the the
ability to to bond us and unite us
because it is
ultimately you know this little tiny
little planet we're floating around on
you know it's the only it is the
boundary that we all share you know you
only can you it only takes you getting
off this planet to realize oh my God
we're all neighbors we're all living in
the same house together and
I I do think ultimately you know as we
continue to uh expand our Horizons and
expand our exploration that it has the
potential to to unite us more than than
it has the potential to divide us so one
of the potential conflicts of the 21st
century that I think everyone wants to
avoid both in the cyberspace and in the
hot War space Cold War Hot War all kinds
of War all kinds of economic conflict as
with between the United States and China
so China is
going full steam ahead in developing a
space program doing a lot of incredible
work like you mentioned uh 64 launches
in 2022 with two failures
but you know Moving Straight Ahead
um
we had a lot of startups like a lot of
the launches were from brand new
companies so to have two failures out of
64. I mean that's still if you look at
operational launches it was flawless
do you see a pathway
where there's again in that same way
collaboration
or a friendly competition between all
the different companies and nations of
the United States and China in the in
the next as we push towards the moon uh
Mars and Beyond I held a dumb hope that
China would actually be allowed to sign
onto the Artemis Accord to be able to
take part in this next step towards the
moon and just imagine if like if they
provided a you know a propulsion module
or a Lander or something and we actually
came together to land on the Moon
instead of having another space race you
know it's like it would have been so
cool and
yeah I still am hopeful that
similar to to back in the cold war that
we might have something like that
someday where we actually are
collaborating and it feels like
sometimes we're really close to that and
then other times it feels like we're
really far from that and it just sucks
because I know and you know I try really
hard on my channel to to always separate
and celebrate the work being done you
know because at the end of the day
there's someone that's just going home
to their family clocking an hour is
working really hard on on pushing their
program and and doing engineering work
you know and it's
uh we don't get to choose where we're
born and what we're born into
um so I really like to avoid
you know the the political aspects of
things and the geopolitical aspects and
just appreciate the science and the the
science we're seeing and the the
progress that China's doing in the last
10 years is is very akin to the you know
early space flight programs and and with
the runway of like just going keeping on
going like I see no reason for them to
be slowing down so it's it's definitely
something to watch and and be interested
in and who knows I mean there really
genuinely might be a race to the moon
again and there really genuinely might
be a race to Mars
hey the part of me is excited about that
because a race is is pretty cool yeah uh
but
hopefully it's friendly competition and
some collaboration it is true that uh
maybe I'm being a bit cynical but
Nations sometimes governments and
leaders of those governments sometimes
ruin things like you don't often have
I think statistically speaking it's
harder to have a leader of a nation that
looks beyond the political the
particular political bickering of that
nation and you have like a JFK type
character that really steps up and
inspires I think statistically speaking
it's better to have somebody like Elon
who's the leader of a company a
commercial effort that is able to look
beyond the borders of Nations and uh
certainly inspiring Educators like
yourself uh to look beyond the borders
of those Nations and the geopolitical
conflicts and so on to uh to inspire the
to inspire people I think that's just
made so much easier like you can have
more reach
uh Tim Tim Dodd can have more reach than
NASA right like in terms of inspiring
the world and that's fascinating like
that that gives power to the individuals
let's see past the this the silly
short-term geopolitical conflicts yeah
that's the whole police yeah yeah
do you worry that there might be a war
in space
yes let's let's look out into the future
so forget
so the interesting thing about these
Rockets right let's not forget rock is
uh do what Rockets do that they can
carry payloads that uh can be weapons
uh do you worry about this
I worry most about space wars as leading
to The Kessler syndrome of of having a
cascading effect of like a spacecraft
blowing up and then affecting another
spacecraft and that blows up and then
all of a sudden you're trapped and have
this debris Cloud that we can't
you know go we can't go into space
anymore like that's my biggest because
frankly at this point we could
annihilate ourselves with terrestrial
stuff anyway you know what I mean we
don't need space to to end society as we
know it you know what I mean yeah
um but we do we could really and the the
good thing is I think everyone well
mostly everyone seems to understand this
for the most part that like
we really can't be risking blowing up
stuff in space and in low earth orbit
because it could easily like we could
strain ourselves from space assets for
50 years
if oh can you elaborate on that so like
what is the danger of the debris there
that uh could jeopardize yeah so for
instance and it was only a couple years
ago Russia did an anti-satellite test on
a on an orbital there's a we've done
this to the U.S has done this like I'm
not pinning it on them but we kind of
know nowadays like don't do
anti-satellite tests on orbital things
because those things stay in orbit you
know when you blow something up in space
it's not like you know people think you
know when in in space like oh you throw
a something that's just going to keep
going forever and ever and ever yeah I
mean that's in the in the sense that
it's not going to be slowed down due to
you know due to air resistance it's
going to continue to do that but it's
staying in orbit around the Earth like
you just slightly change the orbit of it
around earth when you throw a ball or
something you know
so
the scary thing is when you blow up a
satellite
all those pieces of that satellite are
now
millions of bullets in a halo around the
Earth
in a very specific Halo you know so some
things get blown up uh faster you know
in according to its orbit faster so
they'll go a little bit higher
elliptically some things will get slowed
down in that explosion and actually
re-enter some things will go sideways
and change its inclination of that orbit
so you have this debris field but it
more or less becomes a band of like no
no you know like a big scary
sharp scary bullets that can destroy
another spacecraft since then all of a
sudden especially now starlink you know
we're talking about thousands and
thousands and thousands of satellites in
space
if all of a sudden one you know a couple
of them crash and and you know blow up
and obviously have all the shrapnel
going everywhere and then that hits
another satellite that creates shrapnel
you can literally blanket our entire low
earth orbit
and 17 500 mile an hour bullets
you know we're talking that the the
connection the kinetic energy in this is
so hard for people to Fathom because
that you know that's over 10 times
faster than most like rifle bullets and
even like a big 50 cal
is not going to be you know we're still
talking about about 10 percent
that so when you think about the kinetic
energy it's insane so a Fleck of paint
can go through panes of glass
at that velocity you know a little piece
of metal can puncture you know blow
straight through
so like
so our actions that seem small so small
scale military actions
can have uh
can have dire detrimental effects to the
whole Space Program like Global Space
Program oh yeah it can affect everything
and everyone including the like
including satellites oh yeah especially
satellites like that's why I mean the
good and the bad thing is the good thing
is a lot of satellites don't operate in
low earth orbit like a lot of uh the the
ones that we use day to day a lot of
them are
and medium earth orbit like the GPS or
their geostationary which are way way
out there and because of that they they
won't really ever de-orbit or like it'll
take you know Millennia to deorbit
because you know just because
something's in space doesn't mean it's
there forever especially like in low
earth orbit the atmosphere doesn't just
suddenly stop it's not like you hit the
carbon line 100 kilometers and also
there's zero atmosphere the atmosphere
just slowly tapers you know you can
experience that yourself as you climb
them out and you slowly realize there's
less and less air you just keep going
and just because you're in space 200 300
kilometers up there's still Trace
molecules you know there's the
occasional oxygen molecule there's the
occasional nitrogen molecule and so that
is actually dragged so as a spacecraft
in low earth orbit depending on its
altitude will take anywhere from
five years to five months to deorbit you
know or two months or one month like
depending on its orbit or its altitude
we'll have some parasitic drag still and
slowly throughout time slow down which
lowers its orbit which drags it down
more lowers this orbit Etc et cetera
until it reenters so if we end up with
uh some kind of catastrophic event where
the entire low earth orbit is you know
has been inundated and blown up it'll
take months for the first band you know
to clear up it'll take years for
something like Beyond there's charts you
know people have all this stuff
available you shouldn't look it's
terrifying by the way but this is really
the but again the caveat is for the most
part the low earth orbit stuff would
clear up within years so we could get
back to doing some more with it like
starlink stuff would probably be able to
be re and you know we could kind of redo
it and build up from the ground up again
GPS wouldn't be wiped out and our
geostationary satellites wouldn't be
wiped up but the scary thing is we
wouldn't be able to relaunch and replace
new things because we're stuck we're not
going to fly through that debris field
you know
and we avoid that by avoiding military
actions in space and these days like
there's more and more uh requirements
and and legislation and especially
trying to get International
collaboration on having end-of-life
plans for satellites so that satellites
especially those in low earth orbit have
like drag devices to increase them once
they're done they literally pull like
even just a ribbon like a silly little
like you know 40 foot long ribbon will
sit there and it'll slowly it or it can
speed up its re-entry process by months
or years or whatever so we're starting
to see that this is now an importance
there's a really cool company called
Stoke Aerospace out in Washington is one
of these launch provisor providers
that's really looking not into just
trying to be the next you know SpaceX
launch company they're really seeing
satellite uh bringing stuff down from
space is actually being especially right
now we have all of these hundreds and
thousands of satellites being launched
every year someone at some point is
probably gonna have to do some cleanup
and so they're looking at being one of
those companies to do that uh what do
you think about starlink
and the efforts of starlink to put a
very large number of satellites
out there and provide internet access to
uh
to or anyone to anyone generally I think
starlink is phenomenal and I would be
saying this if it was any company I want
to make that clear that people think I'm
just some you know SpaceX Fanboy or
something and anyway I think perfect I
think I think as you're a fan I could
say you're basically a fan a fanboy or
just a fan of everybody that's doing
space though and I don't like there's no
even in this whole conversation there's
no way we cover like 10 of what I wanted
to talk to you about so we're jumping
around I mean there's we could talk
probably for another an hour about
Artemis uh we could talk about anything
with Ula obviously the all the other all
the other commercial efforts we could
talk about the NASA efforts the you know
the I mean yeah and Saturn fight like
are we gonna really go with this
conversation not talk about satisfied
and we might okay so like Anyway star
fan of everything starling
is in general exciting to you and not
for the space assets but just the
potential for Humanity like I I really
think even as a consumer of the internet
personally our studio space down in
Texas we're stuck with with MediaCom
which has like the least reliable
internet service period That's the only
option either that or they're trying to
charge me like twenty thousand dollars
to run a fiber optic cable like a
thousand meters or something like it's
it's insane I'm not going to do that I
bought starlink it helps but it's still
not you know amazing but it has you can
see where this is going in a year two
three five years like oh I can totally
screw this other internet provider and
this is now by far the best option and
it's available literally anywhere you
don't have to be limited to your
internet's local internet service
provider
um and and on the global scale of course
you have you know people be able to
learn and learn about rockets and learn
about uh water management and
architecture and City Planning and
fitness and health all of the all of the
modern conveniences that we Google every
single day there's people that don't
have access to that right now you know I
I'm a self-taught rocket nerd I would
not be who I am if it wasn't for the
internet in the last seven years you
know six seven years so unlocking the
intellectual potential of places like
Africa of rural areas that don't
currently have internet access
um that's a genuine that's a huge thing
that's like humanitarian 101 is give
people access to information and you
like you know I think we have this uh
potential to try to step in and fix
other people's problems but the reality
is like people are smart no matter where
you are you give them the resources to
learn they're going to solve problems
they're going to problem solve they're
going to engineer they're going to but
if you don't give them access to that
information they're going to be stuck in
there
and their Cycles you know and so I I
think the potential for starlink is
incredible I think it's already
impactful it's already affecting
people in you know in Rural and
Indigenous areas and it's already
affecting businesses and all that stuff
I think it's great I think it
is
you know there's some downsides with
astronomy with with ground-based
astronomy that it can hinder uh
observations from the ground
um there's already a lot of
communications between SpaceX and um
astronomical societies and things like
that because it is a real concern you
know it's it can ruin observations it
can ruin data but like one of the big
ones for instance recently I think a new
thing they're going to be working into
is that currently if a starlink is
flying over
um over a ground-based asset a lot of a
lot of ground telescopes actually have a
laser that goes up and it measures the
atmospheric Distortion and the
telescopes literally sit there and like
by the millisecond fixes like changes
the focus and fixes those atmospheric
distortions and that laser can interfere
with satellites so previously I I'm
pretty sure that SpaceX actually had to
you know request that as they're flying
over these satellites they are these
telescopes they turn off the laser and
when you have tens of thousands of these
things flying it's you're going to be
turning off the laser more than it's on
you know and just being this insanely
inconvenient thing because you're gonna
have these Junctions happen often and I
think one of the things that SpaceX is
like okay no no you guys keep the laser
on we'll deal with your laser
um good good step you know things like
that mitigating the brightness of them
so they're not visible under most
conditions of course like there's still
always going to be visible in some
um but then ultimately for me it's like
this you have this weird like almost
like a puberty of space flight and and
astronomy where currently it's not cheap
enough to really do a ton of incredible
science or space-based telescopes you
know we have web we have Hubble we have
uh you know all these other
you know awesome space-based telescopes
um Chandra you know
Etc et cetera whatever and
you uh is but it's still so expensive to
launch them yeah that were still so
reliant on our ground telescopes but in
the future you can see a world where oh
this is so cheap we'll just launch like
we can launch 50 James Webb Space
Telescope size telescopes this year for
half the price of doing it on Earth you
know and get way better data so in the
future I think in 20 30 years we'll look
at it and be like oh man that was an
awkward time where space assets were
interfering with us astronomy but I
think in the future it's like can you
imagine doing space you know astronomy
from the ground that's insane there
could be complexities to just having
that many uh just another topic so a
complexity is associated with having so
many satellites
uh especially with competing companies
and competing Nations do you see that as
an issue having tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of satellites yeah
it becomes a very interesting robotics
collision avoidance problem the the one
thing to keep in mind is perspective
like I know 10 000 satellites and twenty
thousand and a hundred thousand
satellites sounds insane and it sounds
really scary
but I mean just even look at how many
planes are in the air at any given time
and the planes are are bigger they're
flying slower which actually means
there's a greater chance of collision if
you think about you know two objects
occupying space if they're one's moving
really fast like imagine trying to you
know throw two basketballs at each other
relatively easy now try shooting two
bullets at each other and have like you
know at 90 degrees from each other you
have to have your timing down like
really perfect to do that now take that
times 10 you know and these objects are
taking up a physical space a very small
amount of time they're relatively small
like most satellites are not very big
and they have ins Limitless altitudes to
deal with so even though you can have
what look like convergences you know
they can be 10 20 50 100 kilometers
difference often and you know they're
dealing with this like all the the all
space assets know hey I'm at this
orbital plane and this blah blah blah
and they know their altitudes and know
their safe distances and have these
margins built in and it's spaced so
there's like an insane amount of room
you know so there's there's a lot of
margin there's a lot of margin but of
course you can't excuse that all the way
like you have to still have plans and
and be considering that and considering
collisions and considering all of the
above
when do you think the first human being
will step foot on Mars
you don't like timelines but is this
something and you're very much focused
on kind of the short term
of uh incredible progress that's
happening and that makes total sense but
there is the Mars plan that that was
that the origin of the commercial space
flight efforts
um do you still see and dream about that
day
let me be clear that I don't want to go
to Mars but um I do think if you're if
you're making me guess a timeline for
when humans will walk on Mars I even a
year ago I still would have said by the
end of 2020 like the 2020s decade you
know
um so by December 31st 2029 I thought
humans would have walked on mars I'm
starting to think
that's still too optimistic but I do I I
definitely think by 2040 like I I for
sure think that and I really think
it's it's just hard to predict that
curve you know that that project out
that curve we're gonna go from feeling
like it's impossible like it's feeling
like it's enough you know it could be
another by the end of this decade JFK
type moment especially if China steps up
with the Space Race yeah it could be
like uh all right NASA NASA kind of says
all right this Elon fella like really
make us a gigantic effort well and if
Starship works out as planned and as as
NASA has invested in human Landing
system they're relying on SpaceX to land
on the moon SpaceX can land on the moon
they can land on Mars
now whether or not the life support and
the human considerations of of long-term
space flight missions and high radiation
and blah blah blah blah refueling on
Mars is a huge huge huge deal
they definitely could send a Starship to
Mars
um and land ideally land in one piece on
as soon as they can land on the moon
they can land on Mars basically I mean
those two things are very in some ways
Mars is almost easier
if you can use because you can use the
atmosphere to slow down it actually
doesn't take that much more Delta V to
actually land on Mars than it does
because on the moon you don't have any
you got to first get out to the Moon
then orbit the Moon you know you have to
slow down every one of those is a
maneuver change then you have to slow
reorbit until it coincides you know hits
the moon and then if it's slow down
enough to not explode when you hit the
moon so there's a lot of Delta V there a
lot of change in velocity
um Mars is actually by the time we kind
of crunch the numbers it's relatively
similar it's just a lot more difficult
like timeline wise and you know accuracy
and all of these other communication you
know there's a lot of other things
obviously involved I'm glossing over
making it sound easy it's not but
um
but you know I think if I think there's
a real decent chance we could see a
Starship vehicle land on Mars uh
uncrewed by the end of the decade though
end of the decade I mean there's also a
sociological element maybe a political
one where
I think you're allowed to take more
risks with Mars than you are with the
moon because we've done the moon 1969
yeah it's been a while so PR wise you
have to be much safer yeah with Mars
like everyone's like it's super
dangerous like super like so you could
take a little more risk 100 especially
with the with man missions but actually
just uh going back to the moon landing
Apollo 11 Mission I haven't talked about
this at all
the the amazing engine there but it
again the Romantic question and you look
back at that Moon landing
um
one small step for man one giant step
for mankind uh what do you think about
that moment in human history do you go
back to that often or are you focused
just like with the cars on the on the
engines no no I I I I still when I need
inspiration I re-watch this documentary
called um when we left Earth I think it
was like a I think it was Discovery
Channel did it six part episode uh it it
was narrated by Gary Sinise
phenomenal overview of the Space Race
and that will get my juices flowing
every time every time just it's so well
done and it's it really just summarizes
that program so well and when I and
Beyond it goes all the way to the Space
Shuttle but
um yeah when I when I watch footage of
humans walking on the moon it's just I
can't believe we're dumb enough to do it
with the technology we had and the risks
they took to do it and the insane
engineering that it took to do that is
just absolutely astonishing the the
amount of the sheer like Logistics of
what it took to do it with the
technology we had back then is like how
did we have so much money and effort and
energy and time and resources human
resources to do this like it's just
just the weakness of the computers I had
back then they had to do so much I mean
yeah it's so much was so little it's
insane and but at the same time like
I don't know if we want to talk about
conspiracy theories or anything but like
it is all of like we have the proof and
the pudding of like the 400 000 people
on payroll like all of the paperwork all
of the Oh you mean the the question the
conspiracy if we land on the Moon yeah
like I mean I I think the receipts are
there like literally we did but it's
like a lot of things like that I mean we
actually generally live in a in a pretty
cynical time where people distrust
institutions part of the thing with the
space program is one of the things that
can help reinvigorate the Trust In
institutions by institutions even that
word is a bad word now but institutions
means a bunch of humans get together and
do a big thing together yeah
um yeah but you know like if I was
conspiratorily minded It's like how the
hell did humans do that yeah
so yeah I I think that's a very cynical
take unfortunately but it's still an
incredible one and also you know there's
grow there's uh until you look at the
receipts there's a kind of
um
like a rationale to that kind of
conspiracy theory because
so much pressure was put on the Space
Race the the pr of it to be the winner
so it makes sense that you might want to
try to take shortcuts and fake things
and you know propaganda
you you know different kinds of
messaging and I'm sure stuff like that
was happening some kind of like little
you know adjustment here and there to
present things better and so on but
ultimately the actual engineering
project of landing on the moon I the
fact that humans did that I mean it is
sad that we didn't have better like ways
to record it and as I watched like
SpaceX efforts and blue origin and these
efforts
is still not trivial to record the uh
how just amazing awe-inspiring spaces
because it like
you know like it's like Elon jokes about
like his face does look fake yeah like I
think there is some element of it where
you have to be there to experience it
really and I don't like I think it's
it's currently is still an unsolved
problem of how do you capture the awe of
that I mean you're one of the early
people that are uh part of the crew that
is exploring that very question I'm sure
you won't find all the answers but
you'll start to say like how do we
convert this into a visual format into
some kind of format that captures the
the magic of it 100 and that's a
perspective thing that I think about all
the time you know when I I'll I'll do a
lot of thinking about like what is the
thing that's reacting to people is it
the sound is it the perspective is it
like seeing a little tiny human next to
a landing leg that makes people go oh my
God this thing is huge you know just
reading you know and digesting that and
trying to help
to convey that as best as possible
because the stuff that we are and have
worked on is is so cool it's so exciting
and it's so it's so important and like
actually you know
so much bigger than any one of us
physically and metaphorically it's just
so it's just I wish everyone had that
that experience and had that light bulb
go off and that's the cool thing that
you're like smack in the middle of
solving that really difficult and
fascinating problem of how how do you
capture the magic how do you inspire
like that's not just an engineering
problem that's a communication problem
education I I find specifically for
myself that I get most excited about
something when I learn a lot about it
like when I learned the ins and outs and
I learn all the little problem solving
and the you know the cool like oh my God
they had to do what to make it work wow
that's amazing and that's I try to just
always go back to that thing of like
what can I teach myself like if I'm
every video I I expect that I learned
something making it no matter what like
no matter how uh much I think I know
about something at the end of the day if
I'm not learning something it's not a
good video you know and
I always think that people get excited
when they learn and when they have uh
some questions answered for them
let me ask you a couple of quick out
there futuristic questions I have to
sure I'd hate myself if I don't ask you
so first let's talk about nuclear
propulsion so out there interesting
propulsion ideas uh so what do you think
beyond the the chemical engines that we
talked about what do you think about
using nuclear
fishing and maybe even nuclear fusion
for uh for propulsion we already have
thermal nuclear reactors uh they're
nuclear engines that have been tested
both by the United States and Soviet
Union that were 100 valid like totally
ready to go efficient super awesome
um yes yes yes hardcore yes
um and what what they're using is yeah
basically a fusion reactor you're
flowing hydrogen through it and heating
up the hydrogen taking it from liquid to
a gas you know and by heating it up
you're adding energy to the propellant
and then you're literally just using
that now steam hot hydrogen and flowing
it through a d level nozzle and you also
have to use that that energy to spin the
pumps to still pump the thing so you're
still kind of using like a lot of the
tricks that you're using but instead of
a chemical reaction you're literally
just using
nuclear fission to heat up propellant
and do the same thing and at the end of
the day end up with like eight to nine
hundred seconds of specific impulse
which is double that of chemical
propulsion most of that comes just
because hydrogen is so light you're only
emitting you're only ejecting hydrogen
out of the nozzle so the lighter
molecule is the faster you know just
like if you had a
you know a golf ball versus like a
bowling ball you can only physically
throw one so fast and the other one as a
human you're not going to do very well
with so you can just you get you have
the more potential for a higher exit
velocity so nuclear thermal amazing you
can just shoot these little hydrogen
molecules out crazy fast crazy
efficiently we already have it like we
can do it yes yes and actually we're
already re uh investing in that again as
United States is is looking at a
basically ramping back up our nuclear
propulsion why haven't we done it yet
and uh what do you think the challenges
are there and do you think that's an
obvious future like would you would you
see in 50 years we're not using
um
like we're not you for major projects
like a Starship type of project we're
not using chemical propulsion anymore
for getting off Earth you'll always want
to use chemical propulsion because the
the gas will become irradiated like you
don't but you don't want to and and
actually the Thruster weight ratio of
these engines are relatively poor
they're they're very heavy they have a
nuclear reactor like they're not they're
really the reason we kind of give up on
them is they're really most useful for
like interplanetary if you're trying to
get a big like if you're trying to send
a huge payload off to Mars nuclear
thermal is amazing it's still could be
beneficial even going to the Moon you
know like in an Earth Moon system you
could use nuclear thermal uh very
effectively it could be a great choice
but it also that starts to get into that
trait of like well we can just kind of
use a little bit bigger rocket and
and fly a normal you know it's it's that
whole trade thing but another reason why
we kind of stopped using them the the
one that the United States developed
nerva was so heavy only a Saturn V could
actually lift the stage of it like the
upper stage so replace the s4b with a
nuclear thermal with the nerva engine
um the Soviet Union developed one about
one tenth the size and and thrust that
was small enough to fly in Pro on a
proton rocket
um but neither of them ever flew both of
them have been tested and like thumbs up
ready to go was just a huge shame to me
because they could unlock a lot of
interplanetary potential and yeah just
all around us which potentially
Interstellar as well not I don't think
nuclear thermal not we're not quite
getting there but then you get into like
nuclear pulse drives and things where
you're literally like
basically ejecting a bomb out the back
of your rocket and exploding and having
like a shock absorber and pogo sticking
your way out of the solar system
that that's I mean by all physics sure
you know there's not nothing wrong with
that it's not breaking any laws of
physics and
you know I but I just don't see us
getting to that need anytime soon I
don't think we're just going to travel
yeah I mean that's that's I think we're
going to want a better understanding of
physics and physics itself yeah do you
have a hope that maybe theoretical
physics will open the door to some
exciting propulsion systems yeah I do I
think we're still at the very infancy of
our understanding of everything and how
things work and you know 100 years ago
it would be stupid to try to predict the
things we know today and who knows like
even you know I think about things like
James Webb looking deeper into our solar
system than ever before and physically
being able to see objects that we just
have not even been able to physically
see before on being able to study black
holes for example uh a better better
this stuff that's happening outside of
black holes at the edges of black holes
how the information is stored uh the uh
100 holographic principles just there's
so much weirdness black holes yes around
where gravity starts bending light
it's like all right we get to look at
that now and start to wonder like what
is going on and how can we like use that
somehow exactly propulsion I mean it
seems like awfully crazy and futuristic
at this moment but I think that's
because we know almost nothing about uh
you know that those kinds of objects
where again where the general relativity
and quantum mechanics start to start to
um have to be both considered to
describe those kinds of objects and as
we study those objects we might figure
out some kind of unification thing that
will allow us to uh understand maybe how
to use black holes to for propulsion
like yeah
I could say a lot of crazy things but
like basically but the point is it'd be
stupid for us to even guess about things
we don't even know about yet you know
what I mean like and so therefore I'm
not going to say that the best option
for Interstellar travel is
nuclear drives like that could be like
someone saying you know in 1600 the only
way to fly is by strapping a thousand
Birds to your head you know like
but that said I mean everything you're
saying is right but the human history is
such like at the beginning of the 20th
century physicists Rutherford they
everybody this This brilliant people
that said we've basically solved all of
it right if you talk to most physicists
I think they're going to say like we've
pretty much
solved like the standard model describes
physics extremely accurately right uh
general relativity explains the cosmos
as we observe them extremely accurately
yeah there's a whole Dark Matter Dark
Energy things whatever yeah but uh
outside of that so like we basically
solved like
like where are you going to find gaps in
knowledge that are going to somehow
create warp drives or something like
that so wormholes uh but uh that's it
seems like throughout history we prove
ourselves wrong time and time again yes
no I and I this is well outside of any
of my knowledge base so I want to make
sure that if I say anything stupid it's
because I'm I just did a peasant here in
physics land but yes
um we're all peasants in physics land
but I really just think like it's very
humbling that we're still using chemical
propulsion and and variant cell like
injecting mass to to propel ourselves
and I I and no matter how you get at it
and I think someday I I would expect
that our species has figured out a way
to get beyond that
gotta ask you another wild question
what do you think of uh Bob Lazar
who uh claimed that uh he worked at and
saw in Area 51 a propulsional system
fueled by
I'm quoting here maybe from Wikipedia I
don't know where I got this from uh
fueled by an antimatter reactor which
used as fuel the chemical element with
atomic number 115 at the time it wasn't
synthesized it was later in in 2003
synthesized named muscovium
he said that the propulsion system
relied on a stable isotope of element
115 which allegedly generates a gravity
wave that allowed the vehicle to fly
into evade visual detection by bending
light around it
no stabilizer dose
of muscovium have yet been synthesized
all have proven extremely radioactive
decaying in a few hundred milliseconds
one do you believe him which I I find
him fascinating because it's uh I find
the human mind even more fascinating
then um
then then something like an antimatter
drive because I think it's such a giant
mystery that we haven't even begun to
explore deeply anyway
um in that sense whether he's lying or
not are both interesting things to
explore from a psychology perspective
but to
and he's basically saying that I guess
it's an alien
uh
extraterrestrial engine thing
um
what do you think I mean I'm happy to
change my opinion based on new evidence
at any point
I have like
the
part of me wants to just be like this is
obviously just stupid and a hoax and
just total you know quack
and then another part of me still is
like this is exciting and fun to think
that this is all real and then another
part of me goes why
how how good is this guy at lying and
making stuff up because it's all
really good like good storytelling good
like I don't know what to think honestly
I don't know I'm really very skeptical
about anyone explaining anything like
this like I mean my my radar is like
screaming at me like this is all app
full crap you know
but I'd say like there's still an
apartment just like man that is kind of
cool how did he know that and like you
know what I mean well I think you're
conflicted I think you're actually in
the in the best kind of place because
it's uh
I'm afraid of being the kind of person
that hears something like that and says
it's definitely
um he's definitely full of crap and
basically closed my mind off to all that
stuff I'm afraid of being somebody who
closes my mind off to a thing that's
actually uh a early thread to a
brilliant to it to a future to a
fascinating solution to a mystery so uh
but in this case I mean I have so many
red flags from a psychological
perspective that um
that but again uh outside of this
particular individual I do wonder if
aliens have visited us
I think aliens are everywhere I think
the universe is teeming with alien life
I mean there's
it's very difficult for me to
statistically understand given
how
life finds a way here on Earth just
everywhere is the entire history of life
on Earth from the very origin of life it
seems to be damn good at doing its thing
evolving to get better and better and
better at doing its thing now there
could be some special aspects to the
origin of life itself which is
completely not understood so maybe the
true magic is in the origin of life
or it could be that there is some
magical leaps uh to uh eukaryotic cells
for example that the Universe our
galaxies teeming with alien life but
it's all bacteria they're all boring
bacteria or exciting bacteria no offense
to bacteria the but the no intelligence
space-faring civilizations I don't know
but
I just if I were to guess if I had to
bet all my money
there is space faring civilizations
everywhere in the universe
and the fact that they're not that they
have not been directly definitively
observed
confuses me and I think it's a mystery
and if I were to suggest what solution
to that mystery is is they might look
extremely different from us
and we might be too dumb to detect them
yeah and then and so there I think you
have to be extremely open-minded
at what would we be looking for right
that and that that's a very practical
thing to be open-minded about and
practically speaking if we were to be
able to even detect them from a distance
get a tech techno signature of a distant
planet of a distant star system that has
alien life
honestly the number one thing I kind of
want to know is like
what's your propulsion system
how do we travel faster right like
there's a bunch of details probably but
first let's get together and teach me
how to go fast go fast I like
motorcycles I like rockets exactly what
you got yeah uh yeah like how like I'll
show you mine if you show me yours kind
of thing at the at the inter
Interstellar Intergalactic uh level
um yeah anyway I just wonder
maybe it's a cheat code in this video
game we call life but I wanna I wanna
use the cheat code to figure out what
kind of propulsion systems are possible
and it feels like other alien
civilizations might help us give us
um
give us a guidance on that of course I
think even just
discovering
boy one of the things with a space
program like everything we're doing with
Mars
like the secret thing I'm really excited
about the romantic thing is humans on
Mars but the secret thing is building
giant stations on Mars that allow us to
definitely
hopefully find the traces of life that
either currently doesn't live or has
once lived on Mars because if that's the
case that means for sure life is
everywhere oh 100 and then you're like
and once you know that sorry to keep
interrupting not shutting the hell up is
this supposed to be an interview God
damn it all right uh that uh like that
just the knowledge of that just the
knowledge that a form minute mile can be
run I think we'll open our minds
completely to really really hardcore
push to Interstellar travel or
colonizing Mars becoming multiple entire
species it'd be truly inspiring
you think that
do you do you get nervous though like
I'm gonna I'm the interviewer now yeah
um don't you get nervous that we could
make spectacular discovery on Mars that
not only has there been life there's
actually like pretty Advanced Micro you
know or a multicellular life totally
thriving in certain regions we just
hadn't visited the man on Mars and we
make this big discovery that
um a relatively large percentage of
people just simply wouldn't believe it
they think it's all yeah 100 fake and
that they're just doing this to control
us and that blah blah blah like we could
make the most important discovery
in human life like in all of human
existence that that we're not alone in
this universe
by you know cellularly at least and a
good percentage of people I'm thinking
20 30 40 in today's world 40 plus
percent of people wouldn't even believe
it existed interesting I I I'd be it's
just a very important thing to think
about especially as an educator like
yourself
I think the the current cynicism towards
institutions and science is temporary I
think it's they're basically the
internet woke up
the internet smells [__] and it
looked at uh I'm sorry I'm not being
ageless but saying older scientists and
and they looked at them and they kind of
said you're kind of full of [__] you got
a lot of ego uh you're you speak down to
everybody you're not very good at
communicating I think there's a lot of
Truth to what they're saying and I think
the young scientists that are coming up
will be much better at not being full of
[__] being authentic being real not
treating uh people like their children
they can't possibly understand like
taking it very seriously that there's a
lot of intelligent people out there that
are curious that are this full desire
for knowledge like being transparent
about all the uncertainties uh of the
scientific process all the tensions the
conflicts all of that and I I think
I think once we fix the community
science Communication System adapted to
the internet
um I think that won't be an issue I I
hope I hope I mean that's that's why
people like you are really important is
it's like uh communicate with
authenticity
um
but yeah that's definitely something to
think about I mean yes the early uh I
mean listen scientists too like the
phosphine discovered on on Venus is like
they're extremely skeptical always uh so
definitely there will there will be a
lot of skepticism uh it and it depends
what it looks like if it kind of looks
like this thing kind of looks like
bacteria back on Earth uh yes uh so it
means contamination is very difficult to
avoid in general but if the thing looks
like fundamentally different yeah then
you're like all right yeah that like
totally different DNA RNA like this is
not we would never observe this ever
yeah then uh then you're like all right
cool of course and uh so that another
promising thing that difficult to be
definitive about but let's get better
and better direct Imaging systems
there's now uh like I don't know how
many but thousands of planets are being
discovered outside of our solar system
there's moons being discovered now the
earth-like planets being discovered so
like all of that if you could do direct
Imaging of those planets more and more
and more uh there could be some gigantic
listen if there is like a Kardashian
like type 2 civilization we're gonna see
the damn thing it's going to be
producing a lot of uh it's going to be
radiating a lot of energy so the
possibility of detecting someone that
that's also a real possibility with
something like James Webb telescopes
like those kinds of efforts that starts
becoming a reality uh have you read Andy
Weir's project Hail Mary I have not no
you're going to love it like it is
basically uh
almost answering that like how could
they not see us type of thing almost
where he creates this this incredible I
don't want to spoil anything but you
know um it's just the sense of like
we could have totally different
perspectives with with an alien race and
not even like consider that you know the
two of us are coexisting almost yeah I
don't want to spoil anything because
it's really really really worth the read
or Oh you mean a different perspective
like the aliens have a different
perspective than humans yeah like but we
just like we see with this visual light
yeah someone could see in x-ray et
cetera you know like and just the way we
even come to the same perspective like
looking and observing is just so
different fundamentally
that like we could I mean it's not quite
like that it's not like it's like oh
they were actually on the moon and we're
you know it's nothing like that but uh
but it's such a unique and incredible
story I think Andy Weir is one of the
the best science fiction writers I don't
I can't say that with much Authority
because I don't listen to much science
fiction
so zero 30. I really like Andy Weir's
books and that book is no different but
that sounds like I'm really worried
about this I was like uh I would really
love it I've uh definitely I've been
very
uh I've I've done a lot of reading in my
life but like the science fiction is one
of the things I've been really really
weak on I haven't really read much and I
just made more and more friends over the
years recently
um that say
that I absolutely must read some of
these things are you do you physically
read or do you do audio books while you
run and stuff uh well I I do both yeah
but physically I sadly don't it's a
Kindle right yeah yeah yeah yeah but uh
but while I run I also do uh so I do
both I do about
uh on a normal day especially now
because I've been really focused on on
reading it's about 60 Minutes of
reading on a Kindle and I wanted two
hours uh because I run about two hours
when I don't have like other stuff like
today I won't run uh so it's about three
hours so on average I would say it's
like two two and a half hours a day and
I read an audiobook is just the same
they're a little slower but they're they
they can especially for the classics
they can capture some of the magic with
the deep voice usually with the British
accent I love it I also read that uh
listen to sorry that uh a book on
propulsion like two years ago I remember
but I remember that was extremely
definition yeah it was an issue by John
D Clark yeah
it was very difficult to listen oh I
yeah I see I don't read I listen when
I'm on road trips or running or stuff
like that too so I swear there's
probably 40 or like not 40 but there's
like eight minutes of we tried PMZ 15
yeah 13
bm412 rmnl mitral muscle hydrogen for
like I swear it's multiple minutes of
explaining one trial on something
because there's just so many different
chemicals they try I don't know it's
it's it's almost a joke like I literally
audibly laughed out loud listening to it
because I'm like this is so ridiculous
I'm sure it makes sense reading it but
like listening to it is just hilarious
but it's great though
what do you think of some of the
challenges for long-term space travel do
you think about this kind of stuff the
biological stuff yeah
um do you do you worry do you think
about radiation on Mars
uh and out in Space over periods of uh
actually the effects on the human body
forget even the radiation over periods
of months and years yeah
I think realistically we have a really
good handle on what the effects are
and we actually have the solution to
like everything it's just whether or not
we can like you know for instance one of
the you know in low earth orbit one of
the biggest challenges eventually after
your long-term space travel is bone
density loss and not having gravity you
know you actually have issues with a
handful of things and artificial gravity
is easy in terms of relatively easy in
terms of uh space flight you know you
can you have two vehicles just tethered
together and you know just spinning uh
give it enough distance and a decent
enough spin velocity and you can you can
get one gene like relatively easy we're
talking again relatively easy especially
after talking about theoretical physics
like this is that's easy stuff
um we haven't done that yet but like
there's there's no reason why we can't
produce artificial gravity if we say
that that's
um you know a big enough hurdle that we
absolutely have to overcome this okay
cool we'll just spin up two vehicles
that are going to Mars and people will
have but you know that's the thing is
Mars is only about we'll say six months
there then you're hanging out on Mars
you have 38 of gravity and then six
months ish back people live on you know
the International Space Station at six
month stints we've had people for
basically a year up on the International
Space Station it's not like it's it's
not life-altering yeah you have a couple
days of not being able to walk very well
and you do have some bone density loss
and some other concerns but like again
that's
it's solvable and I think you know the
first mission is to Mars
I think it might we might we'll probably
do the trade is it worth it to like land
on Mars and have a crippled crew that
can't even physically stand yet you know
for a day or two before they get their
you know feet from underneath them or is
it do we need to spin up
two Space Crafter you know a tether and
have like you can't do it like Starship
you know even though it's 30 feet wide
or nine meters wide if you spin it on
that one axis
um that's not enough space to get 1G uh
without your feet and your head being at
two different uh velocities so you get
really sick at all you always feel like
you're falling your brain will tell you
that you're falling constantly
um but then again okay so this is this
is the whole thing is
I you know and I don't know if there's
we don't really have the data yet on
like going from zero g we know the
effects of that we know the effects of
1G really well that's our majority of
our data set but we don't really have
much data on the long-term effects of
uh you know 1 6 gravity like on the moon
or 38 gravity is it is 1 6 gravity
actually enough to counteract 95 of the
effects of low gravity or is it 15 for
you know is it 1 6 the is it like a
linear thing is 38 gravity totally you
know 38 as bad as one or whatever you
know is it a slight like where is it out
on the scale so there's a chance that we
don't need anywhere near one g of
gravity to counteract the bulk majority
of these problems we could have
0.1 G or whatever is the you know the
right compromise of of vehicle
complexity and human biology and all of
these other effects like we this is
absolutely a solvable thing that is and
and all we figure some of this out
through just experimentation 100 along
the way yep uh one of this is back to my
dating life I think one of the essential
fundamental research questions I'm
wondering about is uh the Dynamics and
um
so the details of how you have sex in
space
um asking for a friend of course I mean
that's there literally is sort of work
on this right because like if you think
about long-term space travel
I mean
sex is is uh
sort of like the there's the
recreational aspect of sex but the most
important aspect of sex for long-term
space travel is
um
uh procreations
and also the full biological cycle of
that so that from the embryo the
development of the baby the giving the
birth and all that kind of stuff so like
you know there's a lot of really
difficult
problems of biology there to understand
and uh but perhaps it's all some of that
again just like you said brilliantly
some of that can be just solved with
engineering outside of the human body by
creating a gravitational field like that
but maybe along the way you can figure
out how to do that without doing it but
we're balancing the cost and so on and
radiation is the other thing we know we
have a really good data set on what
radiation and doses do to humans like we
we know we can measure radiation we know
we can approximate you know and kind of
give edge cases for the Mars transient
and getting to Mars and being on Mars
and the simple answer to that is like at
the end of the day if we have to you
know dig into Mars or find a tunnel to
to live in so you get some extra mass in
between you and Cosmic radiation so be
it like that's the that's the answer
then again none of these are like
insolvable problems they're just things
the hurdles you would have to overcome
based on
you know the the risk exposure and the
posture there imagine being
the first
child the first baby born
outside of Earth
that'd be pretty cool yeah I would love
to be alive to see that that's a big one
I don't know if they'll um
I don't know because it's such a
dangerous thing it's so risky I think
that could be in our lifetime you think
so yeah
I I would like to think in a perfect
world of her thinking futurism then
30 to 50 years I definitely think we
could have a full-time like permanent
major civilizations you know like like
um
uh like what blue origin wants to
develop where they have a a huge like
sphere you know and you're doing a lot
of uh especially heavy industry off of
Earth you're not polluting earth like
that's makes so much sense to me
um I yeah I think I think we
we could live in a lifetime where you
know we thought that since the 50s and
60s that people are going to be living
and working in space like crazy and at
any given point we're lucky to have 12
people in space today
um
but I really think In Our Lifetime we're
finally getting to that point of
yeah that that's a reality let me
because you mentioned blue origin I can
we just lay out some of the competitors
to SpaceX so much of what we talked
about is uh SpaceX specifically because
they're sort of pushing the boundaries
of what's possible in the commercial
space light but there's a lot of like
you said incredible work being done for
large companies and small companies
startups and so on uh so who are the
competitors to SpaceX
Ula United launch Alliance blue origin
as a Virgin uh is it Galactic orbit
orbit or the competitor virgin orbit uh
there's a rocket Labs electron rocket
that you mentioned
um there's the folks you covered Firefly
yep and uh what are we missing there's
the the Epic space launch system
from NASA I guess that is yeah
technically NASA but prime contractor
Boeing and Boeing
yeah the boosters yep okay nice so like
what uh what's what's interesting to say
to lay out the land here that you're
excited about just in general I think if
you aren't working on a reusable some
form of reusable vehicle like physically
working on it pen to paper not Beyond
pen to paper like bending metal for a
reusable vehicle you're gone you're
toast
I think we're well into that being the
only
provable you know Way Forward the only
way you're going to compete and survive
is a reusable rocket fully reusable
would be great but that's obviously
massively aspirational still
um but it will come but to me
um
the the yeah the list you pretty much
had it right on the head uh there's
there's Astra was another orbital rocket
company
um they there's a lot of companies and I
think right now the
the ones that I personally really
believe in
um you know rocket lab is is awesome I
really think that they are
one of the few that I believe can
actually build a falcon 9 class rocket
uh like today with the with their
technology with their knowledge with
their Investments with their funding you
know like they've and they've proven
themselves there's very few they have
actually made it look easy I think
there's a lot of startups and a lot of
new rocket there's a too many launch
providers popping out of the woodwork
right now they won't all survive of
course I think realistically if you look
at like airplanes how many airplane you
know there's a handful of airplane
manufacturers there's not hundreds and
thousands of airplane manufacturers I
think it'll be a similar thing for space
flight I think we'll see we'll see you
know realistically in the terms of jumbo
adjusting passengers there's basically
two you know there's Airbus and there's
Boeing
um so I I think in the long run there'll
be two or three major players
I think they'll be you know 10
minor like as far as launch providers as
far as the ones actually leaving Earth
and getting into orbit I just don't
think there's a ton of room for
individuality really you know yeah I
would love to see it like a really
serious competitor uh to SpaceX in the
way that SpaceX does things I don't know
if you'll like is quite
what I it's quite the right kind of
competitor let me let me say this Ula
has all of the potential but just
operationally they're you know they're
either Lockheed Martin and Boeing's like
love child yeah but they're
kind of set up in a far too traditional
manner where they just really aren't
given the opportunity to innovate like a
lot of these startups are so rocket lab
is a little bit more of that nature what
do you think about sort of just blue
origin in general Georgians ah man I
what blue origin has done with new
Shepard is amazing and people just lot
it because it's sub-orbital and it looks
very phallic it's
it's uh so I guess the meme matters also
it's modern day but it's sad because
people don't see what they are also
working on which is new Glenn you know I
I see comments almost every day still of
like it doesn't matter because you know
they're they're working on Tiny it's
like no new Glenn is more powerful and
more capable than Falcon heavy new Glenn
is almost more of a competitor to not
quite as to Starship but it's almost in
that class it's a it's a heavy lift
launch vehicle it's huge it's crazy
it'll be nuts they're very actively
working on it you know I still think
we're three years away from it launching
but that's a very strong competitor in
the class of rockets at SpaceX is
currently making so SpaceX is currently
leading the way but that that it
couldn't become a close race and what
it's just I we'll just for now we'll
ignore SpaceX and we'll just kind of
talk about like I think who's kind of
coming around the corner here who's here
so let me just do a quick overview I'm
going to shoot myself in the foot for
getting some cool people here and some
some exciting companies but relativity
is one that if you you should definitely
get to MLS on the show who is the uh CEO
of Relativity they're doing 3D printed
Rockets
the ones that have the world's largest
3D printer they're getting really close
to their first orbital launch
um the cool thing about them the reason
that I think they're exciting the reason
that I I think they have the potential
is just how quickly they can iterate I
think 3D printing a rocket is really
dumb
I think iterating with 3D printing on a
rocket is brilliant because you can
literally change software and have like
very little you know upload a file and
have a new rocket like that's amazing so
in terms of long-term iterative process
if if we're really talking about like
hitting the ground running and and just
seeing where the the evolution takes you
I think that's about as good as you can
get you know I think what SpaceX is
doing at Starbase just physically
bending cheap steel is probably also a
very valid solution
all right so I really think and they
have the engineering jobs I think
they've got some amazing people there
um again rocket lab I adore what they
work on and you know like every everyone
there's a caveat here that everything
takes longer anything any company tells
you it's two or three times longer just
period rocket lab's no different
um but I really they're they're working
on a neutron rocket that's going to be
um like I think eight thousand to
fifteen thousand kilograms to low earth
orbit like it's a good medium class
rocket well compete right along with
Falcon 9 hopefully by the way Neutron
would be its name right yeah yeah so
that's like kind of neutron it's not
some kind of fascinating new physics
breakthrough where they're using
neutrons no no but they are using
they're also using liquid methane and
liquid oxygen
um I just think it's a really it's a
seems like a great rocket and assuming
they can actually get it flying in two
or three years I think they're gonna be
it's here to stay you know
um I I'd be remiss right now I'm editing
a video from an interview with Stoke
Aerospace out in in Kent Washington
um it's just one of these companies that
they have a long ways to go like they're
still in the very they're they're behind
the curve frankly in in terms of launch
Vehicles right now because like I said
there's so many coming out of the
woodwork but the idea they're working on
their solution to a fully reusable
rocket is amazing one of the coolest
Concepts I've ever seen are you going to
cover in the video yeah yeah that'll be
hopefully coming out the next depending
on what the schedule like is down there
I'm work I'm actively editing that as we
speak and it is
so cool I mean it is like it's it's
genius and um if they can actually get
it to work I can see them merging I can
for sure see someone potentially like I
perfectly in a perfect world they merge
with rocket lab they uh Stoke develops
the upper stage and maybe even the
engines they are the two guys the the
CEO the co-founders of that company
um have they are engine like propulsion
engineer magnificence they have they
used to they both have worked at Blue
they developed engines in a hurry there
and then left blue and it felt like it
was getting too slow for them and now
they are I mean these these guys fired a
15 chambered rocket engine instead of
four from the Soviet we're talking 15
Chambers single turbo pump
uh 70 times in the month of October wow
wow that's impressive wow and that's
like that was on average you know if you
think about like days off time off you
know Parts changing yes over twice a day
on average of a hydrolux engine that's
insane so I I love them and I hope the
best for them uh but they're also
topical right now they're top of my head
so uh what about Firefly what I like
about Firefly they've already got kind
of a traditional Aerospace backing
they're starting to Buddy up a lot with
Northrop grumman's they're going to be
building the booster stage for Antares
which is currently flying only out of
Wallops Virginia and is one of the only
other commercial providers for the
International Space Station and Northrop
Grumman is a very traditional Aerospace
company you know like lots of solid
rocket boosters and they've purchased
ironically their their current Antares
is reliant on Russian engines and
Ukrainian boosters two things that I
don't think are going to be able to get
your hands on too much anymore so yes
they're looking to uh um some U.S
propulsion and stages so they actually
are partnering with uh with firefly and
their new Antares rocket will be a first
stage built entirely by Firefly so I'm
excited that Firefly already has the
propulsion technology
um and they actually developed
ironically their tap off cycle engine
was developed uh in partnership with
Ukraine with Ukrainian Engineers uh who
developed the the whole turbo pump
system so it's like it's this cool
meddling of of these worlds
um their former CEO Tom marcusic was all
like I have an interview with him and
he's anyone that can just
spout nuances and facts I just love I
just soaked that guy's information up as
best I could because he is brilliant
literally a doctor a rocket doctor you
know it's so yeah I mean that's what
like you said the fascinating thing
about these folks they're they're legit
they're they're such great Engineers
that people that bring these Rockets to
life and then there's all the stuff that
we know and don't know about in uh in
China and other parts and other nations
that are putting stuff into orbit one of
the sad things also is like you know
with Lockheed and and Boeing
is uh
it's just military applications in
general there's so much technology
that's currently being developed that we
probably know nothing about yeah
and um yeah it makes me a little bit sad
of course
yeah but for several reasons one is that
the use of that technology is has really
much like it's not it's not that
inspired it's like a very military Focus
yes to kill someone is to kill someone
yeah uh there's not even like a
a side application right and and the the
big one is that the secret it's it's
shroud and in secrecy as opposed to
being a source of inspiration yeah 100
but that's the way of the world like
what was that one plane that you covered
that was like we know nothing about oh
the X-37B the x37b yeah orbited for over
900 days and returned like yeah I want
to set that thing up to I don't know
that's what's it's so frustrating we
know when it launches people you know
amateurs track and no they even will be
like oh it changed orbit you know it
raised and lowered its orbit blah blah
we generally have just almost no idea
what it's doing up there and I just
saddens me because I want to know and
it's awesome it's a great vehicle
War what is it good for
uh you mentioned Kerbal Space Program
the video game uh someone asked you what
video game you recommend for learning
about space and Rockets and you said
duh Kerbal Space Program so tell me
about this game what is this game and I
also saw heard that a second one is
coming out so what what what
like uh you know I've been playing more
games recently uh because games are fun
and they remind you that life is awesome
uh so why should I play this game if you
want to learn about Rockets how to fly
how to build how to get into orbit how
to get to other planets there's no
better way to learn about Rockets this
whole language what does it entail like
do you actually like uh it's like
SimCity and Microsoft flight simulator
for Rockets oh interesting so you'll get
to like what do you design the Rockets
yeah
yeah it's okay so I started playing it
in like 2014 I think around as I'm like
falling in love with space and I became
obsessed with this game like literally
you you know you you you take a like you
get a little Command Module click you
click on a fuel tank Boop you choose
your engine Boop you choose a stage
connector Boop you connect more tanks
and build these space planes and
Fantastical things and it's all like
physics based it's a fail this sounds
like a commercial it's available on PC
I'm so hacking and console like it's
available everywhere but wait there's
more but wait there's more and you you
uh you said like you streamed yourself
playing this at those any of those
videos up oh yeah yeah there's some of
my actually the first videos I ever
uploaded to YouTube were re like
recaptured streams from twitch that are
just physically uploaded to YouTube this
is awesome and so it's it's me playing
Chrome we I used to do this kind of like
a podcast style thing uh I should get
back into this because it's one of my
favorite things I ever did it's called
we called it today's in space fight
history but these days I'd probably just
play Kerbal but I had my friend come sit
next to me his name's Jacob and he is a
former professional pole vaulter just
this really knows nothing about Rockets
yes knows nothing about space hilarious
like in the sweetest most fun way you
know like he you know as an adult asked
me which is bigger the Earth or the Moon
and I love that for him you know that's
that's fantastic he's just a delightful
human he would sit next to me we would
recreate a historical space flight
mission in Kerbal Space Program and he
would just sit there and play guitar and
sing about what I'm like doing and
asking questions yeah and it's still one
of my favorite things I've ever done
yeah you should definitely do something
like that so basically just uh yeah
shoot the [__] with a friend get their
curiosity going let them just sit there
and ask questions it was awesome like I
mean yeah those are some I I've done it
a handful of times I think we probably
did like 20 or 30 episodes or something
and it is it's definitely something I
would like to get back to doing can you
in the in the game like go to go to the
Moon Yeah so it's technically a
different solar system it's the Kerbal
system and you're on the planet curbin
so there's the mun m-u-n there's a
second moon in the system uh on this
planet uh it's called mid Miss they
didn't want to pay licensing fees or
what
well it's just a little easier it's a
little bit smaller so the physics are
easier oh so it tries to be consistent
with physics yeah oh yeah yeah the
physics are all are all like real world
physics and I mean there's Aero
simulations there's all of it's like one
to one you know for Earth physics
awesome it's just on an easier scale
solar system so it's easier to to
navigate but there's still like there's
a planet called Eve that's kind of like
Venus so it has a really thick
atmosphere really thick really soupy
it's um it's and a lot more gravity so
it's just really really hard to get off
of
um it's easy relatively easy to land on
Eve but like that's kind of like the
ultimate boss in the game it's like
getting off of Eve so that's one of my
favorite things to do is build these
crafts to to get to even and try to
return home you mentioned that there's
almost like a podcast thing you also did
uh our Lucas future what uh
is there a podcast in your future are
you are you thinking do you enjoy the
medium you're so incredibly good at
talking it's less effort to uh
sort of to produce are you is that
something in the in the back of your
mind also oh man I love talking yeah
you're very good at it I mean yeah
um I
I find that I it's just the problem with
for me with with podcasts and I guess
the podcasts that I've done have tried
to be relatively topical about like the
current space flight Affairs and four
three or four years ago that was
actually you know manageable for me to
keep up with these days man I can't keep
I just can't keep up with it I gave up
on trying to be super topical and I
realized that maybe my my biggest talent
and the things that resonate most with
people is just trying to explain the
like the basics and the and the the root
it really get so I'm really just trying
to like
I'm trying to do less live streams if I
can but then again like Starship I gotta
stream that there's no way I'm not going
to do that but I'm really just trying to
get back to like making the Deep dive
videos where I have no limit on how long
and how deep and just really go for it
because that's actually what I love to
do the best yeah I mean this is like uh
views aside those are just works of
genius and you're getting better and
better at them and like that's the
that in in terms of the beautiful things
you can create in this world those are
that so it's like if you continue
especially where the the way space
travel is developing right like that
your voice is very much needed so I
think it's wise to um
to do what you do best and I I think I'm
feeling more and more especially this
last year I did a lot of like live
streaming and traveling back and forth
between Florida and California and here
and just handling major like big live
streams really stress myself out and at
the end of the day I was like all of
this is taking away from my ability to
make videos and that's ideally honestly
if I like had my choice of things I
would just ignore everything else and
just sit and lock myself in a in in my
house for a year and just sit there and
make videos and and go and travel every
every other month you know for fun like
not for space stuff just go and and do
some light traveling you know some like
around the moon or what
yeah just some light traveling
uh what advice would you give to Young
Folks
um or just folks struggling to find
their way in life uh whether they're in
high school college or Beyond like how
to have a life they can be proud of how
to have a career they can be proud of
you've had a really interesting journey
to yourself
what what from that can you draw
give your advice to others to be honest
like I feel like it's so painfully
obvious to follow your heart and follow
like what makes you happy that I'm just
shocked that people allow themselves
to sit on like mediocrity you know like
to just sit there and be like well this
is just what I do you know and someone
for a lot of people that's perfectly
fine like I have you know some of my
best friends are clocking in and out and
they're perfectly happy they have a
wonderful life absolutely no judgment
there of course
um but
for people that are stuck feeling like
they're not sure of you know what's next
and how to bring light into their world
uh you really just gotta listen to like
what does make you happy you know people
feel guilty about oh I play video games
for eight hours then start learning how
to make a video game learn how to do
reviews of video games or make there's
so many you can work in the video game
industry you know you don't have to
isolate your love from your work you
know and it's just funny that we you
know maybe uh maybe you feel guilty that
you drink too much okay I don't know if
there's a good advice go go learn how to
make alcohol you know be a star liquor
company yeah start a liquor company
that's great advice but it's also in
your own story it seems like you've
almost stumbled on like
some of it is just exploration and
keeping your mind and heart open to
discovering that thing that grabs you
right it's what do you fall asleep
thinking about you know like but you you
stumbled on the space almost
accidentally right I mean yeah yeah okay
did you would you when you were doing up
being a professional photographer would
you have known oh no well do you want to
know what I wanted to be when I was a
kid what's that well first when I was
young I wanted to be a tractor I'm not
quite sure I understood yeah how that
works then I wanted to be a scorpion
trainer yeah thought I could train him
to cut people's Lawns better yep yep and
then honestly the majority of my
childhood goes along I think your
understanding of physics early on was
just a little
the Pinter's man Pinterest uh then uh
from like probably six until like early
college I wanted to be a prosthetic
engineer
and never once did I think about
anything Rockets really you know I had
like a I had like a special poster I had
some space shuttle Legos you know I
liked space and you know I knew of the
Space Shuttle but uh you know it was a
fart on the list as far as things that I
thought were cool
Ninja Turtles Lamborghini Countach
b17g Flying Fortress Yeah I guess I
guess that means if you just keep your
heart open to falling in love with an
idea with a passion yeah you could start
from that from Ninja Turtles and
scorpions getting along to uh being one
of the best one of the top Educators
inspirational figures in space
and actually traveling around the moon
and who knows maybe one day stepping
foot on the moon and Mars even though
you say you're not interested it seems
like you stating that you're not
interested in certain things somehow
results in you and you're doing those
things my friends joke that like I'm
gonna be the first person to go to the
Moon against their will yeah like I
guess all right yeah this is uh all
right what's the thing guys we're gonna
start a fundraiser please like Tim just
doesn't want to have to he doesn't want
to go you know definitely don't want to
do it all right Tim you're an incredible
person thank you so much for everything
you do I've I've been a fan of yours for
a long time not just the the content but
just who you are as a human being just
how excited you are for everything it's
just an inspiration your joy to watch
thank you for being you thank you for
doing the stuff you're doing uh I can't
wait to see what you do next man thank
you so much for talking with me today
that was awesome thank you so much it's
my pleasure
thanks for listening to this
conversation with Tim Dodd to support
this podcast please check out our
sponsors in the description and now let
me leave you some words from H.G Wells
life forever dying to be born afresh
forever young and eager will presently
stand upon this Earth as upon a
footstool and stretched out its realm
amidst the Stars
thank you for listening and hope to see
you next time